THIS MORNING BECAUSE I KNOW FEW
OF THE PRESENTERS- WITH JOINING
AS VIRTUALLY HAVE TO MOVE ON
TO. TWO OTHER ACTIVITIES THIS
MORNING WELCOME TO OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE. SUBCOMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION FINANCE THIS IS
OUR FIRST HEARING IN THE YEAR
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
OUR NEW COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY DENNIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAD SWIMMER
RAMOS HE'S NOSE IS NOT IT. THAT
STAGE HE WAS SORT OF A
DIFFERENT SUB COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR OF COURSE- SO WITH THAT
TODAY IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING THERE ARE NO VOTES BUT
STILL WANT TO TAKE THE ROLE SO
PLEASE TAKE THEM ALL. I'M NOT A
HERO OKAY AND ALSO WERE JOINED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET SHARE-
SEEING A VICE SERVICED FONG SO-
TODAY WE ARE GOING TO START
WITH AN OVERVIEW HEARING OF THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT- BUDGET IN K.
TWELVE IN AND THIS IS A UNIQUE
BUDGET YEAR BECAUSE WE OF
COURSE. FOCUS ON THE BUDGET
YEAR BUT WE HAVE SOME
PROPOSALS. IN THE CURRENT YEAR
WHICH ARE VERY IMPORTANT AND
TIMELY WHICH WILL BE- VOTING ON
IN THE FULL COMMITTEE IN A
COUPLE WEEKS BUT TODAY IS OUR
CHANCE TO HAVE. THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THOSE HEAR AN
OVERVIEW FROM. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND ELADIO
ESPECIALLY ON THE SCHOOL RE
OPENING WHICH I KNOW MANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
COMMENTS AND CERTAINLY. WE'RE
HEARING STUFF BACK HOME OR
DISTRICTS WILL WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES OTHERS WILL BE NO
VOTES TODAY THIS IS PURELY
INFORMATIONAL. WILL VOTE ON THE
FULL BUDGET FOR THE BUDGET
PROPOSES LATER IN THE SPRING.
AND AGAIN WITH ONE OF THESE
CURRENT YEAR PROPOSALS THE
GOVERNOR HAD LAID OUT ON
JANUARY TENTH. IN A COUPLE
WEEKS IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND FOR BUDGET
COMMITTEE. SO OF COURSE. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET- AT
PIVOTED FROM A DEATH LAST TO A
TO A SURPLUS. IN SO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FOCUS ON OUR OUR
SCHOOLS OUR KIDS AND- AND AS
OUR PRESENT UNITED STATES HAS
BEEN SAYING A BILL BACK BETTER.
AND SO THAT'S KIND OF THAT THE
REST OF THIS COMMITTEE THIS
YEAR AND- WHEN OF COURSE FOCUS
ON OUR NEEDIEST STUDENTS AND
LEARNING- DEVELOPMENT RECOVERY
AND GETTING ALL OUR STUDENTS
AND- EDUCATORS BACK TO SCHOOL
SAFELY. A STABILIZING OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM FROM
EARLY AT THROUGH HIGHER AT. ANZ
WELLS ARE CHILD CARE SYSTEMS-
AT TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE
ABOUT THE LARGER PROP NINETY
EIGHT- BUDGET AS WE DISCUSSED.
BUT WE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT THE CURRENT YEAR
PROPOSALS- THIS OF COURSE IS A
UNIQUE- BUDGET. COMMITTEE
PROCESS WITH VIRTUAL
PARTICIPATION- THIS IS I NEED
TO READ THIS FOR THE PUBLIC
LIKE WE ALWAYS DO THEY WERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. WE WILL
HAVE A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
HEARING PERSON- MINIMAL- STAFF
HERE IN IN PUBLIC AS WELL BUT
WE WILL HAVE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE END. EITHER IN PERSON. OR
PEOPLE CAN PARTICIPATE-
REMOTELY- ONE MINUTE PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE WILL ASK ALL OF
OUR- PANELISTS TO MAKE SURE
THEY FOLLOW THE TIME LIMIT AS
WELL. AND SO I WILL BE GIVING
THE THAT THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT LATER IN THE
IN THE- IN THE HEARING BUT WANT
TO GET ON BECAUSE OUR FIRST
PARTICIPANT IS OUR
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION- MISTER TONY
THURMOND- NO STRANGER TO THE
ASSEMBLY. AND HE IS JOINING US
THIS MORNING BUT NEEDS TO MOVE
ON- NINE FIFTEEN NINE TWENTY SO
WE BRING UP MR THURMAN FOR HIS
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. TONY THURMOND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
NOW THE BUDGET- I LIKE TO FIRST
START BY ACKNOWLEDGING OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THEIR EDUCATORS FOR THEIR
RESILIENCE THIS IS CERTAINLY MY
ESTIMATION THE TOUGHEST
EXPERIENCE THE MOST EXPERIENCE
IN OUR LIFETIME I DON'T EAT
UNTIL YOU HEAR FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT MOST OF OUR
SCHOOLS FIND THEMSELVES STILL
IN DISTANCE LEARNING STRUGGLING
TO KEEP STUDENTS SAFE.
STRUGGLING TO DEAL WITH MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES OF THE PANDEMIC-
FIRES UNFORTUNATELY NOW
MUDSLIDES POWER SAFETY SHUT OFF
IN MANY CHALLENGES THAT OUR
STUDENTS. IT'S I KNEW TO
ACKNOWLEDGE- YOUR WORDS OF THIS
BUDGET AND WHAT THIS
OPPORTUNITY CAN MEAN FOR OUR
SCHOOLS THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
OPEN ARE STRUGGLING TO STAY
OPEN THOSE THAT WANT TO BE OPEN
NEED RESOURCES IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES RESOURCES THAT CAN BE
IMPORTANT TO THEM- I COULD BE
TESTING. IN PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT I ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR EFFORTS
PROVIDE TO FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION FUNDS THAT THEY'VE
USED TO PURCHASE COMPUTERS IN
THE THINGS THAT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
IN THE MONTHS SINCE PANDEMIC
ARE ARE OFFICE WORK CLOSELY
WITH OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT CITY
ADDRESS MANY CHALLENGES. LIKE
CLOSING THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WE
WILL COVER THAT- IN THIS
PANDEMIC THAT A MILLION
STUDENTS LACK ACCESS TO HIGH
SPEED INTERNET. ESPECIALLY IN A
RULE COMMUNITIES. WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR INTERNET AND
BROADBAND DOESN'T EXIST- BUT
ALSO IN MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS.
WHICH HAS EXACERBATED
CONNECTION FOR STUDENTS
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
WHO HAVE NOT CHECKED IN- WE
SEEN CHALLENGES IN ATTENDANCE
OUR OFFICE HAS WORKED WITH MANY
OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
IDENTIFY THE STUDENTS. TO TRY
TO PROVIDE THEM SUPPORT MANY OF
THESE FAMILIES WE KNOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH FOOD INSECURITY-
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND OTHER
CHALLENGES AS LOVED ONES MAY
HAVE LOST IT YEAH. AND SADLY
MAYBE EVEN LOST SOMEONE TO
COVERT BUT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR DISTRICTS IN THIS
WAY IN THIS TIME OF. DO YOU
PROVIDE RESOURCE AND WOMEN.
LITERALLY- OVER A HUNDRED. ON
EVERY TOPIC THAT YOU CAN
IMAGINE. INCLUDING HOW TO
DELIVER SOCIAL EMOTIONAL.
RESOURCESTO OUR STUDENTS AND
CONNECTING DISTRICTS WITH
PROVIDERS WHO CAN PROVIDE
DIRECT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SPORTS. YOUR STUDENTS WE KNOW
THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
DEPRESSION HAS BEEN ON THE RISE
YEAH WE KNOW THAT OUR STUDENTS
NEED AS MUCH SUPPORT AS WE CAN
PROVIDE THEM. SPENT A GREAT
DEAL OF TIME TALKING ABOUT HOW
TO STRENGTHEN DISTANCE LEARNING.
YOU KNOW AGAIN COMMENDING OUR
EDUCATORS FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS
TO LEAD IN. BUT IS AN
UNAVOIDABLE FACT THAT FOR MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCE LEARNING GAPS MANY
OF THESE ARE THE SEVEN STUDENTS
FOR WHOM WE WERE TRYING TO
CLOSE. LEARNING GAPS EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THOSE
LEARNING GAP NOW EXACERBATED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND SO WE'VE
PROVIDED GREAT RESOURCES TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND WEBINARS AS RECENT
AS LAST WEEK WITH A THOUSAND
EDUCATORS. SHOWING THEM WAYS TO
MAKE DISTANCE LEARNING BETTER-
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT UNTIL WE
CAN OPEN ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS
THAT THAT IS THE KEY THAT WE'VE
GOT TO. FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
IMPROVE LET'S FACE IT EDUCATION
WAS NOT BUILT TO DELIVER
EDUCATION BY REMOTE. OUR
SYSTEMS WERE BUILT THAT WAY SO
WE'VE GOT PROVIDE MORE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
EDUCATORS SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES
IN THE DEEPEST LEVELS OF FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE CAN. SO
FAMILIES ARE CONNECTED TO OUR
SCHOOLS AND IN THAT WAY WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THESE
WEBINARS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT
ADDITIONAL STEPS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN TAKE TO
ACCELERATE LEARNING AND TO HELP
TO CLOSE LEARNING GAPS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED DURING
THIS CONDEMNED. WE ADDRESS THE
ISSUES AROUND HATE. S. RACES
THAT MANY OUR STUDENTS THAT
WITNESS WE WORKED. TO PROVIDE
GRANT RIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ADDRESS EQUITY GAS. AND TO
PROVIDE WHAT WE CALL EDUCATION.
AND HATE ADDRESSING THINGS LIKE
ANTI SEMITISM AND RACISM- AND
PROVIDING WAYS TO USE EDUCATION
AS AN IMPORTANT. TOOL AND HATE
I WANT TO QUICKLY KNOWLEDGE
SOME OF THE KEY INVESTMENTS. IN
THIS BUDGET. WE APPRECIATE THAT
IT HAS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
INVESTMENT THAT WE HAVE SEEN
EVER. FOR K. TWELVE EDUCATION
INCLUDING THE EIGHTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS. IN PROP NINETY
EIGHT SPENDING. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT OUR
EDUCATOR WORK FORCE- A COLD TO
SUPPORT. THE RISING OF
EDUCATION AND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. I
CANNOT UNDERSCORE MORE FOR YOU
AS YOU DISCUSS AND DEBATE AND
ULTIMATELY BOTH. ON SOME OF THE
ITEMS THAT ARE IN THE BUDGET
INCLUDING SOME OF THE EARLY
ACTION ITEMS. HOW MUCH SUPPORT
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS STILL
MEET. THEY NEED ACCESS TO
CORPORATE TESTING IN PP SO THAT
THEY CAN HAVE THE CONDITIONS TO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE TO REOPEN FOR
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPEN TO
STAY OPEN. I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE THINGS IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT MANY OF YOUR
QUESTION SOME OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT QUESTION. BUT I
CAN TELL YOU THAT UNTIL WE GET
THE VACCINE. THERE'S NOTHING
MORE IMPORTANT THAN PROVIDING
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE US COBIT TESTING. TO
PUT IT IN CONTEXT WE HAVE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPEN ARE
SERVING STUDENTS THAT ARE
SEEING HIGH NUMBERS OF STUDENTS
RETURN TO SCHOOL OFTEN A
CINEMATIC. IMPALA DIFFICULT IN
ORDER FOR US TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS IN THEIR EDUCATORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES OUR SCHOOLS WILL
NEED TO HAVE THOSE RESOURCES
THAT ARE IN THIS PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR EARLY ACTION. FOR
COVERT TESTING AND I WOULD JUST
ECHO THE IMPORTANCE OF DOWN IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS TO COME HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN US. WE ARE
CONTINUING OUR WEB IN OUR
SERIES. ON HOW TO STRENGTHEN
DISTANCE LEARNING. WE ARE.
HAVING A HEARING. ON CLOSING
DIGITAL DIVIDE WE CAN. A NUMBER
HAVE SOLUTIONS. FOR CLOSING THE
BROAD GAP. IN WILL BE WORKING
WITH ALL THE EQUITY ADVOCATES
LIKE A TRUST WEST. IN WOMEN ARE
ON A DRESSING EQUITY GAPS GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF WHAT'S IN THIS
BUDGET THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF. ON HOW
WE SUPPORT OUR THOUSAND
DISTRICTS. CONCLUDE MY REMARKS
HERE AND SUBMIT MYSELF FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SUPERINTENDENT SO YOU DO HAVE
TIME FOR SOME QUESTIONS THAT WE
WERE TOLD YOU HAD TO LEAVE I
KNOW I HAVE A COUPLE AND SOME
OTHER MEMBERS DO AS WELL DO YOU
HAVE TIME. MISTER THURMAN. YES
SIR OKAY- LET ME FOCUS ON YOU
KNOW THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
IN THE SCHOOL THE QUESTION
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT'S-
REOPENING OUR SCHOOLS. AND SO
CERTAINLY. WE SOUGHT YEAH GOOD
NEWS THIS WEEK THE GOVERNOR
ANNOUNCED THAT HE'S LIFTING THE
STAY AT HOME ORDER- MANY
COUNTIES HAVE GONE- YOU KNOW.
ARE ARE STILL IN THE PURPLE BUT
OUR CAR HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND YOU KNOW. THAT I
KNOW MR GALLAGHER ASKED THAT
QUESTION YESTERDAY IS LIKE A WE
HAVE RESTAURANTS OPEN AND-
PEOPLE CAN GO OUTSIDE BUT- WE
CAN'T GO BACK TO SCHOOL- SO. I
THAT I THINK WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT SO. MISTER SUPERINTENDENT
WHAT DO YOU THINK ARE THE
IMMEDIATE. NECESSARY STEPS- TO.
TO GET OUR KIDS. AND EDUCATORS
SAFELY. BACK TO SCHOOL WHETHER
IT'S FALLING IN PERSON A HYBRID
SMALL COHORTS WHAT HAVE YOU.
THIS YEAR I THINK THAT THAT
ACCESS TO ROBUST COVERT TESTING.
IS KEY OBVIOUSLY THE VACCINE IS
THE GAME CHANGER AND IF WE HAD
ENOUGH DOSES TO VACCINATE OUR
EDUCATORS THAT WOULD BE THE
MOST. IMPORTANT EFFECTIVE WAY
TO GET OUR SCHOOLS OKAY WE ALL
KNOW THAT WE JUST DON'T HAVE
THOSE DOSES AND UNTIL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN PROCURE
THEM FOR US- ROBERT S. COLEMAN
NINETEEN TESTING IN CONTACT
TRACING. IS CERTAINLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT. OKAY I KNOW THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE DISCUSSION
OF THE GOVERNOR'S RE OPENING
PROPOSAL IN THAT IT CONTAINS A
PROVISION FOR TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO BE TO GET THE CO PROTECTING
I WOULD SUBMIT THAT THAT IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING I'M EITHER
MANY ELEMENTS WHEN YOU DISCUSS.
HOW WE CAN YOU KNOW ADDRESS
OFFSETTING LEARNING GAPS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE BUT TO
YOUR QUESTION I THINK THE
ACCESS TO KOBE TESTING IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENT THE STAR.
OKAY I'M- FURTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER MEDINA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OUR STATE SUPERINTENDENT
I AM I CORRECT IN UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE STATE'S ALLOCATION TO.
FOOD OR NUTRITION- EXPIRED. AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR. THE WE WORK WITH OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROVIDE MEALS
IT. HUNDREDS OF SITES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE- AND WE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT- WE ALSO
HAVE- WORK CLOSELY WITH OTHER
DEPARTMENTS FOR WHAT'S CALLED-
THE PANDEMIC EBT WHICH PROVIDES
MORE BENEFITS TO FAMILIES- TO
THE EBT PROGRAM- I'M NOT SURE
SPECIFICALLY WHICH ASPECT OF
NUTRITION FUNDING. THAT YOU
REFERRED TO THAT MAY HAVE
EXPIRED BUT IF YOU PUT ME IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GET THAT INFORMATION
TO PROVIDE THAT FOR YOU I HAVE
HERE IN FRONT OF ME THAT THERE
IS NO OF. PROPOSED FOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS BY THE
STATE- IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE. I
WOULD HOPE THAT THE STATE WOULD
WOULD DO SOMETHING ABOUT ABOUT
THAT AS WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOOD AND
NUTRITION TO THE KIDS TO THE
CHILDREN OF DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
GETTING BACK TO ME- HERE MY
STAFF HAS ALREADY SENT ME A
RESPONSE THAT THERE'S A HUNDRED
THIRTEEN MILLION IN THE BUDGET
FOR NUTRITION. THERE HAD BEEN.
A REIMBURSEMENT THAT EXPIRED
BACK IN AUGUST- A NEW HUNDRED
THIRTEEN MILLION IS IN THE
BUDGET FOR NUTRITION RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YES
QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VIA THAT IS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND- GET YOUR AND
RECOMMENDATION AND MEETINGS
HAVE. NEW HERE. I'M TO GET THAT
THE YOU MISTER TO GET TO YOUR
AND RECOMMENDED OF TESTING IS
THERE A SCHOOL OR A DISTRICT
THAT IS CURRENTLY OPEN IN
UTILIZING A COMPREHENSIVE
TESTING PROGRAM THAT'S WORKING
IN FACT HAS PROVEN TO MITIGATE
TRANSMISSION IN SCHOOLS. THE
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
WOULD SAY THAT- PROBABLY LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAS THE MOST ROBUST TESTING
PROGRAM. EVEN WITH THAT TESTING
PROGRAM THEY'VE ACTUALLY GONE
OUT AND CONTRACTED WITH THE
VENDOR. THAT CAN PROVIDE CO THE
TESTING I EVEN WITH THAT
PROGRAM THEY PROJECT THAT ONE
IN THREE STUDENTS HAVE COME TO
THEIR SCHOOL- HOW ARE PONDERED
FOR COVERT. BUT A SYMPTOMATIC
IN SO THE REALLY SPEAKS TO THE
NEED FOR KOBE TESTING TO REALLY
ENABLE SCHOOLS TO BE OPEN NOW I
WILL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
MANY COUNTIES. WHERE SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN OPEN SINCE THE FALL
IN I WOULD SAY IN THEIR
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN MAKE SOME.
I WOULD SAY LET OKAY- NAPA
COUNTY MARIN COUNTY. THEY
CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT. THERE EXT.
BM STAY OPENS THE FALL MINIMAL
ARE INCREASING GREAT EXCEPTION-
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
PLACES LIKE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
WE'VE HEARD STORIES OF. SCHOOLS
OPENING AND THEN HAPPEN TO
CLOSE BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN A COVERT TESTING.
THE RESEARCH THAT WE LOOKED AT
THE NATION AND REALLY
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD- SUGGESTS
THERE AGAIN IT'S THE RESULTS
ARE MIXED SOME COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN. SMALL OR
MINIMIZE THE SPRING- WHEN
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN OPENED OTHERS
HAVE NOT. BY MOST ACCOUNTS WHAT
WE SEE IS OUR BEST EFFORT
DISTINCT OPEN SCHOOLS IN PERSON
IN SMALLER GRADES K. THROUGH
SIX. IN THAT. IT RELATES TO
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL OTHER
THAT CAN BE HIGHER RATES OF
TRANSMISSION AGAIN AND THIS IS
ALL BASED ON RESEARCH I'M NOT
AN EPIDEMIOLOGIST BUT WE'VE
BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH MANY
OF THEM- IN THIS IS WHAT THE
RESEARCH HAS TOLD US. IN THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM MANY
PARK DISTRICTS WHEN THEY SAID
MORE THAN ANYTHING IS THEY WANT
HELP THEY NEED DOLLARS TO GET
ACCESS TO CORRECT I THINK. THEY
WANT ACCESS TO INFORMATION FROM%
HEALTH EXPERTS ON WHAT THE
TESTING INTERVAL SHOULD BE AND
HOW TO GO ABOUT TESTING IN.
CONTEXT RACING TO KEEP EVERYONE
SAFE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD- YES
AND I THINK YOU MISTER
SUPERINTENDENT IF ANYONE WANTS
TO LOOK AT A TESTING PROGRAM
LOOK AT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THE TWO BILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL HE PUT ON
JANUARY THIRTY THAT ACTUALLY
DOES HAVE A TESTING PROGRAM.
THE CADENCE IS ASSOCIATED WITH
YOUR COLOR. RATHER THAN- CASES
CASE RATES ETCETERA. IN YOUR IN
YOUR COUNTY SO THAT THEY THAT
IS A PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE
TESTING PROGRAM THAT HE LAID
OUT. IN HIS IN HIS PROPOSAL
BACK IN JANUARY AND- PEOPLE ARE
BEATING THE WHOLE PROPOSAL UP.
FOR VERY REASONS BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF TESTING IN THERE. IT'S
IN THERE AND AGAIN IT'S
ASSOCIATED. WITH THE COLOR YOUR
COUNTY MAY BE AN- AND THERE'S
MONEY TO- PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH
IF YOU'RE IN THE PURPLE
PROBABLY. MAYBE EVEN TOO MUCH
OF YOUR IN THE L. QUITE FRANKLY
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
THAT TEST REQUIREMENT TO.
PERFORM THE TESTING CANES. AND
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT TESTING
YOU WANNA TALK ABOUT DATA
TRANSPARENCY WITH REGARD TO
COVER CASES. WHICH ARE BOTH
TALKED IN. TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. IN A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE MANNER THANK YOU.
THANK WOULD AGREE WITH THIS
MEMBER. TO WOULD ALLOW FOR MANY
DISTRICTS TO ENGAGE IN A WEEKLY
CALL THE TESTING- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN ADDITION TO THE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS CREATES
REQUIREMENT FOR REPORTING- THAT
DOESN'T CURRENTLY EXIST AND
IT'S SAD TO SAY THAT IN A STATE
WITH THE THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ALL RUN
LOCALLY WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
KIND OF SYSTEMS THAT ALLOW US.
TO HAVE REAL TIME DATA FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE LITERALLY
ARE SURVEYING THROUGH COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS WHO THEN GO TO
THEIR INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT WE WOULD AGREE-
THAT EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
DETAILS OF THE RE OPENING
PROPOSAL WE THINK THAT BY AND
LARGE. THE MOST IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS THAT WE HOPE YOU
WILL SUPPORT IS THE TWO BILLION
DOLLAR. PROJECT THANK YOU AT
WORK WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
AND A MOMENT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ABOUT THAT BUT MAYBE
YOU CAN. YOU CAN A PINE ON THE
FEEDBACK WE'RE GETTING FROM
DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA AS
ABOUT THIS TWO BILLION PROPOSAL
AND- AND WHETHER IT'S WORKABLE
OR NOT AND SOME LARGER
DISTRICTS HAVE HAVE OUTLINED.
SOME FLAWS IN THAT DID NEVER BE
ABLE TO UTILIZE THAT SO DO YOU
HAVE A RESPONSE TO THAT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WE WE'VE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT RAISE CONCERN-
IN THE CONCERNS HAVE RANGED
FROM- FEELING THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH FUNDING- WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT WHICH IS LEGITIMATE WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS AND STAFF THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT- BUT- I DON'T SEE
THAT AS A REASON TO NOT SUPPORT
THE TO THE- BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. AND IT'S A GOOD
START AND IN MANY WAYS. IT'S A
GREAT H. TO MARCH AND WE ARE
STATEREASON I SAY BRIDGE
TOMORROW JUST BECAUSE WE KNOW
WHAT THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED- A HUNDRED DAY
TIMELINE. TO GET SHOOLS OPEN
HAS TALKED ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF MOVING FROM A
HUNDRED MILLION VACCINATIONS. A
DAY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY. NO
MILLION TAX ASIANS. SO WE THANK
THAT- WHY THEIR CONCERNS THE
DOLLAR AMOUNTS. AND WE THINK
THAT THIS IS A BRING. TO WHEN
I'M TAXING DOSES. ARE TASA.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT SOME
HAVE RAISED ABOUT THE TESTING
INTERVAL- I THINK ALSO TIED.TO
FUNDING. BUT BY MOST ACCOUNTS
TESTING WEEKLY OR EVEN EVERY
OTHER WEEK. GIVES US THE
INFORMATION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF WILL BE
STAY. WHEN THEY RETURN TO
SCHOOL A MESSAGE I BELIEVE THAT
THE CONCERN THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED CAN BE ADDRESSED. IN WE
ARE PERSONALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATION BETWEEN SOME OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
CAMPS OFFICE AND MANY OF YOU.
TO TRY TO FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS.
SOME OF THE DETAILS. AND I
THINK WE CAN WORK THROUGH THE
DAY. OF BUT I THINK THAT THE
PROPOSAL- BY AND LARGE- HAS A
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT TO OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND I THINK
THAT THE FEEDBACK WE'RE GETTING
FROM OUR DISTRICTS IS- THEY'RE
HELPING TO SHAPE. AND WE SHOULD
LISTEN TO THEM TO SHAPING US
THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY MEETS THEIR NEEDS
GOING FOR. MR TANG. MR TO
PROTECT A GOOD TO SEE YOU- JUST
THE FULL QUESTION SO- YOUR WITH
A LETTER FROM THE SEVEN LARGEST
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE SAYING
THAT THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
WOULDN'T ALLOW THEM TO OPEN DO
YOU HAVE A SENSE OF- GIVE A
SENSE OF WHAT HOW MANY
DISTRICTS WOULD ACTUALLY BE
OPEN FOR ME IT WOULD BE A SHAME
TO APPROPRIATE THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN NOT SEE
CHILDREN GOING BACK TO SCHOOL.
AND THEN WE IN REGARDS TO THE
SEVEN LARGEST DISTRICTS DO A
SENSE OF WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO-
MOVE THOSE DISTRICTS OR WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE TO ASSIST THOSE
DISTRICTS TO OPEN UP. FIFTY TWO
THE STATE A CERTAIN. AS I UNDER
IT THOSE DISTRICTS HAVE
INDICATED A DESIRE. FOR MORE
STATE STANDARDS CAN BE
ARTICULATED. DOWN OPENING NOW I
SUSPECT THAT THERE'S SOME A BIT
OF A GAP BETWEEN WHAT THE
DISTRICTS ARE ASKING FOR WHAT
HAS BEEN PROVIDED BECAUSE THE
PROPOSALDOES CREATE SOME
STANDARDS IT IT TALKS ABOUT
THAT TESTING INTERVALS THAT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT- TO BE MAY I
STILL THINK THAT THERE'S ROOM
FOR ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION I
BELIEVE THAT MOST DISTRICTS
WOULD AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
FUNDING BUT SOME HAVE SAID.
THAT THE MONEY WOULDN'T BE
ENOUGH WHERE THEY HAD ISSUES
WITH SOME OF THE TIMELINE
DISTRICTS HAVE RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT SOME RECENT GUIDANCE THAT
HAS BEEN PUT OUT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THAT CHANGES WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
FOUR DIFFERENT THAT'S NOT OPEN
TO OPEN BUT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
FROM THE GOVERNOR AND GOVERNOR
STAFF THAT THEY'RE. WORKING TO
ADJUST THOSE. ASPECTS OF THE-
BECAUSE THEY WANT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WANT WITH ANYONE
SEE OUR SCHOOLS BE OPEN SO.
ASSEMBLY MEETING I THINK THAT
IT IS POSSIBLE- TO WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS I KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE HAS
BEEN IN DIRECT CONTACT WITH A
NUMBER OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT RAISE CONCERN- AND I THINK
THAT ALTERNATELY THE PROPOSAL
SHOULD BE SUPPORTED- BUT SOME.
REVISIONS GET MADE TO BEST MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SUPPORTER I THINK THAT'S WHAT
NOT THIS COMMITTEES BEEN SAYING
FOR. FOR QUITE A WHILE THE FACT
WE HAD A HEARING ON IN THE
FALL. WITH THE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND JUST
REITERATING. HOW CRITICAL THOSE
GUIDELINES WERE IN JUST HEARING
FROM. MANY OF OUR OUR SCHOOLS
ON OUR PERCENT WHEN THE LARGE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- STATING HOW
THERE NEED TO BE CLEARER MORE
SPECIFIC MORE DIRECTIVE AND
GUIDANCE FROM DPH AND- I THINK
WILDER MOST RECENT GUIDANCE WAS
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION-
IT'S STILL NOT. QUITE ALL THE
WAY THERE ARE SOME I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
CONTINUES TO BE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE- WITH THE DISTRICTS
TO. REALLY FIND A VERY CLEAR-
DIRECTIVE PATH FORWARD SO THAT
DISTRICTS. CAN CAN KNOW WHAT
DIRECTION TO FOLLOW I THINK
THAT'S ALL THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR GUIDANCE.
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AS
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ON YOUR
STAFF. DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE
THE- RESOURCES TO A PUBLIC
OFFICIAL HELP PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS ON THEIR STAFF THAT
THEY REALLY. ARE LOOKING TO THE
STATE AND ALL THE DIFFERENT
COUNTY ALL COUNTY PUBLIC.
HEALTH OFFICES FOR GUIDANCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I AB TWO
AGREE SO MEMBER TO AND I THINK.
THAT WHAT WHAT THE- FROM OUR
LARGEST DISTRICTS IS TELLING US
IS THAT. REALLY NOONE REALLY
KNOWS HOW TO DO THIS THIS IS A
MOMENT THAT NONE OF US HAVE
BEEN IN BEFORE. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
PUTTING OUT GUIDANCE THEY WILL
ALSO OFFERED THAT THEY WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
TO ANY DISTRICT IT NEEDS MORE
HELP- THEY'VE OPENED UP THE
VALENCIA LAB WHICH HAS WORKED
WITH. MANY OF OUR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS TO. OUTLINE THE
PROCESS FOR HOW TO GET TESTING
IN PLACE ACTUALLY TO HELP IN
PROCESSING COBA TESTING. IN SO
IT'S BUMPY BUT I BELIEVE THAT
WE CAN GET THERE AS LONG AS WE
CONTINUE THE COMMUNICATION AND-
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK FROM
YOU AND- MANY OTHERS IN THE
SPOT. YEAH THANK YOU BEFORE I
GET O AYE MR FONG I JUST
WANTED TO JUMP ON THAT SO WE
HEAR HER I HEARD YOU TALKING
ABOUT- GUIDANCE TESTING
VACCINES ARE VACCINES IS OF
COURSE OUT OF OUR CONTROL A
LITTLE BIT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DISTRIBUTION AND THE
MANUFACTURERS YOU KNOW POPPING
OUT ENOUGH. THAT THAT GUIDANCE
CERTAINLY WE'RE WORKING ON THE
TESTING IS A THING THAT I THINK
IS INTERESTING BECAUSE WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE A MONEY PROBLEM WE
HAVE A- INFUSION OF CASH RIGHT
NOW PROP NINETY EIGHT. IT COULD
EVEN GET MORE THIS NEW FEDERAL-
PACKAGE IF IT GOES THROUGH WHO
KNOWS IF THEY'RE GONNA. ADOPT
WENT PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
PROPOSED BUT THAT'S LIKE.
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLARS WHAT
SO. AND IT'S TO ME THAT THE
TWO. YOU CAN. GET THE OF THEIR-
WITH WE RESOURCE AND SO WELL I
HAVE HEARD ABOUT CATHOLIC
SCHOOLS HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHO
HAVE DONE THIS. AMAZING TESTING
PROGRAM IS EXPENSIVE SO. IT IF
WE HAD THAT RESOURCES TO DO
THAT DID THAT WOULD THAT BE
ENOUGH. TO GET GOING SOONER. IN
YOUR OPINION. YOU KNOW THIS IS
YOUR I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT
THE- INABILITY TO ACCESS
TESTING IT'S ALWAYS BEEN ONE OF
THE BIGGEST BARRIERS TO OUR
SCHOOLS OPENING EVEN GOING BACK
TO THE FALL. IN IN SO WE'VE
ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT TESTING
WAS NEEDED UNFORTUNATELY THE
SURGE HAS. SO AS YOU SAY
VACCINES BE GAMES- BUT UNTIL WE
HAVE IT COVERT TESTING IS THE
WAY TO GO OUT THERE ARE A LOT
OF THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS HAVE FOR
THEIR OWN TASK. LARGER
DISTRICTS HAVE PAID FOR THEIR
OWN CONTRACTS SMALLER DISTRICTS
IN OTHER DISHES JUST DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO SO THEY NEED
SUPPORT- AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
REQUESTED THEY BE OPENING
PROPOSAL IS A WARRANTY. ONE TO
HELP. BITING THAT TESTING YEAH.
THIS O'DONNELL'S A QUICK FOLLOW
UP TO THIS THEY'RE GONNA GO TO
SOME MEMBER FONG YEAH I JUST I
REALLY PROBABLY A COMMENT OR
NOW. MORE ANYTHING ELSE BUT I'D
I WOULD YOU MISTER TO. WOULD BE.
PUSHING LOW COUNTY HEALTH OFF.
TO ENSURE TEACHER ARE KEPT IN
THE- TO. SO WILL GIVE US. L. A.
COUNTY OR LOOKS THEY'RE GOING
JUMP OVER TEACHERS. AND MAYBE
PUSH SOME OF THEM OF ONE B.
ONE. AND VERY PROBLEM THAT'S
GOING TO HINDER ABILITY TO GET
SCHOOLS RE OPEN. HER CHILDREN.
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. SO I HOPE
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE A ROLE IN
THAT I KNOW I BEEN PUSHING ON
THE L. A. COUNTY- HELTER. FOR I
THIS VERY ISSUE. BECAUSE IT
APPEARS SHE'S GOING TO PUSH
TEACHERS. FROM THE ONE THE ONE
SCHEDULE THAT. IS TO BE
DISASTROUS IS GOING TO. VERY
MUCH HAMPER OUR EFFORTS FOR
SCHOOLS THAT'S IT THAT'S
POSSIBLE TO HAVE ACROSS STATE
IS WELL. SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU'RE AWARE THAT NUMBER I
HOPE YOU WOULD PUT ON- LOCAL
DIRECTORS OF HEALTH. ACROSS THE
STATE TO ENSURE THE DO NOT. DO
THAT THANK YOU. CIRCLE BACK
WITH YOU SENATE. OF THE NEST.
AS YOU WE'VE ALWAYS SAID
TEACHERS HAVE BE AT THE FRONT
THE LINE ORDER FOR US HAVE IT
YOU TO GET OUR OKAY. YOU KNOW
AND COUNT WERE SEEN THAT
EDUCATE ARE RECEIVED THE BACKS
IT SHOULD IT'S. I THINK IT WAS
A VERY GOOD MORNING THIS IS
SUPERINTENDENT- JUST TO FOLLOW
UP ON- WHAT MR DONALD I JUST
MENTIONED- IN TERMS OF THE
EDUCATORS AND THE CLARITY OF
THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
VACCINATIONS- WHAT ROLE DO YOU
HAVE IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS KIND OF A UNIFORM
STANDARD I THINK THE GOVERNOR
OUTLINED YESTERDAY IN HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT. IT WOULD BE
ONE A SIXTY FIVE AND UP AND
THEN ONCE THAT WAS COMPLETED
THEN IT WOULD BE EDUCATORS AND
ONE B. IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OR- THE BABY FROM
PLANTS PROVIDE SOME CLARITY FOR
US. IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG IT'S ALSO
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR MADE ANNOUNCEMENTS
THIS WEEK THAT WOULD AGAIN- PUT
TEACHERS IN PLACE TO BE
ACCELERATED IN THE PRIORITY-
ROTATION FOR WHEN. BACK SCENES
CAN. BE PROVIDED FOR THEM IN
SOME COUNTIES THAT IS ALREADY
THE CASE. BUT THAT IS REALLY
DICTATED BY MY AND MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT'S DICTATED
BY. THE AVAILABILITY OF SUPPLY
AND OF SOME HAVE SAID NO- WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE AND THEN COUNTIES
CAN USE IT. EITHER FOR THOSE
WHO ARE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER OR
FOR OTHER PRIORITY GROUPS AND
THAT THAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING.
IN SOME COUNTIES AND SO THE
GOVERNOR'S. ANNOUNCEMENT THIS
WEEK AGAIN PUSH TEACHERS UP
EVEN FURTHER. IN THE PRIORITY A
LINE. AND IF ANYONE HAS ANY
EXAMPLES OF PLACES. WHERE
TEACHERS AREN'T BEING SUPPORTED
IN GETTING ACCESS TO THE
VACCINE WE LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU. TO RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES- I
THOUGHT I THAT CINEMA BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY MISTER ON A AND JUST
THAT WE NEED TO GET A RATES-
ACCESS THE BACK. AND ONE LAST I
MAYBE ON A GOOD. JUMPING TO A
TO TOPIC A TERMS OF- THE
DEFINITION OF WHAT AND ALL.
SCHOOL IS IT SEEMS THAT- AT IT
APPEARS ARE SOME.
INCONSISTENCIES AND IN TERMS OF
THE APPLICATION THE GUIDANCE OF
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE. WERE
FOLLOWING THE GUIDANCE BY CDPH
TO MOVE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
BACK TO CAMPUS- YOU KNOW THE-
YEAH STUDENTS THAT WERE
HOMELESS FOSTER CHILDREN- THE
END OF THE CHILDREN OF OUR
SYSTEM. THAT DOES A SPECIAL
NEEDS BUT THEN IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S A NEW DEFINITION THAT'S
COMING UP WHERE A REAL OPEN
SCHOOL IS HAS TO BE A FULL
CLASS ACROSS ALL STUDENTS OF
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME CLARITY IN
TERMS OF. WHAT IS IT WHAT WOULD
BE THE DEFINITION OF AN OPEN
SCHOOL- FOR ELIGIBILITY OF
WHATEVER THE LEGISLATURE ACTS
ON. FONG I KNOW THAT THIS-
RELATES TO GUIDANCE THAT WAS
PROVIDED MAYBE TWO WEEKS AGO.
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT INADVERTENTLY-
BLOXHAM EFFORTS OF SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. OPEN MORE SCHOOLS
THAT ESSENTIALLY SAID THAT- IF
YOU ALREADY OPEN YOU CAN STAY
OPEN BUT IF YOU WERE NOT OPEN
AND YOU COULDN'T MEET CERTAIN
CONDITIONS THAT YOU WOULDN'T
OPEN WE HELD A MEETING IN. MY
OFFICE ALL THE MEETING WITH A
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND-DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH IN
THIS CAME UP AS  TOP CONCERN-
I CAN TELL YOU THAT I KNOW
THAT- THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. ARE
WORKING FOR WAYS TO ADJUST THAT
THEY DON'T WANT THERE TO BE ANY
BARRIER TO SCHOOL BEING ABLE TO
OPEN I BELIEVE THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO KEEP- CLARITY AROUND
KEEPING SMALL COHORTS IN
KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE. AND THEY
ARE AWARE OF THIS CONCERN AND-
WE BROUGHT TO THEIR ATTENTION
DIRECTLY. BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD
IT FROM MY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS IN I BELIEVE.
THAT THEY'RE WORKING TO SOLVE
IT. I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT
THAT'S A- THAT THAT'S ONLY
WELCOME NEWS I A LOT OF- SCHOOL
THIS AT LEAST AND IN IN MY
COUNTY IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WE'RE TRYIG TO FOLLOW THE
GUIDANCE AND NOW- ARE. WOULD BE
PUNISHED IF IT WAS A NEW
DEFINITION SO I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOU LOOK INTO THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU. SIMON FONG
AND WE TALKED OFTEN THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY FOR YOUR SCHOOLS IN
YOUR FAMILIES. IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED IN THIS WAY
PLEASE LET'S. SHARE THAT WITH
ME WE'RE HAPPY TO. RAISE THAT
CAN LIFT IT UP THE MORE
EXAMPLES WE HAVE AND THE MORE
CONTEXT WE HAVE. I THINK THE
BETTER THAT THAT ADJUSTMENTS TO
THE GUIDANCE CAN BE MADE. SO AS
YOU SAY THERE WON'T BE ANY
BARRIERS TO THEIR OPENING. I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT NOW
TAKE YOU UP ON THE OFFER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER
MEDINA. YEAH I JUST GOT INTO
THE CONVERSATION HERE- JUST.
SOME EXPERIENCE FROM MY
DISTRICT- MY HOME SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS STILL CLOSED- YOU
KNOW- IT'S COMPLETELY ON
DISTANCE LEARNING- BUT I HAVE
MANY PUBLIC SCHOOLS ACTUALLY
THAT HAVE OPENED IN THE
DISTRICT- AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DO SO SAFELY AND- AND- THERE'S
BEEN VERY LIMITED. CASES- A
MARKS SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN
OPEN THEY'VE BEEN OPEN VERY
SUCCESSFULLY EVEN WITHOUT A
ROBUST CADENCE I MEAN I DON'T I
GUESS WE NEED TO DEFINE WHAT
THAT TERM IS- BUT AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. STATED THERE IS
TESTING AVAILABLE AND SCHOOLS
ARE TESTING- YOU KNOW IT AS
PART OF THEIR PROGRAM WHAT THEY
CAN DO AND WHAT'S FEASIBLE- AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT YOUR
VERY SUCCESSFULLY THUS FAR- I'M
REALLY AWARE OF ONLY ONE.
OUTBREAK AT A LOCAL SCHOOL IT
DID NOT BECOME SOME KIND OF
LARGE SPREADING EVENT IT WAS
CONTAINED IN THE AND THEY YOU
KNOW. WERE ABLE TO GET THE KIDS
BACK INTO SCHOOL WITHOUT
WITHOUT ANY ISSUES SO I THINK
TO SOME EXTENT YOU KNOW THE YES
WE'D HAVE TESTING BUT IT'S GOT
TO BE SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
FEASIBLE FOR THE SCHOOL TO BE
ABLE TO DO- I HEAR A LOT OF IF
IT'S A WEEKLY TESTING
REQUIREMENT THERE'S MANY
SCHOOLS ARE JUST NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT- FEASIBLY-
SO I MEAN NOTE I THINK WE JUST
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT WHAT
HAS BEEN THE EXPERIENCE YOU
KNOW HOW. HAVE WE BEEN ABLE TO
DO THIS SAFELY ALREADY I THINK
THE ANSWER IS ACTUALLY YES- AS
FAR AS VACCINES AND HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT THERE IS A
DISPARITY RIGHT NOW SOME
SCHOOLS SOME COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MOVE FOR WITH VACCINES-
SCHOOL STAFF AND TEACHERS.
WHEREAS OTHERS HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO AND JUST TO SHED A
LITTLE BIT MORE LIGHT ON THIS
BECAUSE THIS NEEDS TO BE
BROUGHT TO LIGHT. IS TEACHERS
AND EDUCATION. STAFF WERE
ALWAYS IN ONE B. I SINCE THIS.
VACCINATION ROLLOUT WAS
ESTABLISHED THEY HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN ONE B. THAT HAS NOT CHANGE
WHAT CHANGE WAS LAST WEEK THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WAS
TELLING LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS. THAT THEY NEEDED TO
DO SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER FIRST
AS A PRIORITY BEFORE YOU MOVED
INTO ONE B. AND THEY WERE IN
FACT SAYING THAT AND SO PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS STARTED
TELLING EDUCATORS. AND
EDUCATION STAFF AND TEACHERS
THAT HEY WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO VACCINATE TO. UNTIL WE
DO SIXTY FIVE PLUS THAT'S A
FACT. AND THEN YESTERDAY THE
GOVERNOR REVERSE COURSE AND
STARTED SAYING NO THAT'S
ACTUALLY NOT TRUE- YOU CAN DO
THEM BOTH AT THE SAME TIME- BUT
HIS PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
WAS TELLING. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS LAST WEEK THEY COULD
NOT DO THAT. THAT HAD THE
EFFECT OF DELAYING IT AND NOW
SOME PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS.
ARE STICKING TO THAT POLICY AND
SAYING THEY WILL NOT MOVE INT
ONE B. UNTIL THEY HAVE
COMPLETED THE SIXTY FIVE PLUS.
CATEGORY AND THAT GOES TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL'S
POINT WHICH IS WE NEED TO BE
PUSHING OUR- PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS SAY HEY YOU CAN DO
BOTH GROUPS. AND THAT WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE EDUCATION A
PRIORITY. AS THESE ARE FRONT
LINE WORKERS EDUCATION IS
ESSENTIAL. AND THEY SHOULD BE
PART OF THAT SO. THESE ARE THE
KIND OF ISSUES THAT WERE HAVING
TO WORK THROUGH YOU KNOW AGAIN
IT'S A KIND OF A MIXED MESSAGE
COMING OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION- AND NOW THE
POSSIBILITY OF SOME COUNTIES.
BEING ABLE TO VACCINATE THEIR
IS- SCHOOL STAFF. WHILE OTHERS
ARE NOT ABLE TO AND THAT'S
GOING TO CREATE A FURTHER
DISPARITY IN EDUCATION. BECAUSE
THOSE THOSE COUNTIES WILL BE
ABLE TO MOVE FOR WITH IN PERSON
EDUCATION WHILE OTHERS. MAY BE
FURTHER DELAYED AND THAT TO ME
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO. REALLY ADDRESS. VERY
QUICKLY AND IMMEDIATELY. THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GO I'M SURE
THAT THE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL WANT
TO AMPLIFY. THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE VACCINE I THINK THE
DISPARITY HAS TO DO WITH EACH
COUNTY. HAS RECEIVED A DOSE IS
DIRECTLY- FROM THE FEDERAL FROM
THE CC IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOT FROM THE STATE
EACH COUNTY. HAS MADE DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO USE SURPLUS IF
THEY HAVE INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WHO FOR
WHATEVER REASON CHOOSE NOT TO
USE THE VACCINE AND SO THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED
FLEXIBILITY- TO. AND ALLOW
EDUCATORS TO RECEIVE THAT
VACCINE IT HAS ALSO ALLOWED
FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE THOSE
WERE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER TO
GET THE VACCINE S. AS THEY
SHOULD GIVEN THAT THOSE WERE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST CASES OF
COINFECTION- TAKE PLACE- IN IN
MOST SERIOUS CONDITIONS. AND SO
WE AGREE WITH YOU WE MUST
PRIORITIZE EDUCATORS THEY ARE
AT THE FRONT OF THE LINE THERE
AND THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN ONE B.
AS YOU SAID- BUT EVERY COUNTY
HAS. ITS OWN WAY OF
DISSEMINATING THE VACCINE AND
THEN A GUY SAYS CHANGE IN SO
THERE ARE THOSE WHO NEED SOME
HELP UNDERSTANDING THAT
EDUCATORS STILL ARE- AT THE TOP
OF THE LINE FOR AVAILABLE DOSES
WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU.
AND OTHERS IN THIS BODY- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE AWARE
OF THAT. THANK YOU OUT LET'S
MOVE ON BECAUSE I KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM WE CAN ENGAGE
THEM ON THIS ON THIS TOPIC AS
WELL- SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
SUPERINTENDENT AND WE'LL SEE
YOU SOON HOPEFULLY IN PERSON-
AND IN THE FUTURE HOLD ON. ME
YES MR GONNA START. THANK YOU-
MISTER SUPER AND- AS A FORMER
TEACHER. AND FORMER SCHOOL
BOARD- VERY MUCH WANT TO SEE
YOU KNOW SCHOOLS GO BACK. IN
PERSON. BUT MY QUESTION TO YOU
IS. WHERE DOES THE ULTIMATE
AUTHORITY. TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS FOR STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE FOR SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN. ALLY WHO WILL MAKE THAT
DECISION WHO HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO MAKE THAT DECISION. THANK
YOU SOME REMEMBER DINA YOU KNOW
AS A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER- I'M A FORMER SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER THAT ALTERNATELY
THE AUTHORITY FOR OPENING
DECISIONS SLICE WITH THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE HAVE OVER
ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
EACH WITH THEIR OWN SCHOOL
BOARD WHICH IS THEIR OVERNING
BODY TO MAKE THEIR DECISIONS.
NOTHING ABOUT WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN THE STATE HAS TAKEN AWAY THE
DECISION MAKING OF LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
EVERY LEVEL OUR OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH WE TRY TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE TO HELP
GUIDE THAT. LIKE THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE TO HELP DISTRIBUTE
THE P. P. ACROSS. OUR STATE WE
WORKED WORTH FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS TO HELP THEM
DISSEMINATE THAT BUT WE WILL
TELL THEM HOW TO DISSEMINATE
THAT. WE DON'T TELL THEM WHEN
THEY OPEN- AND SO AGAIN THAT
POWER ALWAYS HAS RESTED WITH
THE LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS- TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS- BUT OUR
OFFICE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE DOES
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN. LET
RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE AND
SUPPORT TO HELP THEM IN MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS. THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU NOW
LET'S MOVE ON AND WE'LL GET TO
OUR OUR FIRST- PRESENTATION
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE HAVE I THINK WE SAW JESSICA
HOLMES SHE HAD TO RUN WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND IT AT A MEETING IF
NOT WE'LL HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STEP
IN. THAT CORRECT. CORRECT I'M
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JUST GO HOME DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- I WON'T GO TOO
DEEPLY INTO DETAIL ON OUR
PROPOSAL AROUND- IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AS IT YOU KNOW IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT YOU'LL HAVE AN
EXCELLENT UNDERSTANDING OF IT-
BUT JUST TO REITERATE AND THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS MORE THAN SIX POINT
SEVEN BILLION TO ENABLE QUICK
TO MITIGATE CODED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IMPACTS. ON STUDENTS
AND STAFF AND PROVIDED SCHOOLS
WITH GUIDANCE AND RESOURCES- TO
MAXIMIZE STATE AND PERSONAL
SERVICES TO STUDENTS. HOWEVER
AT THE PANDEMIC PROGRESSES IN
AT THE SCIENCE CENTER STANDING
UP CODE NINETEEN INCREASES- WE
UNDERSTAND IT MUST BE ADAPTABLE
TO OUR CIRCUMSTANCES AND GIVEN
OPPORTUNITIES TO STEM THE
IMPACT. OF THE PANDEMIC ON OUR
CHILDREN. AND TO THAT END THE
IN. IS AT THE IT POPPED SAFETY
GUY FOR PERSON. AND RECOGNITION
THAT MASKING SOCIAL DISTANCING
CO COURTING. AND OTHER KEY
MEASURES ARE EXCELLENT
SAFEGUARDS TO MINIMIZE VIRUS
SPREAD AND CAN OFFER PATHWAYS
TO SCHOOLREOPENING EVEN IN
COMMUNITIES WHERE RATES OF
COMMUNITY SPREAD ARE HIGH- WE
ARE. IMPROVING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
SCHOOLS. IN PUTTING HEALTH
SAFEGUARDS INTO PLACE. MAKING
IT EASIER FOR EDUCATION
MINISTRY URGED TO GET ONE ON
ONE GUIDANCE FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS. AN ACCESS CODE IN
NINETEEN TESTING. AND MAKING IT
EASIER FOR SCHOOL STAFF AND
COMMUNITY TO OLDER PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS BUT HEALTH
CONDITIONS AT SCHOOL CONCERNED
THEM- WE KNOW THAT FURTHER
FORWARD PROGRESS REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND TO
THAT END THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO BILLION FOR
IMMEDIATE ACTION FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT. ANY GRANTS
ARE INTENDED TO BUILD ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INVESTMENTS AS WELL AS SIX
BILLION IN FEDERAL ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY SCHOOL EMERGENCY
RELIEF FUNDS THAT WILL SOON BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO SCHOOLS. THE
GRANT FROM TWENTY FIVE AND FUND
TAKE THE OPENING FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN THE
STATE INCLUDING CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE SINCE
DISABILITIES IN THE STATE'S
YOUNGEST LEARNERS. BRICOLAGE
OCCASIONAL AGENCIES ARE ELEAZAR
RELATIVELY LOW COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION RATE THAT PLANS IN
PLACE FOR STATE THINKFREE
OPENING WE'LL GET RISKY
PROPORTIONALLY. LARGER GRANT
NOW. UNDER THIRTEEN PLANNING
TIME TO STILL APPLY AND RECEIVE
FUNDING AS NO LOWER BUT
SIGNIFICANT RATE. ALIANT AT
HIGHER TREND RATE ALSO FOR GRAN
ON EITHER. AND RECEIVED GRANTS
AND BUT ARE NOT REQUIRED REOPEN
INCREASED INSTRUCTION UNTIL
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION RATES
DECLINE. I'M I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE- OBVIOUSLY MR THURMAN- WHO
HAS DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB IN IN
DESCRIBING AND THEN AFTER A LOT
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU. YOU
POSED TO HIM AND JUST WANT TO
THANK HIM FOR ON THE EXCELLENT
WORKING THE STOCK FOR DEALING
TO SUPPORT- YES SHOULDN'T
GETTING BACK INTO SCHOOL AND AN
IMPROVING DISTANCE LEARNING- ED
THAT'S HAPPENING FOR THOSE WHO
CAN'T COME BACK. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. YES I. SO DO YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE MISS HOLMES- PLEASE STAND
BY TEN THIRTY. YEAH OKAY GOOD
SO- I KNOW WE TALKED A LOT WITH
MR THURMAN ABOUT THIS BUT YOU
OF COURSE HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S
VOICE HERE. AND THIS IS OUR
FIRST TIME THAT TALKING ABOUT
THIS BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
OUR OUR COUNTERPARTS IN THE
SENATE. HAD A ROBUST HEARING
LAST WEEK AND DOG REALLY INTO
THIS ISSUE AND THERE WAS SOME
INDICATION THAT THERE IS GOING
TO BE. A REVISED- PLAN WITH
THIS TWO BILLION TO ADDRESS.
SOME OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
ISSUES SOME OF THE SCHOOL
CONCERNS AND OF COURSE WILL BE
VOTING ON THAT IN THE FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE. SOON BUT YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A CHIP I WAS
A TEST OF THAT SO DO YOU HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO. EXPAND ON
WHAT ELEMENTS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
TWEAKING WITH THAT PLOT
PROPOSAL. ABSOLUTELY AMBER
SPEAKING WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH AND BOTH YOUR STAFF AND
STAFF FROM THE SENATE. I'M TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AROUND-
TIMELINE OBVIOUSLY THE FEBRUARY
FIRST TIME LINE IS COMING UP
VERY QUICKLY HERE SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT. MAY NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED- AS WELL AS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FEASIBILITY-
AROUND THAT CASTING CADENCES-
ALTHOUGH ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE THAT MINIMUM
CASTING IN THERE TO ENSURE
HEALTH AND SAFETY- AND THEN.
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS RUN
IMPLEMENTATION- AND HOW THAT
COULD BE IMPACTING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE ALREADY.
OPENED AND WHO HAVE SHOWN A
TRACK RECORD OF- YOU KNOW
TRANSMISSION SO AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE- WE'VE HEARD FROM
MANY MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AS
WELL AS CHARTER SCHOOLS. YEAH
VEGETATION AND THEN AS WELL THE
CONCERN OF MEMBERS AND WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO WORK HARD WITH
YOUR STAFF TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE. THE WORKABLE- SOLUTION
THAT REALLY PRIORITIZE BRING.
CAN ACT IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
YEAH AND I DO OPEN RIGHT HERE
WE'RE HEAR FROM LA- BUT- MAYBE
YOU CAN JUST READ RISK. YOU
KNOW YOU LOOK LOOK AT. DOT BALL
AT THE NAY THAT PROPOSED AND-
TO IN PER INSTRUCTION SO HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS WHAT THE L. A. O.
HAS BROUGHT UP. GIVEN THE LACK
OF A DETAIL ON THAT IT'S A
LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT TO RESPOND
TO HOWEVER- I WOULD SAY THAT
YOU KNOW IN THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING WITH
DOZENS UPON DOZENS OF ELEAZAR-
WE'RE WE'RE DEFINITELY MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THEIR SPECIFIC
BARRIERS AND CHALLENGES. SO
THAT WE CAN TWEAK OUR PROPOSAL
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT ALIGNS- TO
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE- AND- YOU
KNOW I WOULD JUST POINT TO THE
FACT THAT ALTHOUGH MANY MANY
FOLKS HAS HAS QUESTIONED
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO GET. OF OUR PROPOSAL ARE
FEASIBLE. THERE ARE AT LEAST IN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO ARE DOING
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING NOW AND REALLY
WHAT WE HAVE IN OUR GUIDANCE
OUR- BEST PRACTICES THAT THAT'S
FINE AND THAT FOLKS WHO ARE
HAVE BEEN IN THE FIELD DOING
THIS WORK. AND SHOWING THAT IT
WORKS AND HOW TO HAS HAS PUT
FORTH AN IMPALA SO. I DON'T
NECESSARILY AGREE THAT THAT
IT'S UNLIKELY TO RESULT INQUIRY
OPENING OBVIOUSLY RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
CHANGES. ON SOME OF THE DETAILS
OF THE PLAN TO MAKE IT MORE
FEASIBLE- BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
IF BOTH CAN AND WILL RESULT IN
INCREASING FOCUS SAFETY OF IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION.
AVAILABILITY IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. YEAH AND THEN.
THIS IS THE VACCINES AS I SAID
EARLIER ARE OUT OF OUR CONTROL
BASED UPON WHAT WE'RE GETTING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
THE MANUFACTURERS BUT ONE
THING. I THINK WE COULD
ADDRESSES THAT IS THE TESTING.
AND I'VE HEARD FROM LOCAL AS
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER SCHOOLS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND HOW MUCH THEY ARE
SPENDING ON TESTING BUT MONEY
IS NOT THE PROBLEM WE HAVE.
INFUSION OF ONE TIME I IN THIS
BUDGET FOR REVENUES COMING IN
THE FIRST FEDERAL PACKAGE THE
SECOND ONE. SO WHAT COULD WE DO
TO NOT LESSER AND I USED TO
PROVIDE CASH OR THE PROMISE TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW I
MEAN. LAST YEAR OF THE DIESS WE
HAVE TO BUY. OR NOT WE HAVE TO
BUY BUT THEY HAD TO BUY THESE
TESTS THAT WE. TAKE THE INSTANT
TEST WHATEVER THERE ARE THINK
THEY'RE THIRTY BUCKS A TE WOULD
HAVE YOU- BUT- WHY WE HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY IT'S- AND- MORE
COMING IN. TO JUST FRONT AND
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
PURCHASE THESE. IS THAT AT ALL
IN THIS SCENARIO BECAUSE IT
WOULD BE A SHAME. TO GET THE
FEDERAL MONEY IN A FEW WEEKS
WE'RE HERE IN MARCH BUT- WE
FINALLY HAVE THE MONEY FEDERAL
MONEY WE'RE GONNA PUT OUT TO
DISTRICTS IN MAY AND THEN THE
SCHOOL YEAR IS OVER. SO YOU
KNOW WHAT CAN WE DO TO ADDRESS
THIS NOW. THAT'S A GREAT POINT
AND- I'M JUST IT JUST CAN'T
BUILD ON WHAT YOU YOU SAID MR
MCCARTY AND- WE DO HAS. AT
LEAST WE HAD AT APPROVED BOTH
THE ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
HAVE APPROVED- THE ALLOCATION
AT SIX BILLION OF THE SIX POINT
SEVEN BILLION ALLOCATED TASK
GROUPS. ON THE SECONDS. THAT
CARED BACK. I THINK IT'S THE C.
R. R. ESSAY. ON THE FEDERAL
RELIEF BILL THAT JUST CAME OUT-
AND THAT WE HAD JUST SENT THAT.
OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO THEY CAN GET
STARTED. ON ALLOCATING THOSE
FUNDS DIRECTLY TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF THE FUND SHOULD BE
COMING RIGHT AWAY- I THINK IN
TERMS OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT'S WHERE YOU ALSO SEE
SPENT. ON URGENCY AROUND THIS
TWO BILLION PROPOSAL TO INFUSE
MORE FUNDS INTO THE SYSTEM- BUT
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL PATENT
FILED. IT'S INTERESTING I THINK
THE INITIAL REACTION OF MANY
FOLKS- FROM ELEAZAR COULD NOT
PARTICIPATED IN TESTING YET-
AND ACTUALLY THERE ARE QUITE A
FEW THAT HAPPENING. YOU KNOW WE
TALKED TO THE SEVEN LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND- YOU KNOW
A LOT OF THEM SAID YOU KNOW
WE'VE WE'VE GOT TESTING
PROGRAMS IN PLACE ALREADY- SO A
LOT OF. A LOT OF AT LEAST HAVE
BEEN PARTICIPATING- BUT IT FOR
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T BEEN IT SEEMS
VERY OVERWHELMING HOWEVER WHEN
WE HAD INDIVIDUAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH THOSE ELEAZAR. AND WALK
THEM THROUGH THE PROCESS AS A
WORKING WITH THE VALENCIA LAB-
IT BECOMES VERY CLEAR VERY
QUICKLY THAT IT'S ACTUALLY MUCH
MORE DOABLE- BUT A LOT OF. A
LOT OF AT LEAST THINK IT IS
THAT WE REALLY RECOMMEND AND
ENCOURAGE FOLKS. TO REACH OUT
THROUGH OUR SAFE SCHOOLS. AND
WEBSITE- AND- AN AFTER
QUESTIONS AND GET CONNECT UP
WITH THE- JULY BECAUSE- AND
IT'S REALLY BEEN SO UP TO BE.
SCHOOL THIS. AND TRY SCHOOLS-
CAN REALLY PROVE ACTUAL OPTIONS.
FOR WHO NEED TO GET STARTED ON
THEIR TESTING. NOW OKAY THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER REST. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. WE KNOW THAT
THE JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL
ASSUMES IN PERSON LEARNING FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO SCHOOL YEAR AND IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE ANY EXTENSIONS. OF WHAT
IS CURRENTLY IN THE DISTANCE
LEARNING EDUCATION CODE WHICH
IS SET TO EXPIRE IN JULY. WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE NEED TO CONTINUE
WITH DISTANCE LEARNING IN THE
FALL BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY WHAT
ARE. OUR CONTINGENCY PLANS AND
HOW WILL THE ADMINISTRATION
ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK OF ACTION
FOR THIS SCENARIO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THE PHONE NUMBER
IS FOR THAT QUESTION AND IT'S
AN EXCELLENT ONE WE'VE ALREADY
HEARD FROM ELEAZAR WHO HAVE
BEEN- TALKING TO THEIR FAMILIES
ABOUT OPTIONS FOR SCHOOL IN THE
FALL AND THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERN THAT- THERE WON'T IT
WON'T BE AMONG FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES THAT IT WON'T BE
SAFE TO RETURNED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION OF PAUL AND I THINK
OUR RESPONSES IS TWO FOLD. THE
WINE- YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND WE- NEED TO HAVE A
CONTINGENCY PLAN IN PLACE FOR
THE FALL- AND YOU KNOW. WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING ON GETTING
STUDENTS BACK AS EARLY AS WE
CAN NOW THAT WE INTEND TO START
HAVING A CONVERSATION WITH I'M
LEGISLATIVE STAFF MEMBERS HAD
COMMUNITY GROUPS ELEAZAR- IN IN
THE COMING WEEKS VERY SOON
CARE- BUT THE SECOND PIECE IS.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT WERE
HELPING COMMUNITIES UNDERSTAND
THAT TO BE A SAFETY PROTOCOLS I
THINK THE GUIDANCE THAT WE
HAVE- RECENTLY PUT OUT WILL
KEEP FAMILIES AND TEACHERS
STATE. FARM IN THE CLASSROOMS
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AND
CAN'T AND CAN BE DONE IN A SAFE
MANNER AND I THINK THAT. THAT
BUILDING THAT TRUST AND IS A
REALLY KEY PIECE- SO HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD AT THE
STATE- IN OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
BUT I THINK BOTH OF YOUR YOUR
POINT SIR ARE ARE WELL TAKEN
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO WORK
ON AND. WE HAVE PLANS TO DO SO
IN THE COMING WEEKS. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY FOR. GAL AND
THEN- DON- I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR THANK YOU SO TOPPING
UP. I GUESS- IN MY QUESTION IS
THE WHAT THE SAME QUESTION I
POSED- TO SUPERJET THURMAN
WHICH IS THIS. REDEFINITION OF
THE INCONSISTENCIES IN WHAT IS-
WHAT IS DEFINED AS A RE OPENED
SCHOOL WHETHER THE SCHOOL NEEDS
TO SERVE THE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS OR WHETHER A
SCHOOL- HAS TO RE OPEN A FULL
CLASS SIZE ACROSS ALL STUDENTS
HAD TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES COULD YOU
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY OF FROM
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE-
REPEATING THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF WHAT. IS OCCURRING WHAT IS
THE GOVERNOR'S PERSPECTIVE IS
ON THAT AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD.
CERTAINLY SO I THINK WHAT YOU
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS
THAT THE CURRENT PROPOSAL
CURRENT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WE'VE PUT OUT- SAID THAT
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE FUNDS YOU
MUST BE OPENED BY A CERTAIN
DATE. I MEAN YOU MUST RE OPEN
Q. AND PACIFIED YOU KNOW
VULNERABLE GROUPS AS WELL AS-
CAPE GROUP FIVE OR SIX
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOUR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL GRADES AND-
AND- AND SO THAT'S THE CURRENT
PROPOSAL WE HAVE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF- ELEAZAR ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT HAVE ALREADY OPENED
OR ALREADY HAD PLANS IN PLACE.
FOR A TIERED REOPENING ON
THIRTIETH SOME DISTRICTS MAY
HAS- PLAN THAT BY FEBRUARY
FIRST. AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAS
YET SHE CAME IN FIRST GRADE IN
PLACE AND THEN. YOU KNOW BY BY
APRIL THEY'LL HAVE YOU KNOW
GRADES TWO THREE FOUR AND FIVE
INCH SO IT'S NOT EXACTLY THE
SAME AS AS THE PLAN THAT. WE
PUT OUT AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH A LOT OF
EARLY AGE. TRYING TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND- WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL
SITUATIONS ARE CERTAINLY NOT
OUR INTENT. TO CLOSE SCHOOLS
MORE- OBVIOUSLY UNLESS THERE'S
YOU KNOW AN OUTBREAK OR OR
STURGEON INFECTIONS- AND SO IT
BUT IT DIFFICULT RIGHT. ACROSS
AN ENTIRE STATE WITH MORE THAN
A THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
CREATE A SINGLE POLICY- THAT
ADDRESSES EVERY POTENTIAL-
SITUATION SO WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING RIGHT NOW WE'RE TALKING
WITH. AND STAFF FROM BOTH
HOUSES AND AS WELL AS ELLIE
EIGHT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE NEEDS ARE SO THAT WE CAN-
PUT OUT A POLICY THAT MAKES
SENSE FOR EVERYONE AND ENSURES
YOU KNOW KIDS CAN STILL REMAIN
IN SCHOOL AND IT'S SAFE-
ENCIRCLED. SIXTEEN FORD WITH
THIRTEEN THE CLAIMS AT THE
HOUSE SURE. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND I WOULD
ALSO ENCOURAGE OF COURSE- TO
ALLOW SOME FLEXIBILITY AND OF
COURSE ALLOW LOCALS TO DICTATE
THOSE DECISIONS SO I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- YOU ARE A RESPONSE.
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU. THANK YOU SOME MEMBER GALA.
YEAH AN IMMEDIATE I THAT THAT
THE KINDA AVOIDED WHICH IS-
LAST YEAR YOU GOT. YOUR PROJECT
ON. WERE OFF AND THAT WAS THE
BASIS FOR DOING DEFERRALS. WHY
ARE WE NOT- PAIN DOWN DEFERRALS
WITH THEIR ONE TIME MONEY RIGHT
NOW THAT SCHOOLS NEED RIGHT NOW.
YEAH THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION AND ONE OF YOU'VE
GOTTEN SEVERAL TIMES ALREADY
THANK YOU NUMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER AND SO THERE'S
A COUPLE OF ISSUES AROUND
DIFFER ALSO WON THE FIRST
PIECES- WE HAVE NOT FINALIZED
REVENUES FOR IT BUT THE CURRENT
YEAR AND THE BUDGET YEAR-
THERE'S STILL QUITE A BIT AS- A
FLEXIBILITY IN THE AFFECTED BY
POSSIBLY. THERE COULD STILL BE
QUITE A BIT OF VOLATILITY IN
THOSE AND WE'RE NOT A 100%
LOCKED DOWN ON WHAT THAT COULD
BE I'M LOOKING FORWARD SO IT
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A
PROPOSAL AND THAT WE JUST DON'T
KNOW AT WHAT OUR FINAL REVENUES
ARE GOING TO BE. STEP ONE
PIECES THE UNCERTAINTY THE
SECOND PIECE IS THAT AND FOR
THOSE ELEAZAR WHO HAS- GONE OUT
FOR TRANS WHICH ARE SHORT TERM
CASH LOAN AND THAT THEY OFTEN.
TAKE ON DURING THAT TIME THE
DEFERRAL- IT EAT EARLY PAYOFF
COULD RESULT IN PENALTIES- AND
OR TAX IMPLICATIONS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND I WOULD HAVE
TO DEFER FOR SPECIFICS. ON CUE
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAVE
MORE INFORMATION AROUND THAT
BUT ESSENTIALLY- ELLIE A IS NOT
ALLOWED TO TAKE OUT A TREND
THAT IS BEYOND WHAT- IT'S
ACTUAL NEED IS SO IT COULD
CREATE COMPLICATIONS IN THE
FIELD TO THE EXTENT THAT WE-
TRY TO PAY OFF- DEFERRALS.
BEFORE WE ACTUALLY DEFERRED
THEN. AND SO. THAT'S ANOTHER P.
AND THEN THE FINAL P. ISSUES
AROUND CASH DEPENDS FOR THIS-
THAT CASH FLOW WITH SOME. THAT
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
AND NATURE THAT WE CAN DO IN
OUR SPA. WAY SO THERE ARE OTHER
COMPLICATIONS AROUND THAT AND
THAT YOU KNOW AT THIS POINT IN
TIME WHERE WE ARE IN THIS WHOLE
PROCESS- IT DOES NOT SEEM WIDE.
TO PAY THOSE OFF EARLY. OKAY
WELL WITH A FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR WINDFALL AND SIX BILLION
COMING IN FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I THINK WE CAN MAKE
OUR SCHOOLS HOLE ON TO PAYMENTS
I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT I'LL
GO INTO A- YEAH YOU WANT TO
MORE SPECIFICS I THINK WHY THE
L. A. O. IS SAYING THAT YOUR RE
OPENING PLAN AN INCENTIVE GRANT
IS ON WORKABLE. IS BECAUSE OF A
FEW THINGS AND ALL THIS LIST
SOME OF THEM ONE IS YOU HAVE A
FEBRUARY ONE FILE DATE WE
HAVEN'T EVEN COMPLETED THIS
EARLY ACTION ITEM SO HOW ARE
THEY GONNA APPLY FOR MONEY NEXT
WEEK. AND THEN THEY HAVE TO BE
OPEN BY MID. FEBRUARY YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR'S GOT A BLUEPRINT
IN PLACE THAT SAYS IF YOU
DIDN'T REOPEN YOUR SCHOOL IN
THE FALL YOU CAN'T REOPEN UNTIL
YOU GET OUT OF PURPLE TEAR.
UNLIKELY THAT MANY OF THESE
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE IN RED
DEER BY THAT TIME HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO RE OPEN- SO I MEAN
THAT THAT'S ONE THING THAT'S
KIND OF A MAJOR BLOCKADE-
ANOTHER ONE. IS THE TESTING
CADENCE MANY DISTRICTS AS YOU
KNOW. I'VE BEEN SAYING THAT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO A WEEKLY TESTING CADENCE
WHICH AS I UNDERSTAND IT WOULD
BE- THE CADENCE REQUIRED TO GET
INCENTIVE GRANT MONIES. ANOTHER
BARRIER. FOR DISTRICTS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
MONEY- AND THEN YOU HAVE BEEN
HERE A REQUIREMENT THAT. THE-
TEACHERS LOCAL TEACHERS UNION
HAS TO SUPPORT. OR APPROVE ACT.
RE OPENING PLANNED FOR THAT
SCHOOL I HAVE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
GETTING CEASE AND DESIST
LETTERS FROM THE DAY AS WE
SPEAK- AND THERE YOU AND
THEY'RE GOING TO USE THIS
PROVISION ESSENTIALLY TO KEEP
SCHOOL SHUT DOWN SO THERE'S
SOME MAJOR. PROBLEMS WITH YOUR
RE OPENING PRO AND I JUST GIVE
YOU A FEW- HOW DO YOU GUYS
INTEND TO ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE I THINK YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO GET A LOT OF DISTRICTS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
INCENTIVE MONEY. CERTAINLY AND
FIX IT TO TACKLE A BUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF MY REMARKS. AND WE
ARE AWARE THAT THEIR CONCERNS
AROUND TIMELINE DETECTING
CADENCES AND THEN CONCERNED
ABOUT. SCHOOLS THAT ARE ALREADY
OPEN- AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TO ENSURE THAT KIDS ARE NOT
YOU. WILL NOT CLOSE AND SHORT
OF AND AT STURGEON FACTION. I'M
FOR THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
ARE DEFINITELY WORKING ON-
AGAIN YOU KNOW OUR OUR
ANTICIPATION WITH THAT- YEAH WE
MIGHT HAVE IT AT A FASTER- MOVE
ON THIS ITEM THAT HAD HAPPENED
AND SO CERTAINLY NEED TO LOOK
AT THAT FEBRUARY ONE DATE AS I
MENTIONED. I'M THE ONE THING I
DO I DO WANT TO JUST CLARIFY-
ON DECLINING ISSUE IS THAT- THE
LANGUAGE IN THE EVEN IN THE.
CURRENT ITERATION OF THE
TRAILER BILL. DEFIES THAT
ELEAZAR ARE- YOU KNOW ABOUT
TWENTY. TO EIGHT AND- IT'S IT
WILL BE CHANGED FIVE. ABOUT THE
I. TWENTY FIVE HER HUNTER
THOUSAND- THAT AD THEY DON'T
HAVE TO RE OPEN- BY THE DATE
SPECIFIED THEY ONLY HAVE TO
REOPEN LINDA THANK YOU DO YOU
FELT WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THEY'RE-
THERE COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION
RATES DROP. I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WAS CLEAR THAT WE'RE
NOT HOLDING ANYONE WHO IS- IN A
DEEP. PURPLE CONTUSION PEOPLE
ARE CALLING IT COULD REALLY.
AND TO REOPEN BEFORE IT IS SAFE
TO DO. WE HAVE MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE OPEN RIGHT
NOW IN PURPLE TEAR- THEY
ALREADY RE OPEN IN THE FALL AND
THEY STAYED OPEN AND THEY ARE
NOT HAVING PROBLEMS SO. I GUESS
I UNDERSTAND THAT I MEAN SHOULD
THERE BE A CHANGE TO THE
BLUEPRINT. FRAMEWORK I MEAN THE
GOVERNOR CHANGES PLANNED
OVERNIGHT LAST NIGHT- I'M
SUPPOSING YOU COULD PROBABLY
CHANGE THE BLUEPRINT TODAY TOO
IF YOU WANTED TO. I'M NOT SURE
WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO IS A
DEFINITE CHANGE IN THE FINE
OVERNIGHT LAST NIGHT HOWEVER
AND- I WOULD MENTION THAT MORE-
THE REGIONAL STAY AT HOME WATER
THAT HE LIFTED. NOT CONSISTENT
WITH HIS PREVIOUS CRITERIA AND
NONE OF US WERE TOLD ABOUT
AHEAD OF TIME THAT CHANGE.
THAT'S WHY I CAN'T I CAN'T
THINK THAT OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT
MY AREA OF EXPERTISE BUT- WHAT
I CAN SAY IS THAT AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE ARE
LOOKING AT WAYS THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT. ON SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE ALREADY OPEN
AND THAT HAVE NOT HAD SEARCHES
OR OUTBREAKS OF INFECTION I'M
CAN ALSO BENEFIT FROM THIS
PROGRAM IS FILE AND NOT HAVE TO
BE CLOSED SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW I'M
TRYING TO FIND SOME SOLUTIONS
FOR. OKAY. SAID MR GALLAGHER
YES I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT I
FULLY SUPPORT THE FIRST THING
THAT MR GALLAGHER BROUGHT UP AS
FAR AS THE DEFERRALS FOR K.
TWELVE AND FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- NOT TO MENTION THAT
WE'RE ANTICIPATING GETTING MORE
MONEY IN MAY FROM INCREASE
REVENUES JUST FROM THE ECONOMY
ARE TAX RECEIPTS PLUS WE HAVE
THIS INFUSION OF FEDERAL MONEY
COMING UPGRADE IT'S ONLY ONE
TIME BUT- WE'RE- LOOKING AT
POTENTIALLY. THIRTEEN BILLION
ON TOP OF THE SIX WE ALREADY
GOT SO. I THINK THAT WE OWE IT
TO OUR SCHOOLS- TO MAKE THEM
HOLD ITS IS SMART BUDGETARY
PRACTICE SO I WITH THAT NEXT WE
HAVE SOME MEMBER OF DONALD ON
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BY ADONIS.
I THANK YOU MISTER TURNER IS
GOING TO BRING UP DEFERRALS AS
WELL BUT IT'S BEEN ALREADY
DISCUSSED SO I JUST WANT TO
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT
ISSUE- I HAVE A QUESTION WITH
REGARD AT THE BUDGET- YEAH THE
PERSON STIRS PAY DOWN. A FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO PAY THESE FUNDS
DOWN PAY THIS LONG TERM DEBT
DOWN. BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT
ENOUGH MONEY COMMITTED TO THEM
IN THE PAST- SO. ARE YOU
INCREASING THE STANDARD
PAYMENT. IN PERSON STIRS THIS
YEAR OR IS IT JUST THE STANDARD
PAYMENT. I SEE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND- TWENTY MILLION FIRSTERS.
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION FOR PERS ARE THOSE THAT
OTHERS THE STANDARD. PAYMENTS
ARE THOSE AN INCREASE. IN IN
THE STANDARD PATTERN. YES THANK
YOU SO MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
THOSE TWO PAYMENTS ARE AND
INCREASED ABOVE WHAT WE WOULD
NORMALLY BE PAYING AND THOSE
AND PAYMENTS WERE SCHEDULED AS
PART AS- THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT AN AGREEMENT THAT WE
HAD WE HAD AT PLANNED FOR THOSE
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT-
BUT THEY ARE ADDITIONAL
PAYMENT. OVER OUR NORMAL
PAYMENT HE SAID THAT WOULD BE
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
ALONE TO STIRS ABOVE THE.
REQUIRED OR STANDARD PAYMENT IS
THAT ACCURATE. IS ACCURATE YES
OKAY THE IN ONE YEAR. IS THAT
IN OUR TWENTY THAT'S A HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE ONE YOU'RE CORRECT.
IN ONE YEAR YES TO PAY DOWN THE
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER. GREAT SO-
HOW MANY OR DO YOU YEAH I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE THIS
INFORMATION WAS THERE IT WAS
THERE ARE MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT
MADE. TO PAY DOWN. THAT DEBT
YES SO THERE WAS I IS IT IS IT
AND THIS YEAR DOESN'T NEED TO
CONTINUE AFTER THIS YOUR
ORDERED OR DOES IT WHERE'S
WHERE'S THAT DISCUSSION. THE
MULTI YEAR DEAL WAS TO PAY DOWN
THE EMPLOYER SHARE OF COSTS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. AS WELL AS
MAKE- PAYMENTS INTO THE LONG
TERM AGAINST THE LONG TERM
LIABILITY- HOWEVER DEBT PAY
DOWN OF THE EMPLOYER RATE IS
NOT CURRENTLY SCHEDULED IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OR
BEYOND. OKAY SO WE WOULD HAVE
TO RE UP THAT EFFORT. GOING
FORWARD CORRECT. AND I THINK
THAT THAT THAT'S ERY IMPORTANT
IS THE ULTIMATE IMPACT IS THAT.
IT TABS DOWN THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH STORES IN
PERSON THE OUT YEARS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. SO ISEE IT DROPPING
FROM 18% ROUGHLY TWO. FIFTY THE
HIGH END OF 15% AND THAT'S A
GOOD THING SO THIS PAYDOWNS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT- I JUST WANT TO
NOTE THAT- THEN ALSO SHE
FIFTEEN MILLION. FOR THE CRADLE
TO GRAVE DATA SYSTEM- I GUESS
I'LL JUST ISSUE AN OPINION- I
JUST SEE A DISASTER COMING I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE NEED THIS
THING- AND- WE HAVEN'T HAD
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS IN THE STATE
WITH OUR DATA SYSTEMS
ESPECIALLY DURING CREATE A NEW
ONE. I JUST HOPE WE'RE VERY
THOUGHTFUL ON WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS REALLY NECESSARY AND IF
THESE DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT
IN AN EFFECTIVE MANNER. AND
WITHOUT IT I AM VERY I DON'T
NEED COMMENT BACK FROM YOU.
BUT- THERE IS THE YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. NUMBER SO MY
QUESTION IS AROUND THE BILLION
DOLLARS AND BE OUT OR THE
BILLION BEING ALLOCATED FOR
THEM WITH THE RE FOR RE
OPENING- IN MY DISTRICT MY AND
THE THIRTIETH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT- HALF OF MY SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN IN VENTURA COUNTY AND
THEN MY LOS ANGELES- PORTION OF
THE DISTRICT AND THE SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED AND THERE ARE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERN- OVER THE COST
OF TESTING OVER THE LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE- FOR TESTING-
THE RESPONSIBILITY AND REALLY
MY DISTRICTS ARE ALREADY
THINKING IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFICULT TO FIND SUBSTITUTES.
YET ALONE I'M PERSONALITY HELP-
WITH THE TESTING- CADENCE UNDER
THE GUIDELINES- BUT REALLY- THE
N. AND CHAIRMAN- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE TEST THAT
WE'RE TAKING NOW IF YOU LOOK
THEM UP ONLINE THEIR UPWARDS OF
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
DOLLARS AND I'VE HEARD A COUPLE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO A LOT OF MY
DISTRICT ARE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN
HELP AND THEY'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO APPLY AND WHETHER THEY
SHOULD APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS.
BUT REALLY- WHEN I LOOK AT THIS
TWO BILLION DOLLARS BEING
ALLOCATED FROM PROP NINETY
EIGHT I'M DOLLARS MY QUESTION
IS THERE AN EXISTING PRECEDENT
IN WHICH PROP NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS ARE USED TO FUND A
HEALTH CARE PROGRAM OR
STRATEGY- IMPLEMENTED BY
DISTRICTS TO THE TUNE OF TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF YOU KNOW
BILLION DOLLARS OR EVEN. A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND I
HAVE SOME UPS WELL. CERTAINLY
AND SO I'LL IT SHOULD THE FIRST
POINT YOU MADE ABOUT THE COST
OF THE TASK. UNTIL I JUST
WANTED TO NOTE THAT TO THE
EXTENSION LEN PARTICIPATE IN
THE VALENCIA ALLOWED PROGRAM ON
THE CURRENT COST PROTEST THERE
IS FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS PER CAST-
AND WE ANTICIPATE THAT ONE- ONE
PARTICIPATION INCREASES BEYOND
A CERTAIN POINT. THAT WILL DROP
TO THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS PER
CAST AND WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT
OPTIONS AROUND APPROVING- TO
REDUCE COSTS EVEN FURTHER. SO
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
WORKED ON- WE ARE A WAY FROM
THE FEDERAL. RUN MEDICARE HELP
TO ENSURE THAT THE COST OF
TESTING. FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE ALL ITS
COVERAGE ABOUT PROGRAMS THAT
ARE TWO PIECES. ON YOUR ON YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF USING IT- SO
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
CURRENTLY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
USING- THANK YOU TO FIND A
TESTING- AND IN THE END IN OUR
NORMAL. IN A NORMAL. SCHOOL
YEAR. AND USE THAT FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY CLASSES WELL- GIVEN
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECES PROVIDING AND-
IN ADDITION YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
WE HAVE. FUNDING FOR SCHOOL YOU
KNOW THE LVF ANYTHING USED FOR
SCHOOL NURSES- THERE ARE MANY
MEDICAL COSTS FOR. US STUDENTS
MEET BECAUSE THE SOLICITATION
OR OTHER- NEEDS THAT ARE
COVERED- WITH PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND- SO I JUST.
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE SOME IN
INSTANCES WHEN NINETY EIGHT
HUNDRED USED FOR PURPOSES. LIKE
I'M SO AS A FOLLOW UP- MY
QUESTION KNOW I HAVE SOME SMALL
DISTRICTS IN THE THIRTY THE-
TO. AND IS THERE DISCUSS.
AROUND AUGMENTING THE BASE RATE
FOR SMALLER DISTRICTS WITHIN OF
IT BUT- TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OR
THREE THOUSAND EIGHTY EIGHT. ON
THAT REALLY DON'T HAVE A LARGE
ENOUGH FINANCIAL ABILITY-
APPARATUS. TO EXECUTE THIS CD
PH REQUIREMENTS. YEAH YOU KNOW
I THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND-
I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT ONE AND ALSO I NEED TO
CHECK WITH MY PUBLIC HEALTH
FOLKS ABOUT HOW THEY ARE. AND
HOW THEY'RE WORKING WITH THEIR
SMALLER DISTRICTS I CAN SAY
THAT GENERALLY SPEAKING TO THE
EXTENT THAT SMALLER DISTRICTS
HAVE ISSUES AROUND
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY GENERALLY
WORK FOR THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO HELP. THREE EIGHT-
YOU KNOW IT- AT. STATE YET
EFFICIENT THE ABOUT AND LARGER
NUMBERS AS A STUDENT INTERFERE
LARGE NUMBERS OF TESTING IN
PROVIDED THAT I HAVE TO DOUBLE
CHECK ON YOU ON THAT QUESTION
FOR YOU- WITH MY PUBLIC HEALTH
FOLKS AND WHAT THEIR GUIDANCE
ARE GETTING TO THE SMALLER
DISTRICTS. GREAT M. AND MY LAST
QUESTION- IS AROUND A FOR ALSO
ON THE INTERNET REITERATE MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SUGGESTED AND
THAT IT IT I THINK IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE OUR
DISTRICTS HOLE BUT I JUST DO
HAVE A QUESTION IN REGARDS TO
ONE OF THE LAST TIME THAT THE
STATE REQUIRED DISTRICT
DEFERRALS FOR WHAT AMOUNT OR
WHAT WAS THAT TOTAL. I'M WANT
TO THE STATE PAY BACK THE
DEFERRALS AND DOES THE STATE
PAY INTEREST. ON DEFERRALS THAT
COLLECT INTEREST. SO V. AND
DELVED INTO. RECESSION WE- I
THINK THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
DEFERRAL THAT WE BUILT THAT TOO
WAS JUST SHY OF ELEVEN BILLION
CREDIT RUN ELEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS- AND THAT WAS DONE OVER
A PERIOD OF MANY YEARS. AND
THEN THOSE DEFERRALS WERE PAID
OFF I THINK THE LAST DEFERRAL.
WEDNESDAY WAS- WAS PUT INTO
PLACE FOR INCREASED- I WANT TO
SAY WAS ELEVEN TWELVE- I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES WHO MIGHT BE IN
ONE OF THE AT THE OTHER PANEL
CAN- CAN VERIFY THAT NUMBER-
AND THEN WE PAY IT OFF OVER
SEVERAL YEARS. AND I THINK OUR
FINAL PAYMENT I WANT TO STAY
WITHIN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN- AGAIN
I MIGHT MY COLLEAGUE ERIN HAD
IDEA CAN. ANSWER THAT QUESTION
PROBABLY BETTER THAN I CAN. AND
IN TERMS OF- INTERESTS NO THE
STATE OF NEW PAY. FOR INTEREST.
WITH THE FOR. AND ONE THING TO
FOR HONORABLY BIT COMP- BUT ONE
OF THE THINGS I YOU CAN NOTICE
THAT GENERALLY SPEAKING-
ATTACHED LETTER GIRLS LIKE THE
ONES ARE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT
NOW- ARE SHORT TERM CASH FLOW
LOANS THAT ARE PAID OFF. IN A
MATTER OF MONTHS- IT IT APPEARS
AS THOUGH THEY CONTINUE OVER
SEVERAL YEARS. BUT WHAT WE
ACTUALLY DO WITH THE PAY OFF
THE LOAN IMMEDIATELY AND THEN
IN THE FOLLOWING FISCAL YEAR-
AND THEN TAKE OUT NEW DEFERRALS
ESSENTIALLY- AT THE END OF THE
NEXT FISCAL YEARS NOW ACTUALLY.
EXTEND OVER MULTIPLE YEAR
PERIOD THEY ARE- SHORT TERM
CASH BALANCE JUST IN THEIR
NATURE- YEAH I WOULD I WOULD
JUST BURN FROM THE SPECIFICS TO
MY COLLEAGUE AND ONE OF THE
FUTURE PANELS BUT- BUT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THAT IS.
THAT. IS THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SOMEONE TAKE. THANK YOU MISS
JUST THIRTY TO GO BACK TO OF
THE- COMMENTS FROM THE STATE
SUPREME- YOU KNOW IN A LETTER.
THE GOVERNOR AT THE SEVEN
DISTRICTS. SEVEN LARGEST
DISTRICTS HAVE CONCERNS OVER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE THE PROPOSAL
AND WANT TO WORK VERY CLOSELY
SO THAT WE ALL HAVE THE SAME
GOALS. TO SAFELY FIND A PATH TO
OPEN UP SCHOOLS. CAN CAN YOU
GIVE US A SENSE HOW THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE GOING WITH THE-
SEVEN LARGE DISTRICTS AND I
KNOW THAT- YOU REFERRED TO
MEETINGS WITH YOUR- THE HEALTH
TEAM IN. TRY TO GET GREATER
CLARITY OVER- WHAT YOU COULD DO
TO YOU KNOW PROVIDE. LATER
GUIDANCE TO HELP THEM. SO WE'VE
BEEN MEETING WITH WITH MANY
ELEAZAR ANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING- REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE SEVEN LARGEST- AND THEIR
NEEDS REALLY ARE DIFFERENCE
DEPENDING ON THE L. E. A. AND I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW MANY TO
MENTION THAT YOU HAVE TESTING
PLANS IN PLACE FOR OUR TEACHERS
AND FOR SOME OF THEM IN THE
TESTING AS STUDENTS THAT IS A
CONCERNS- AT THE OTHER PIECE IS
AND THAT WE HEAR QUITE A BIT
AND THEN INTO CONCERNS AROUND
THE TIGHTENING AND HOW MUCH
TIME THEY WILL HAVE. TO
RENEGOTIATE WITH- WITH THEIR AT
THEIR HOUSE BY TEACHERS UNIONS-
AS WELL AS AND TRY TO GET THERE
YOU KNOW COMMUNITIES ON BOARD-
I THINK THE LAST BLAST YOUR
CONSISTENT- FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN. FROM FOLKS AND IS
AROUND. AND THE CONCERN TOOK
HAS THAT THE- CONCERN FAMILIES
A TEN TO CHILDREN- YOU KNOW
WHILE WILD. RATES ARE HIGH AND
YOU KNOW CONCERNED ABOUT
SAFETY- AND THEN ALSO
VACCINATIONS AND HAD TO HAVE
DEFINITELY BEEN PART OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- AS WELL AS
CONCERNED ABOUT- AS- PERSONNEL
RESOURCES SO. WHETHER OR NOT
THERE ARE ENOUGH. TEACHERS ARE
CLASSIFIED STAFF. TO SUPPORT
THOSE PROGRAMS THOSE ARE ALL
ISSUES THAT WERE I'M DISCUSSING
I LOOK AT LEAST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER SO THAT WE
CAN. AND MAKE THE CHANGES
PROPOSAL TO MAKE IT MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR THOSE FOLKS.
GREAT THANK YOU. DO YOU GET A
SENSE THAT WILL DPH P.
DESTROYING A REVISED GUIDELINES.
THEN BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO BE
THEM. THE REAL OF THE ISSUE
WE'VE BEEN ABOUT THIS SEEM.
BASED ON THE THEME IN THIS THAT
I'VE HAD WITH AND IT'S OF LIKE.
MONEY BEEN THAT MAIN HURDLE
IT'S- THEIR SENSE OF. NEEDING
CLEAR GUIDANCE AND CLEAR
DIRECTION. YEAH I CERTAINLY
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH THEY WILL SAY
THAT THE GUIDANCE THAT DATE
THEY PUT OUT I KNOW IT FEELS
LIKE THEY'RE CONSTANTLY KIND
BEING RELEASED BUT- REALLY THE
ONLY APPEALING TO PEOPLE TO
KIND OF PUT OUT HAVE BEEN IN
AUGUST AND IN THE THREE POINT
LINE AND- THEY WORK REALLY HARD
TO ENSURE THAT. WHAT THEY DO
PUT OUT IS BASED ON THE BEST
SCIENCE THAT THEY HAVE AT THE
TIME BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
DEFINITELY GET KIDS BACK INT
SCHOOL THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S DONE SAFELY IN
DOESN'T EXACERBATE THE CURRENT
SITUATION WHICH WE FIND
OURSELVES. I'M HOWEVER I THINK
THAT WHERE THE INTERSECTION OF
THE GUIDANCE AND THE GRANT ARE
CONCERNED I THINK THAT'S
DEFINITELY AN AREA WHERE. WE'RE
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
IS GOING TO BE- REQUIRED AND TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GRANT AS IT
CONNECTS TO THE GUIDANCE SO. I
THINK THAT I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY KEY AREA. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
GRADING DON'T THINK WE WOULD.
WE WOULD CONCUR AS WELL AS A
NEW. I DON'T THINK YOU WERE AT
OUR HEARING AND I THINK IT WAS.
OCTOBER OR NOVEMBER- THAT WE
WE'VE BEEN. WE'VE BEEN WAITING
FOR. QUITE A WHILE FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE TO COME
OUT- THEN GOT GOING TO THE
DISTRICTS OUTSIDE OF THE- LARGE
SEVEN DISTRICTS HAVE YOU GOTTEN
FEEDBACK. IN TERMS OF- WITH
THIS PROPOSAL BE ENOUGH FOR
THEM TO. OPEN UP OR FOR. THEM
TO SAY THE MAJORITY OF THEM TO
MOVE FORWARD OPEN UP. YEAH YOU
KNOW IT OBVIOUSLY AS YOU WELL
KNOW AND THERE IS SUCH A
DIVERSE CITY AND SITUATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE- AND SOME
DISTRICTS ARE- ARE IN A PLACE
WHERE THEIR INFECTION RATES ARE
SO HIGH- THAT IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO OPEN UP
ANY TIME SOON- AND- I. IT WHAT
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE FOR THOSE DISTRICTS
IS OBVIOUSLY NOT AT THE OPEN IF
THEY'RE INFECTION RATES ARE
INCREDIBLY HIGH THAT. THAT
THEY'RE PLANNING FOR WHEN WE
OPENING AS POSSIBLE AND I THINK
THAT WE DO BELIEVE THAT OUR
PROPOSAL WILL ENCOURAGE- AT
LEAST TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE PLANS IN PLACE AND I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY CRUCIAL
POINT THAT EVEN IF YOU'RE NOT
IN THE PLACE WHERE YOU CAN OPEN
RIGHT NOW. THAT YOU ARE READY
TO GO WHEN YOUR INFECTION RATES
DROPPED LOW ENOUGH TO MAKE IT
SAFE- BECAUSE I THINK BUT ONE
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT. WE'RE NOT CAUGHT FLAT
FOOTED- AS AS YOU WELL KNOW AND
AS I MENTIONED IN THE LAST
HEARING YOU KNOW I THINK WE ALL
THOUGHT BACK AT LAST MARCH
THAT. WILL CLOSURES WERE GONNA
LAST YOU FOR A EW WEEKS AND
THEN WE GO BACK IN AND THEN
THEY CAN CHANGES PRESS ON AND
THEN YOU KNOW WE- FINISH THE
SCHOOL YEAR AND DISTANCE
LEARNING AND YOU KNOW IT IS
DONE SO ON AND SO FORTH AND SO
I THINK OUR- ONE OF OUR MAIN
HE'S- AND GOLD WITH THIS GRANT.
IS NOT ONLY TO GET AS MANY
PEOPLE BACK IN PERSON AS WE
CAN. I'M IN A SAFE MANNER WHERE
IT IS SAFE TO DO SO BUT ALSO TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THOSE ELEAZAR
THAT ARE. IN HIGH TRANSMISSION
AREAS ARE READY TO GO AS SOON
AS A DISTINCT IDENTITY THEFT.
THE HOME SOME WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT WE. WE DID THAT IN THE-
IN THE JULY BUDGET. WE GAVE
ELEAZAR FIVE BILL. DOLLARS ON.
I THINK WE'LL ALL. OF PAST OUT
BUDGET. IN IN THE SUMMER THIS
OPTION WAS EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAID THAT THEY WERE GOING TO BE
READY THEY WERE GONNA DO THEIR
TAKE A SUMMER WE GAVE THEM FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. TO GET READY TO OPEN
IN THE FALL AND WHAT WE SAW IS.
ON HOW DO YOU KNOW AUGUST HIT.
AND TRANSMISSION LEVELS WERE
WERE LOW MUCH MUCH LOWER THAN
THEY ARE TODAY. AND YET- YOU
KNOW I WOULD I WOULD DISAGREE
DO YOU ARE YOU MAKE YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU SEE. YOU
KNOW ELLIE IS ALL OVER THE
PLACE ACTUALLY- HE'S ACTING
VERY CONSISTENTLY I THINK OVER
90% OF THEM ARE CLOSED. SO THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT THE
SITUATION MAY BE DIFFERENT.
THEIR BEHAVIOR IS VERY
CONSISTENT JUST LIKE A YEAR AGO
THEY WERE ALL PRETTY CONSISTENT
THEY WERE ALL OPEN. SO AGAIN
THERE IS. YOU KNOW WE- I DON'T
WANT TO REPEAT WHAT WE DID IN.
IN JUNE WHEN WE PASSED A
BUDGET. GAVE SCHOOLS WHAT WE
BELIEVED WERE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES WHAT WE SAW IS. NOT
NOT ONLY DID THIS DISTRICTS NOT
UTILIZE THOSE RESOURCES IN THE
SUMMER. THEY DIDN'T EVEN REALLY
UTILIZE THE RESOURCES UNTIL THE
FALL YOU DIDN'T EVEN SEE. MOST
RESOURCES BEING PULLED DOWN
UNTIL DECEMBER WHEN THE
DEADLINE WAS COMING. IN SO- YOU
KNOW I WANT TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE ALL HAVE THE
SAME GOALS WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE SCHOOLS. BE REOPENED IN
THE SAFEST MANNER. PASSABLE
pTO REPEAT THE SAME. MISTAKE
THAT WE'VE MADE IN THIS LAST
BUDGET WERE BECAME DISTRICTS-
RESOURCES TO OPEN UP AND WE DID
NOT. SEE THAT HAPPEN. IS SO-
YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU YOU
FEEL THAT THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS COULD BE SPENT TO
PREPARE. DISTRICTS TO OPEN UP
WHICH WOULD. DID YOU MEAN TO
PREPARE THEM TO OPEN UP THIS
YEAR OR YOU'RE TALKING IN THE
FALL BECAUSE IF WE'RE TALKING
IN THE FALL I DON'T I DON'T
THINK WE NEED TO DO IN THE-
EARLY ACTION WE CAN JUST TAKE
ACTION IN. IN JUNE. SO THAT'S A
GREAT POINT AND ATKINS. YEAH SO
THE DIFFERENCE I THINK ONE OF
THE BIG ONE THE MAIN
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN WHAT WE DID
IN THIS IN THE SUMMER AND IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
AND WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING NOW-
IS REALLY AROUND- YOU KNOW. THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE AND WE GET
A FIVE POINT THREE BILLION OUT
TO ALL L. YATES REGARDLESS- OF-
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE
PLANNING ON OPENING FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND WE
DIDN'T REQUIRE THEM TO OPEN FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION OR TO
RECEIVE THOSE FUNDS. WE ALSO
TOLD THEM THEY COULD BE USED
FOR LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION-
DEFENDER VERY TARGETED TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND BUT WE
DECIDED THAT- TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU RECEIVE THE FUNDING
YOU DON'T REOPEN WHEN ITS- THE
DOSE FUNDS WILL BE TAKEN AWAY
THAT THAT YOU WILL SEE IT THREE
YOUR ANNUAL AUDIT YOU WILL
RECEIVE AN ON A PENALTY IN THE
FUNDS WILL BE TAKEN AWAY- SO TO
YOUR QUESTION I THINK THERE
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE. IN WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING NOW AND WE
PROPOSED THIS SUMMER I THINK
ALSO YES TO ANSWER YOUR LAST
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY- WE WANT
PEOPLE TO OPEN UP YOU KNOW EVEN
IF IT'S FOR THREE WEEKS BECAUSE
THAT YOU KNOW WHEN THEIR RATES
GO DOWN LONG ENOUGH. FOR THEM
TO REOPEN YES WE WANT THEM TO
OPEN THIS YEAR THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THIS FALL HOWEVER I WAS
NOTING EARLIER. ANOTHER BENEFIT
IS THAT. I YOU KNOW. LOCAL TO
BE READY MORE READY. FOR
INSTRUCTIONS WHENEVER THEY RE
OPEN- YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT A
FULL THIS. TO SAY KNOW- WE ONLY
FOUR WEEKS IN THE SCHOOL. THE
SCHOOL YEAR YEAH I KNOW IT A
FRESH OPEN RIGHT- BUT WE'RE
JUST NOT GONNA GET WE'RE JUST
GONNA WAIT FOR THE FALL THE
ONE. THOSE FOLKS TO TAKE THOSE
FOR WEEKS INTO THE MOST OF
NOTHING. CAN FOR THE- OF THEIR-
AND IS FOR. IN PART OF THE
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND THAT'S- OF THE LOOK AT. WE
WERE- YOU KNOW I PERSONALLY.
OTHER ON- PUTTING THIS FORWARD
A PUTTING THIS PROPOSAL
FORWARD. I THINK IT'S STILL.
NEEDS TO. BE DISCUSSED FURTHER
BUT WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
AND WE REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN
FIND. FIND A PATH THAT WE CAN.
ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT WE ALL
SHARE WHICH IS TO TRY TO GET.
SCHOOLS OPENED UP AS SAFELY AS
POSSIBLE AND AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M WE DID KIND OF. CHANGE THAT
SCHEDULES MORNING A BIT
BECAUSE- WE WANTED TO
ACCOMMODATE- THE- JESSICA HOMES
AND APARTMENT OF FINANCE- BUT-
WE DO HAVE THIS OTHER BUDGET.
WITH WITH TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS. BUDGET YEAR
PROPOSAL THAT WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT AS WELL BUT- THIS IS
PRIORITY RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA
BE RUNNING ON THIS IN A COUPLE
WEEKS. IN THE FULL COMMITTEE SO
WE WANTED TO. TALK A BIT ABOUT
THIS WHICH WE DID. SO NOW I
WANT TO GO BACK AND LET THE L.
I KNOW LMAO. IS HERE WITH US.
AND IF YOU CAN GIVE US RUN
THROUGH. ANY MAYBE OUGHT TO GET
THE WHOLE PIECE BUT ANY. PIECES
YOU THINK ARE IMPORTANT FOR US
TO CONSIDER. ON THE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT PROPOSAL. AND
THEN IF ELLIE- CAN GO OVER
YOUR- ANALYSIS OF THE- OVERALL.
PROP NINETY EIGHT BY PROPOSALS
FOR THE. TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET. PRETTY MEMBERS THIS IS
A WE WILL THE LARGEST ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I AM SO THINK IT
WORTHWHILE PRIVILEGE. TO
EXPLORE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
SCHOOLS TO REOPEN ESPECIALLY
FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN AND HIGH
NEED STUDENTS. HOWEVER AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTING IT WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW EFFECTIVE
THE COUPLES WILL BE.
ANNOUNCEMENT WE GETTING SCHOOLS
REOPENED EARLIER.AND WE HAVE A
FEW ISSUES FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER AS WELL AS OPTIONS
TO SUPPORT SCHOOL RE OPENING.
AND MEMBERS HAVE ALREADY RAISED
MOST OF THESE ISSUES AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE DISCUSSIONS ARE
UNDER WAY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS. SO I'LL JUST
SHARE MY POINTS RATHER BRIEFLY-
SIX TO COMPLETE THE FUNDING
REQUIREMENTS. TO MEET THE
FEBRUARY ONE DEADLINE WHICH IS
AGAIN NEXT MONDAY. DISTRICTS
WOULD HAVE VERY LITTLE TIME TO
UPDATE THEIR SCHOOL REOPENING
PLANS ARRANGE FOR ROUTINE
TESTING. AND AGO SHEET WITH OUR
LABOR UNIONS. SECONDLY WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CAPACITY OF THE STATE AGENCIES
AND LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR SCHOOL
REOPENING. FOR INSTANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES NO
AUGMENTATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. OR
THE LOCAL COUNTY BUDGETS TO
SUPPORT THIS ADDITIONAL WORK-
LASTLY WE KNOW THAT THE
PROPOSAL AS CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED IS UNLIKELY TO BE TO
EARLIER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
AND AGAIN ON THEIR TWO REASONS
FOR THIS. FIRST THE ROUTINE
THERE ARE. FOR ROUTINE A
SYMPTOMATIC TESTING AS OFTEN.
EVERY WEEK FOR ALL STUDENTS AND
STAFF. ADDS MORE COMPLEX WITH
JUST A GOAL CHALLENGES TO
SCHOOL REOPENING WHICH ALSO
ALREADY RATHER. COMP ENDEAVOR
IS- SECOND COPE NINETEEN
SPRAYED ARE HIGH. THIS CURRENT
YOU GREAT THAN A HUNDRED. PER
HUNDRED PEOPLE. AS A JUNIOR
NINETEEN. ONLY COUNTY POSSIBLE.
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND PER.
THAT WOULD BE ALLOW ONLY TWO
SCHOOLS TO REOPEN. CAN WORDS.
RIGHT NOW WE THINK. NOT
ACTUALLY. IN MUCH INTEREST
INSTRUCTION INSTEAD. NOW THE
LEGISLATURE A FEW OPTIONS
CONSIDER AND MOSTLY BECAUSE I.
ARE GEARED TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE- FIRST AND
I JUST COULD. THE PROPOSAL TO
PUT SCHOOL TO OPT IN PER AND-
TO ALL HIDING TO. A MONTH
BEFORE THE OTHER L. GRADES THIS
ALLOWS AND TIME TO RAMP UP
THEIR TESTING. AND OTHER ABLE.
CHALLENGES A SMALL GROUP
STUDENTS AND STAFF FIRST WHILE
STILL. IN PERSON. TO STUDENTS
WITH LARGE BETTER FROM IT.
SECONDLY AND I JUST COULD CAN
IT. SOME FOR. IS ON THE EAST.
TO REQUIRE. I GET AND- AS
MEMBERS ARE READY MENTIONED.
THAT OF THE- MOST LIKELY TO
DAMPEN SCHOOL. THE LEGISLATURE
COULD PROVIDE JUST WITHIN OUR
TO DEVELOPING ALTERNATE TESTING
KIT AND MOTHER LABOR PARTNERS.
OR ALLOW DISTRICTS TEST ALL
STAFF. BUT RANDOM SAMPLED
STUDENTS. THIS APPROACH JUST
LIKE. THAT GINGRICH AREN'T
LOWER OF TRANCE CODED. WHILE
MAKING IT WOULD. TESTING MORE.
LAST APART FROM THE PROPOSAL
THE- COULD ALSO AT WAYS TO
INCREASE STATE TESTING. AND IN
FOR. THAT ALLOW SCHOOLS TO MORE
EASE ACCESS ROUTINES. ALL THAT
MANY HAS. SCHOOLS ACCESS TO
STATE'S BILL BROWN LAB IT UP
MARK REALLY FAST AND THE
TESTING CAPACITIES ASIDE FOR
SCHOOLS. NUMBER KEY POINTSAND
OPTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF THERE
ARE ANY THANK YOU ALL. OKAY.
HEARING NONE RIGHT NOW WE WANT
TO ALLOW. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S REPRESENTATIVE TO
ENGAGE ON THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET PROPOSAL AS
WELL. NOW THEY'RE GONE. OKAY
YEAH SORRY ABOUT THAT SO. L. A.
L. CAN YOU ALSO DO YOUR SECOND
PRESENTATION. I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MIGHT
HAVE SOME OPENING COMMENTS ON
THE GUARANTEE IN THEIR
PROPOSALS AND IF- WE MAY I'D
LIKE TO- BUT THEM I TAKE GO
AHEAD AND START WITH THAT. YOUR.
RIGHT HI GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARENARIA
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I'M GONNA
TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
BUT AS MANY OF YOU HAVE
MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
MORNING SO FAR THERE ARE A LOT
OF DYNAMICS AT PLAY MOST
NOTABLY- THE REVENUE INCREASE
OF COURSE BEEN MENTIONED
SEVERAL TIMES SO- HERE WE GO
COMPARED TO- THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT THE FIGURE OUR
REVENUE TARGET MENTIONED EVERY
BALLOT BY ON PRESIDENT AMOUNT
ALMOST SEVENTY BILL DOLLARS
OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD
COMPARED TO- THE PROJECTIONS.
AT BUDGET ACT- MOST ABOUT DUE
TO. THE CORRECT THE ARRESTED
TAX FOR IN CALIFORNIA I- I'M
FORCING HEALTH OF THE STOCK
CAPITAL GAINS WILL AGAIN TO THE
ORIGINAL PER. ABA TEST ONE
BEING OFFERED IT THE YEAR- THE
GUARANTEE WILL CALL FOR ABOUT
THIRTY EIGHT ON THE DOLLAR
EVERY NEW- DOLLAR THAT THAT WE
RECEIVED ABOUT PROJECT- I'M NOT
SURE. IN ANYTHING. AND THAT I
CAN TRY FISCALLY. YEAH UP TO
TOTAL OF ABOUT NINE AND A HALF
BILLION. A ONE POINT BILLION
INCREASE OVER THE AFTER INTO BY
JACKSON JUNE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEED UP ABOUT
A POINT NINE A BILLION DOLLARS
YOU CAN MAKE UP THE INACTIVE.
FOR A FOR A TOTAL INTO TWENTY
ONE OF EIGHTY POINT EIGHT
BILLION. AND THE INCREASE IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. OVER THE
TOP TWENTY TWENTY ONE LEVEL AT
THE STATE BUDGET ACT I IS ABOUT
FOURTEEN POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS AND I KNOW THE SUMMER
PEOPLE OUTSIDE THAT NUMBER AS
WELL- AND NOT THE- TOTAL-
MINIMUM GUARANTEED CALCULATION.
EIGHTY FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY.
FIVE NOW AT THE BUDGET ACT IN
RECOGNITION OF THIS EXTREME
DROP IN REVENUE THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY PART. AND IMPACT
WITH THE DIRECT IMPACT I WAS
GONNA HAVE TO KEEP FORTY
FUNDING THE GUARANTEE AT THE
TIME. I TRAILER BILL LESLIE
WITHIN IN A TO REQUIRE.
SUPPLEMENTARY PAIN TO BE MADE
ON AN ANNUAL FOR YEARS IN
ACCESS THE POP NINE EIGHT
MINIMUM. CAL NOW WITH TO BEGIN
IN TWO ONE TO TWO AND THE WOULD
BE TO ONE A HALF. OF TOTAL
SOUND GENERAL FUND REVENUES- AS
WELL THERE WAS THEY TEST ONE
SHARE OF GENERAL FUND REVENUES
LEAD BENCH THAT WAS PROPOSED
WITHIN THEIR- WHICH WOULD TAKE
BE PERMANENT ONGOING SHARE OF
THE GENERAL FUND REVENUES FROM
38% APPROXIMATELY. TWO EXACTLY
FORTY PERCENT- ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. NOW WITH THE- REVENUE
AGAINST ME RECOVER- BACK MORE
CLOSELY IN LINE THE KIND OF.
FREAK PROJECT. THOUGH STILL NO
QUITE HEALTHY AS WE HAD
ORIGINALLY THOUGHT- THE- LOS.
WE'RE TO BY TO ELIMINATE
PAYMENTS IN TWO TWO TO THREE
AND JUST A WANT. TWENTY ONE TO
TWO YEAR. OF POINT THREE
BILLION OR EQUAL TO ONE OF
PERCENT OF TOLD SO CHEN.
GENERAL FUND REVENUES AT THE
GOVERNOR'S. THAT BRINGS THE
TOTAL PROPOSED PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT HUNDRED LOVE. IN
THE BUT TO EIGHTY POINT ONE
BILLION. WHICH AN INCREASE OF
NOW SEVENTY POINT BILLION
DOLLARS OVER THE- TWENTY TWO
ONE LEVEL. OF YEAR. AFTERNOON
TO PROBABLY TWO WELL WHICH
FABULOUS THE PROPOSITION NINETY
PER- THE GOVERNOR'S BUT SB THAT
THE- WILL BE WERE. INTERNET
INVOLVED TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
ONE TWO CLEAR IN THE AMOUNT OF
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN TO DOLLARS
AND TWO POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS RESPECTIVELY. AS A
RESULT OF MANY OF YOU HAVE
ALREADY LIKELY HEARD THAT 3%
RESERVE BALANCE. WOULD BE MET
IN THIS CASE. I WHICH WOULD
REQUIRES DISTRICTS OUR CAP TO
GOING TO A- BEGINNING IN TWO
TWENTY THREE I'M HAPPY TO CHECK
MORE ABOUT THAT LATER BUT
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO I KNOW
THAT WE AND MAKES COMMENTS
THERE AS WELL- TO BUY. ACT
INCLUDE. ELEVEN EXCUSE ME THE
BUDGET INCLUDE HELLO BILLION
DOLLAR IN NOT CASE ALL THE
PORTS BEFORE. ABOUT TWELVE AND
A HALF BILLION DOLLAR IN TOTAL
K. WE CAN COLLEGE SUPPORT OF
PEARLS AFFECTING MONTHS SEGUE
THROUGH JUNE OF TWO TWENTY- THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET PROPOSED FOR.
RETIRE BILLS TO ALL THIS
MENTIONED HERE LET'S HEARING-
THROUGH BY JULY JOURNAL SO
BASICALLY PAYING BACK IN THE
ORIGINALLY OP IN- REPAYMENT
MONTHS. AND THEN WE'RE ALSO
ADDITIONAL DEFERRAL THREE POINT
SEVEN BILL DOLLARS HE TWELVE
SIDE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLAR ON THE-
COLLEGE SIDE- SHOULD BE
DEFERRED FROM TWO ONE TWENTY
TWO IN TWENTY. TWENTY FOR A
THAT BUT CALL OF ABOUT SEVEN
THREE DOLLAR US. WITH K. TWELVE
BUDGET FOR ALL P. DOWN IN ONE
TWENTY TWO- AS WELL AS AS WE'VE
ALREADY. TALKED ABOUT- EARLIER
THE- BUDGET ALSO PROVIDES
EFFORT TO. PROVIDE A LIAISE
WITH RESOURCES TO TAKE OPEN.
WHEN APPROPRIATE ME AND ALSO
DIRECT RESOURCES JUNE MOST OF.
IMPACTED BY THE- WE'RE
PROPOSING SIX SIX GOING DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME AND ARE YAK OLD.
SEVERAL OTHER ADDITIONAL
SPENDING PROPOSAL THAT WE CAN
GET INTO ON THIS PANEL AS WELL
AS IN A- LATER PENALTY TODAY'S
HEARING- WITH THAT I'LL ON MY
COMMENTS FOR THE MOMENT AND-
DALY- SPEAKING HAPPY TO. ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. ON
THIS OKAY THANK YOU L. A. M.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CAN COUPON WITH THE
ANALYST OFFICE. I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GIVE YOU
A GOOD OVERVIEW OF WHAT'S IN
THIS BUDGET SO ALL AT JUST A
FEW DETAILS AND THEN TURN TO
OUR COMMENTS. WE ALSO HAND OUT
WITH THIS INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE ONLINE AT OUR WEBSITE
ELADIO DOT CA DOT GOV. SO
STARTING WITH THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE. ELEVEN
POINT NINE BILLION INCREASE IN
THE GUARANTEE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE REALLY AS A MARKETABLE-
THAT IS A 17% INCREASE COMPARED
WITH THE- ESTIMATES FROM- JUNE
FROM LAST JUNE- BY A WIDE
MARGIN THAT'S THE LARGEST
INCREASE IN THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF THE MEASURE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AGAIN
IT'S ALMOST ENTIRELY A STORY
ABOUT GENERAL FUND REVENUE. I
REVENUE STARTED TO REBOUND.
QUICKLY LAST FALL AND TODAY
THEY'RE NEARLY BACK TO PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS MOST OF THE NEW
SPENDING ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ACTUALLY IS RELATED TO
MEETING. IS ONE TIME SPENDING
RELATED TO MEETING THAT HIGHER
GUARANTEED IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THAT CONTINUE AND
WHEN ONE TWENTY. THE GUARANTEED
ANOTHER THREE BILLION. OVER THE
REVISED TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE LEVEL- BOTH HIGHER GENERAL
FUND REVENUE AND HIGHER
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE CONTRIBUTE
TO THAT. AND ANOTHER TWO POINT
THREE BILLION IS PAID ON TOP OF
THAT BECAUSE OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT- SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS. THE GOVERNOR DR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MENTIONED
AT THE THREE BILLION DEPOSITS
IN THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESERVE AND THE FACT THAT THAT
FIGURES FOR THE FIRST TIME A
CAP ON SCHOOL DISTRICT
RESERVES- THAT CAP IS EQUAL
210% OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
ANNUAL EXPENDITURES. MOST
DISTRICTS ARE EXEMPT FROM THAT
CAMP CAP AUTOMATICALLY IF A
DISTRICT HAS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED OR FEWER STUDENTS IT'S
NOT SUBJECT TO THAT CAP- BASED
ON THE LATEST DATA THAT WE HAVE
A WE ESTIMATE THAT ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MEDIUM LARGE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. I CURRENTLY
MAINTAIN RESERVES ABOVE 10% OF
THEIR EXPENDITURES. I DISTRICTS
COULD RESPOND TO THAT CAP IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS THEY COULD BE
CLASSIFIED THEIR RESERVES- TO
AVOID THE CAP THEY COULD ALSO
ASK THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION TO APPROVE AN
EXEMPTION. WE THINK ONE OR TWO
OF THOSE APPROACHES ARE THE
MOST LIKELY WAY THAT DISTRICTS
WOULD RESPOND TO IT- BUT
ALTERNATIVELY THEY COULD ALSO
RESPOND BY SPENDING DOWN THOSE
RESERVES- INTERIM. OF THE
GUARANTEE WE THINK THE AT AT
THE MOMENTA FINANCES PUT
FORWARD A GOOD STARTING POINT
FOR THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. OTHER
ESTIMATES ARE VERY CLOSE TO OUR
IS BOTH IN TERMS OF GENERAL
FUND REVENUE AND LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE. OVER THE THREE
YEAR BUDGET PERIOD
1-922-000-1920 THREE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- THEIR ESTIMATES ARE
JUST FOUR HUNDRED MILLION ABOVE
OURS OVER THAT PERIOD SO
REALLY- VERY CLOSE STARTING
POINT- THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE WOULD CHANGE
ABOUT. FORTY SOMETHING A DOLLAR
FOR EACH DOLLAR OF HIGHER LOWER
STATE REVENUE. AND GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY THE
STATE CASES RIGHT NOW WE THINK
SOME CHANGES ARE LIKELY BY MAY-
BUT SURPRISINGLY THOSE CHANGES
MIGHT NOT MEAN MORE OR LESS
FUNDING IS AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL
PROGRAMS. I TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IS HIGHER THE STATE
WOULD LIKELY HAVE TO DEPOSIT A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THAT
INTO THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT RESERVE. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE GUARANTEE IS
LOWER THE STATE WOULD PROBABLY
NEED TO MAKE A SMALLER DEPOSIT.
YOU HEARD THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO REVISIT
THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS. AND
WE THINK THAT'S A REASONABLE
IDEA- UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE
HAS RECOVERED THE GROUND THAT
THE STATE WAS EXPECTING IT TO
LOSE BACK IN JUNE- BARRING
ANOTHER RECESSION A MINIMUM
GUARANTEE LOOKS LIKE WOULD BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT- BOTH THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT AS WELL AS
OTHER AUGMENTATIONS OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS. ANOTHER
CONSIDERATION WHICH IS AN ISSUE
FOR THE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
AS WELL. THAT THE STATE STATE
IS FACING A GROWING OPERATING
DEFICIT ON THE NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF THE
BUDGET- THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO MODIFY THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS DOESN'T ELIMINATE THAT
OPERATING DEFICIT. BUT IT DOES
MAKE IT A LITTLE AT LEAST A
LITTLE BIT EASIER TO DEAL WITH.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
OVERVIEW OKAY ALREADY OF THE
SPECIFIC SPENDING PROPOSALS IN
THIS BUDGET AGAIN THAT'S
NINETEEN NINETEEN POINT ONE
BILLION- A NEW PROPOSALS. BUT
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION FOR
ONE TIME ACTIVITIES TWO POINT
SIX BILLION ONGOING- I'LL ADD
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF DETAIL. ON
ONE AREA THAT'S IN YOUR GENDER.
WHICH IS PENSIONS- SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOTH HAVE
EXPERIENCED LARGE. INCREASES IN
PENSION COSTS OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS- THE JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET PLAN PROVIDED TWO
POINT THREE BILLION FOR A ONE
TIME COST RELIEF. I SPREAD
ABOUT EVENLY OVER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THE STATE ESSENTIALLY BOUHT
DOWN COSTA DISTRICTS WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE PAID OUT OF THE
LOCAL OPERATING BUDGETS. EVEN
WITH THAT RELEASE KIND OF
LOOKING AHEAD TO TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO DISTRICTS ARE STILL
LOOKING AT COST INCREASES AT
LEAST A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
POTENTIALLY AS LARGE AS HALF A
BILLION. BUT A MUCH LARGER
INCREASE- LOOKS LIKELY FOR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE-
CURRENT PROJECTIONS ARE THAT.
AS THAT ONE TIME RELEASED
EXPIRES IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE DISTRICTS MIGHT BE
LOOKING AT AN INCREASE. OF
AROUND ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. TURNING TO SOME OF OUR
COMMENTS I THINK ONE KEY ASPECT
OF THE OF THIS YEAR'S UDGET IS
THAT IT CONTAINS A LARGE ONE
TIME QUESTION. OF THE FUNDING
THAT SPECIFICALLY ATTRIBUTABLE
TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO A
LITTLE OVER FIVE BILLION
HISTORY ONE TIME ACTIVITIES AND
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FEATURE OF
THIS BUDGET BECAUSE THAT HELPS
QUESTION THE BUDGET AGAINST
SOME OF THE ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES- THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. I REDUCING THE
LIKELIHOOD OF CUTS TO ONGOING
PROGRAM IS- IF REVENUE DOESN'T
COME IN AS STRONG AS WE EXPECT
EITHER BY NAY OR POTENTIALLY A
YEAR FROM NOW. ON THE ECONOMIC
SUPPORT PROPOSAL I WON'T GO
INTO THAT TOO MUCH YOU'VE
ALREADY TALKED TO QUITE A BIT
ABOUT THAT- WE WOULD SUGGEST
THINKING ABOUT SOMETHING A
LITTLE BIT SMALLER AND MORE
TARGETED IN THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PUT
FORWARD- AS- AS THE CHAIR AND
OTHER MEMBERS MENTIONED ARE.
ALREADY DISTRICTS RECEIVED MORE
THAN SEVEN BILLION AND ONE TIME
FLEXIBLE FUNDS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- THE LATEST. FEDERAL ACTION
DECEMBER IT WILL PROVIDE
ROUGHLY ANOTHER SIX BILLION
ANYONE TWENTY TWO. AND SO
RATHER THAN A THIRD ROUND OF A
BROAD PROBABLY FLEXIBLE
FUNDING. WE THINK YOU COULD
MAKE PROVIDE A SMALLER
AUGMENTATION AND MAYBE MAKE
SOME MORE PROGRESS AND SOME OF
THE KEY PRIORITIES THAT YOU'VE
ARTICULATED. AROUND WE OPENING
AND MAKING UP FOR FUNDING LOS.
UP WE ALSO THINK YOU COULD
CONSIDER. A FUNDING A FEW LESS-
IF YOU'RE A NEW INITIATIVES-
THIS BUDGET HAS AROUND A DOZEN-
NEW PROPOSALS ACROSS CHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AROUND
HALF I ONE TIME AFTER I'M GOING.
AND WE DO THINK SOME OF THOSE
PROPOSALS ARE REASONABLE MOVING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT
THIS IS A LOT TO PUT FORWARD-
IN THE MID IN THE MIDST OF A
PANDEMIC RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THAT SO MANY NEW
PROPOSALS- WITH THAT LARGE
NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES THE THEIR
INDIVIDUAL IMPACT MIGHT BE
DILUTED A LITTLE BIT. AND IT
COULD SHIFT ATTENTION AWAY FROM
SOME OF THE CORE PROGRAMS AND
PRIORITIES THAT YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER. AND THEN LASTLY
WE RECOMMEND- ALLOCATING MORE
FUNDING FOR BOTH PAYING DOWN
DEFERRALS AND ADJUSTING PENSION
COSTS. UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET A LITTLE OVER FOUR
BILLION WOULD REMAIN DEFERRED
AT THE END OF TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. WE THINK YOU COULD MAKE
MORE PROGRESS ON THAT THAT
WOULD GET THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET BACK IN
BALANCE. I RELY ON GOING-
PROGRAM COSTS WITH THE FUNDING
THAT'S AVAILABLE TO PAY FOR
THOSE PROGRAMS WE THINK THAT
MAKES SENSE- WE ALSO THANK YOU
COULD- SET ASIDE SOME FUNDING
NOW TO DEAL WITH THE LARGE
PENSION COST INCREASES THAT'S-
LIES AHEAD IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU SET
ASIDE EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION YOU
COULD PROVIDE A MUCH SMOOTHER-
STEP UP FROM. TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. WOULD
MAKE THOSE COSTS MUCH EASIER
FOR DISTRICTS TO DEAL WITH- D.
SOME LOCAL BUDGET PRESSURE. AND
POTENTIALLY MAKE A DISTRICT
PROGRAMS AND OTHER ACTIVITIES
THAT THEY'RE PUTTING IN PLACE
NOW. EASIER JUST TO SUSTAIN A
LONG TERM BASIS. SO I THINK
THAT- AND IT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMENTS BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
ABOUT ARE NOT ANALYSIS OR OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL. YES THANK
YOU JUST ONE UNDERSTAND THE
NUMBERS CORRECTLY AND I DON'T
KNOW THIS QUESTION FOR
DEPARTMENT FINANCER WHOEVER
THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL- I GUESS SURPLUS OR ONE
TIME FUNDS FOURTEEN POINT NINE
BILLION GOING TO SCHOOLS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FOURTEEN POINT NINE SO OUT OF
THAT FOURTEEN POINT NINE
BILLION HOW MUCH THAT IS ONE
TIME AND HOW MUCH IS. OF THAT
IS ON. THE SOMEONE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL SO I CAN JUST SPEAK
TO THE- THAT THE REVENUE NUMBER
YOU MENTIONED IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE INCREASES IN THE
GUARANTEED. AND THEN WITHIN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WITHIN
THAT GROWTH IN THE GUARANTEED
ACROSS ALL THREE YEAR IS
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- THERE'S
A TOTAL OF NINETEEN POINT ONE
BILLION IN YOUR PROPOSALS.
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION OF
THAT IS FOR ONE TIME ACTIVITIES
AND TWO POINT SIX BILLION IS
FOR ONGOING AUGMENTATIONS
MAINLY COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS TO TWO POINT SIX IS
COMMENDED OR THERE'S TWO POINT.
TWO POINT SIX MILLION. FOR ON
GOING. TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
NEW ONGOING PROPOSALS PROPOSALS
OKAY RIGHT MAINLY AND REALLY
IT'S NOT REALLY NEW ACTIVITIES-
IT'S MORE CUTS IT'S CALL YEP
IT'S MAINLY THE L. C. F.
COLLECT OKAY SO HOW HOW MANAGED
IN THE SENATE AND BEEN TRYING
TO THINK MY QUESTION HERE IS A-
HOW I HOW I OPPOSE IT. BUT SO
USE YOU SAYS NO POINT ONE.
TOTAL ADDITION TO PROP NINETY
EIGHT CORRECT THAT'S THE TOTAL
NEW SPENDING ACROSS ALL THREE
YEARS RIGHT BUT ONLY TWO POINT
SIX BILLION IS COMMENDED ON
GOING. THAT'S CORRECT WE WOULD
NOTE THAT- MUCH OF THAT ISN'T
REALLY AVAILABLE FOR ON GOING
MOST OF THAT NINETEEN POINT ONE
BILLION IS. A ONE TIME PAYMENT
WERE MAKING TO SETTLE UP TO THE
HIGHER GUARANTEE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- BUT IN TERMS OF THE
TOTAL THREE YEARS- THE NUMBERS
YOU JUST MENTIONED ARE CORRECT
TWO POINT SIX BILLION I'M GOING
SIXTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION ONE
TIME. OKAY AND WITH REGARD TO
THE PERSON STIRS YOUR COMMENTS
ON PERSONS STIRS- YOU BASICALLY
MENTIONED THAT. INDIA NOT YEARS
OUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACTUALLY
MAYBE EVEN THIS YEAR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE GOING IT IS-
EXPERIENCE AND INCREASE THEIR
PERSON STIRS COSTS YEAH WE'RE
WE'RE PAYING IT DOWN WE HAVEN'T
HAVE HOLES WE FORCED TO DO THAT
DO WE NEED TO MAKE A STRONGER
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT A LARGER
COMMITMENT. I THINK OUR CONCERN
IS THAT THE DEFERRALS THE
PENSION COST INCREASES IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO C.
MANAGEABLE TO US. WITH THAT THE
COAL- THE THREE POINT 84% FOR
LCS SELF. I THINK DISTRICTS CAN
COVER ALL OF THOSE COST
INCREASES THEY'RE FACING IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. BUT THE
INCREASES IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE ARE. MUCH LARGER ONE
POINT SIX BILLION THAT'S
POTENTIALLY EVEN LARGER THAN
THE COLA DISTRICTS MIGHT EXPECT
RECEIVE NEXT YEAR. AND SO WE
THINK YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO
BE IN A POSITION WHERE IN A
YEAR FROM NOW. DISTRICTS. ARE
FACING VERY DIFFICULT INCREASE-
THERE BUT HAVING TO MOVE. PEDAL
AND SOME OF THE- OF MY
IMPLEMENT. SO WE THINK USING
SOME OF THE ONE TIME FUNDING
THAT'S AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW IN
THIS YEAR- COULD MAKE FOR A
MUCH. EASIER A LESS DIFFICULT
BUDGET CONVERSATION A YEAR FROM
NOW. THIS IS A DO YOU HAVE A
NUMBER. SURE SO ONE REASONABLE
ONE KIND OF NUMBER TO PUT OUT
THERE WOULD BE EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION- THAT WOULD BUY DOWN
HALF OF THE ONE POINT SIX
BILLION INCREASE IN COSTS AND
WOULD CREATE MORE OF A FAST
MOVING SUBJECT TO REVIEW FROM
THIS YEAR- THROUGH THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS. SO TO. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION. CORRECT
AND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
ANOTHER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
AND IS THAT IN A MILLION ON THE
STREET SIDE OF THE PER SIDE OR
WAS THAT A COMBINATION OF. THAT
WOULD BE A COMBINATION THE END
OF THE A COMBINATION OF BOTH
MOST OF THAT IS RELATED TO
STORIES JUST BECAUSE DISTRICTS
HAVE MORE OF THEIR PAYROLL- FOR
TEACHERS ON CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES- AND THAT WOULD BE AT
THE- THE NUMBERS THAT-
DEPARTMENT FINANCE MENTIONED
EARLIER WITH THE- I BELIEVE
THAT WERE APPROVED IN THE
TWENTY. TWENTY BUDGET PLAN- SO
THAT EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION YOU
ARE CORRECT WOULD BE ON TOP OF
THAT RELEASED THE STATE HAS
ALREADY PROVIDED. THE
DIFFERENCE WOULD BE THAT IT
WOULD BE A DISTRICTS WOULD
RECEIVE IT IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. WHEREAS THE PREVIOUS
ALLOCATION OF OVER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. SO YOU'RE THERE
YOU'RE THINKING ANOTHER EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION- DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
COMMENT ON THAT IS THERE. DO DO
DO THEY HAVE A CONCERN THAT THE
OUT YEARS THAT THE PERSON'S
RESPONSE ARE GOING TO. BE A
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN ON DISTRICTS
AND- MAYBE WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT. ADDRESSING THAT UP
FRONT. I SEE THIS YEAR. AGAIN
ORDER TO FINANCE- MISTER
CLINTON MEMBERS ARE PRECINCT-
THE QUESTION AND CERTAINLY
VALIDATE THINK WE- WE VALUE YOU
KNOW THE ON GOING. COST
RESEARCH I WANT TO SAY
RESTRICTION BUT- THAT ELEAZAR
FACING- STARS COURSE COST BEING
ONE OF THE MANY AND WHILE WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL STANCE
ON YOU KNOW THE L. A. O. SMITH
IT'S NOT AN OFFICIAL PROPOSAL-
IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE AWARE OF AND- LOOKING
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. OVER THE COMING
MONTHS- I THINK FOR US IN TERMS
OF THE PUBLISHING NINETY
GUARANTEE I JUST WOULD REMIND
FOLKS THAT DID PREVIOUS
PAYMENTS ARE THE ONES MENTIONED
FROM BEST TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT OF EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
THAT'S GOING OUT. ARE CURRENTLY
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TALK
THAT RATE IN THIS COMING YEAR-
THAT WAS NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND AND SO THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
CONVERSATION AROUND-
APPROPRIATE USE THEIR OF
WHETHER TO BE REAL GENERAL FUND
OR PERHAPS JUST NINETY EIGHT-
CERTAINLY NOT A- UPRIGHT JOB
SCHOOL BUT- A BIG PART OF THE
CONVERSATION I WOULD NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED. OF I'LL LEAVE MY
COMMENTS ABOUT. THANK YOU RIGHT
NOW JUST FOR. THAT YOU OPEN THE
CAR. RECOGNIZE THE ISSUE YOU.
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AYE IT OUT
AS- SO I HEAR AN REGULARLY FROM
MY SPECIAL NEEDS PARENTS- AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- WHO HAVE FELT
THAT FOR SINCE THE LAST
RECESSION- THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
MADE WHOLE AND THE LACK OF
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO EXECUTE
IT PEAS. BOMB IS DIFFICULT- FOR
DISTRICTS AND FOR PARENTS- WHO
ARE REALLY LOOKING FOR SUPPORT
ON THIS IS ONLY GONNA BE
EXACERBATED BY- THE LEARNING
LAWSON REGRESSION THAT ARE
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN ARE
FACING AT THIS VERY MOMENT. AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS ARE
SIGNIFICANT COST FACTORS FOR
SCHOOLS AND CONTRIBUTE TO
BUDGET IMBALANCES INSTRUCTIONAL
DEFICITS THE STATE SHOULD
ENSURE CONTINUE PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING SPECIAL EDUCATION
COSTS PURSUING ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS AND BUILDING THE
BASE GRANTS INCENTIVES INCREASE
INCREASES PROVIDED- IN LAST
YEAR SO MY QUESTIONS I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS. WHY DON'T COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND OTHER CATEGORICAL
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS GET THE
BENEFIT OF THE COMPOUNDED THREE
POINT 84% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OR COLA- PROPOSED BY
LC A PATH WHY ARE WE DELAYING
THE COLAC AT ALL. WHY NOT
PROVIDE. TWO POINT 31% IN THE
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ONE POINT 5% IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND I'VE ONE FOLLOW
UP QUESTION AS WELL OR TO
SEPARATE QUESTION. SURE AGAIN
ERIN PUBLIC FINANCE APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION- UP FOR THE
MINISTRATION I THINK NOW WE
HAVE THE UNENVIABLE TASK TASK
AS SO DO ALL OF YOU ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OF TRYING TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET. AND WE FELT
THAT WITH THE RESOURCES WE
HAVE- GIVEN ALL THE DIFFERENT
PARTIES I THINK- PAYING BACK
THE PEARLS AS WELL- CERTAINLY
COMPLICATES MATTERS EVEN MORE
BECAUSE THE DAILY- POINTED OUT
YOU HAVE THAT. THIS ONE TIME
SURGE WHAT CAN FEEL LIKE A ONE
TIME SURGERY OR BALLOON TO THE
GUARANTEED- IS LARGELY TAKEN UP
WITH JUST GETTING US BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE. AND THAT WAS A
HUGE PART OF A CALCULUS PROBLEM
WE WERE CONTEMPLATING HOW TO
APPLY THE COLA I WOULD NOTE-
THAT COUNTY ALSO THE VEGETATION
WE ARE ACTUALLY PROPOSING THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO. APPLY
THAT COMPOUNDED COLA OF TO THEM
AS WELL AT LEAST FOR THOSE THAT
ARE THAT ARE FUNDED AT THEIR
TARGET LEVEL SO I WOULD I WOULD
MAKE THAT- THAT QUICK NOTE AND
OTHER THAN THAT- WE FELT THAT
THIS. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET I
PROPOSE MAKES- THE MOST KIND OF
APPROPRIATE MIX OF BONDS WITH
AND EVERYTHING ELSE BETWEEN ALL
THE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT RECEIVE
A COLA- DO MEDIA ACTION IN THE
EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS- AND TO
TRY TO HAVE THE BEST MIX OF ON
GOING WELL BETWEEN ONE TIME AND
ONGOING COSTS MOVING FORWARD SO
THAT WAS REALLY. THE ONE THAT
WE WERE TRYING TO LOOK THROUGH
AND BY WE APPROACH IT- IN THE
WAY THAT WE DID I WOULD NOTE
THAT WE IT AT A PANEL WE'RE
GONNA GET TO LATER TODAY WOULD
BE TO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
COMPENSATION FOR- SPECIAL AT
SPECIAL EDUCATION A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND
WE'LL GET INTO. MORE DETAIL
AROUND WHAT ENOUGH PROPOSAL BUT
I DID WANT TO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES PROPOSE STILL MAKING I'M
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION YOU KNOW
THROUGH OTHER WAYS IF NOT.
THROUGH THE AT THE COMPOUND OF
COURSE WAS THE QUICKLY. AND
THAT'S A PERFECT- SEGUE INTO MY
NEXT QUESTION WHICH IS- WHO
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED. FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY AND- OF
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY
INTERVENTION GRANT WILL BE
LIMITED TO SCHOOL. DISTRICTS OR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND HOW OFFICES
OF EDUCATION. THAT SERVED. AGE
CHILDREN WITH EXCEPTION NEEDS.
BE L. I AM NOT A 100% SURE
ISN'T THAT IT'S NOT MY PERSONAL
AREA OF EXPERTISE- AND I'M NOT
SURE THAT ONE OF MY DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE COLLEAGUES WAS ABLE
TO BE ON THE CALL TODAY- IF
THEY ARE THEY CAN SPEAK UP OR
OR PERHAPS THE L. A. MAY- WHO
WORKS ON THAT ISSUE MUST BE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO TRY MAN. I
APOLOGIZE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
LISTEN I WOULD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I COVER SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SO FOR THAT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ELEAZAR- THAT.
HOUSE PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED FOR.
SPECIAL EDUCATION WILL RECEIVE
A FUNDING AND THE REASON WHY WE
SPECIFIED IT FOR ELLIE AS IS
BECAUSE ONLY A HOP ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SERVING
THREE TO FIVE YEAR OLDS SO
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION WHO DO
SERVE WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE.
CORRECT THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THOSE SERVICES DO Y. WITH A WE
AS AND SO IF. THERE ARE- I
GUESS PURCHASE DO NOT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL BASED ON WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE AND WHO WILL FUND
THE SERVICES. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU THIS OF COURSE IS
THE- THE PROBLEM AND THE EIGHT
PIECE WE'RE GOING TO GO NEXT
THE FEDERAL POLICE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DALY
GARDNER AVAILABLE- I THINK WE
HAD A GOOD PRESENTATION FROM
TWENTY THURMOND EARLIER IF WE
HAVE. RATIONS FOR HER AND C. E.
SHE'S AVAILABLE. BUT WE WENT
TO- TO MOVE AHEAD NOW. TO THE
NEXT SECOND SECTION WHICH I
ABOUT- FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR IN BUDGET YEAR.
START WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THEN L. L. THANK THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MELISSA AND
WHAT APARTMENT OF FINANCE- I'LL
JUST START OFF BY GIVING A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF THE
THOROUGHLY FUNDING PROVIDED IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT AND I'LL PASS IT OVER TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
COPE WITH EXPENDITURES IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AND HOW THE
FUNDING HAS BEEN USED. THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ALLOCATED SIX POINT FOUR
BILLION AND ONE TIME FEDERAL
CORONAVIRUS AID RELIEF AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT COURTS
CARE ACT FUNDING FOR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION THIS INCLUDED FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS RELIEF FUND FIRST
THEY ARE ASKED DURING A JAN
FIFTY FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S EMERGENCY
EDUCATIONALLY FUND OR GEAR. AT
ONE POINT SIX BILLION FROM THE
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EMERGENCY. RELIEF FUND ARE
ASKED THEIR- THE PUBLIC BILLION
IN SIERRA ALONG THE THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE TWO. FROM
HERE ALONG WITH BY HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION. IN OPPOSITION
EIGHT COMBINE IT TOGETHER A
TOTAL OF FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION FOR LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION- THIS FUNDING WAS.
TO ADDRESS VARIOUS ISSUES IN
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND ALLOW FOR BROAD
USE OF EXPANDING LEARNING
SUPPORTS INCREASING
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME AS WELL AS
DEVICES IN CONNECTIVE ITTY FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING. AND
INTEGRATED STUDENT SUPPORTS
JEFF OTHER BARRIERS INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND ACCESS TO
SCHOOL MEALS. I ALSO WANTED TO
NOTE THAT THE SPENDING DEADLINE
FOR THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
FOR THE C. R. AFT WAS
ORIGINALLY DECEMBER THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY. BUT HAS BEEN
EXTENDED WITH THE SECOND
THOROUGHLY PACKAGE TO DECEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
PROPOSED A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE RELATED TO THIS
FUNDING TO EXTEND THE
EXPENDITURE DEADLINE THROUGH
MAY THIRTY FIRST. AND THIS WILL
ALLOW AT LEAST A REPORT ANY
UNSPENT BALANCE TO THE
DEPARTMENT BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN ORDER TO
ALLOW TIME TO RECOVER AND
REALLOCATE FUNDS IF NEEDED.
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT ILLEGAL.
THEIR ALLOCATION BUT HAVING
COULD THIS LANGUAGE AT THE
CONTINGENCY TO ENSURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY. FIND SOMEONE THAT THE
RETURN APPOINTMENT FUNDING TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN
ADDITION TO THE FUNDS PROVIDED
FOR LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION
ONE POINT SIX BILLION WORTH
PROVIDER FROM AFTER FOR THE
CORPORATE NOT PREVENTING
PREPARING FOR AND RESPONDING TO
COPE AT NINETEEN. WHICH
INCLUDED A BROAD RANGE OF
ALLOWABLE USES FROM ADDRESSING
LEARNING LOSS TO THE PARENTS
SCHOOL STORY OPENING. 90% OF
THIS FUNDING OR ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION WAS TO BE ALLOCATED
ELLIE EIGHT BASED ON THE
PROPORTION OF TOTAL ONE PART
EIGHT ALLOCATION. WHICH IS
BASED ON HOW. LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN. THE
REMAINING 10% OF THE FUNDING
WAS PROVIDED FOR AN INCREASE
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
SCHOOL MEALS. A GRANT PROGRAM
FOR IMPLEMENTING THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS MODEL AND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. FOR
ALLOCATING AND OVERSEEING THE
CARE THAT FUNDING. SIMILARLY
THE MOST RECENT FEDERAL AID
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE
AND RELIEF SUPPLEMENTAL A
COOPER APPROPRIATIONS ACT
SIGNED INTO LAW LATE DECEMBER.
PROVIDED SIX POINT SEVEN
BILLION FROM THE ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY REALLY FIND WHICH WE
CALL OUR ANSWER TO. THIS
FUNDING WAS SIMILAR-
REQUIREMENT THAT'S AFTER ONE IN
THAT 90% OF THE FUNDING OR SIX
BILLION A BE PROVIDED TO AT
LEAST BASED ON THE PROPORTION
STYLE ONE ALLOCATION. THE STATE
DOES NOT HAVE DISCRETION ON HOW
THE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED OR THE
USE OF THE FUNDS THIS IS A
SPECIFIED IN FEDERAL LAW. THE
NEW FUNDING FACT. WILL BE
PLAYING ON IN FOR THE BY THE L.
A. L. BY WANT TO KNOW THAT WE
RECEIVED APPROVAL FROM THE JAIL
BE SPEECH PROCESS AND ALLOCATE
THE SIX BILLION AS REQUIRED TO
GO OUT TO AN EARLY AGE. THE
THUNDER TELL ONE ALLOCATIONS.
AND THIS FUNDING WILL ASSESS
GOLDEN ADDRESSING IMMEDIATE
NEEDS RELATED TO CONNECTIVITY
MENTAL HEALTH NUTRITION AND
OTHER AREAS TO HELP FACILITATE
SCHOOL RE OPENING AND MITIGATE
LEARNING LOST. THIS FUNDING IS
ALSO AVAILABLE TO COVER COSTS
DATING BACK TO MARCH. THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE BEGINNING
THANK. AND LAST UGLY FIFTEEN.
WAS PROVIDED THROUGH THE CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT OR
CDBG. PHYSICAL CHILD CARE COSTS
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC. THIS
INCLUDED ALLOCATION FOR
EMERGENCY VOUCHERS STIPENDS
PAYMENTS FOR NON OPERATIONAL
DAYS DUE TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS AND FAMILY FEE
WAIVERS- IN LATE OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
TEN MILLION FROM THE C. R. S.
WHAT MADE AVAILABLE TO OFFSET.
THE CDBG CAR. AND THE FUNDING
WILL REIMBURSE PROVIDERS FOR
WAVE FAMILY FEES THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL EMERGENCY.
ALTERNATE. PAYMENT SPOT- I
THINK WITH MIKE. I AM HAPPY TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE THAT THE PANEL.
BUT WILL NOW PASS WITH A TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF. TO GO OVER THE
EXPENSE RELATED THE RELIEF. FOR
BY TODAY. OKAY. AS YOU HAVE
JUST MENTIONED ELOISE RECEIVED
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR A NUMBER OF
KERR'S ACT SOURCES THESE
INCLUDE THE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION IN CORONAVIRUS REALLY
FUNDS R. C. R. I. FUNDS AND THE
STATE ALLOCATED THOSE TO
EDUCATION WHICH WAS COMBINED
WITH THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE
MILLION IN FEDERAL GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY EDUCATION REALLY CARE
FUNDS AND FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND TO
CREATE A FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION IN THE LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION FUNDING. THE L. ON
MAP DOLLARS AS THEY WERE
CALLED. I HAD TO BE USED FOR
ACTIVITIES THAT DIRECTLY
SUPPORT PEOPLE ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AND MITIGATE
LEARNING LAST RELATED TO CODE
NINETEEN SCHOOL CLOSURES. IN
ADDITION ELOISE RECEIVED ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IN
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF OR AFTER
FUNDS. WHICH WERE ALLOCATED
BASED ON THE ALLEY IS SERRA
TITLE ONE. THE C. COMPLETED ITS
THIRD REPORTING CYCLE IN
JANUARY FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDS
WHICH CAPTURED EXPENDITURES
FROM MARCH FIRST. TO DECEMBER
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY.
POLICE HAVE REPORTED HAVING
EXPENDED OR OBLIGATED 99% OF C.
R. FUNDS. AND SEE OUR FUNDS
MAKE UP ABOUT 83% OF THE TOTAL
FUNDING FOR ALUMASC.
FURTHERMORE THE DATA REFLECTED
THAT THE MAJORITY OF C. R.
FUNDS ABOUT 59% WERE USED FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING WHICH
INCLUDED BUT ISN'T LIMITED TO.
TECHNOLOGICAL IMPROVEMENTS SUCH
AS INCREASING BROADBAND
CAPACITY SOFTWARE PURCHASES
THAT ENABLE DISTANCE LEARNING
HARDWARE PURCHASES FOR STUDENTS
AND THEIR TEACHERS SUCH AS
LAPTOPS OR TABLETS.
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
NECESSARY FOR DISTANCE LEARNING
STAFF TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE QUALITY DISTANCE
LEARNING. THERE IS A LARGE
PORTION OF UNEXPECTED FUNDS IN
DEAR ESTHER AND GENERAL FUND.
THIS RANGES FROM A LOW OF 73%
OF THE GENERAL FUND REMAINING
TO A HIGH OF 89% OF YOUR
REMAINING. HOWEVER I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS ALIGNS WITH CITY EASE
EXPECTATIONS ALLEYS WERE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED TO SPEND
THEIR C. R. FUND ALLOCATIONS
FIRST GIVEN THAT THE ORIGINAL
DEADLINES. FOR USING VR FUNDS
WAS DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FOR CONTEXT THE GENERAL
FUND DOES NOT EXPIRE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
YOUR DOESN'T EXPIRE UNTIL
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
COLLECTING DATA FOR THE FIRST
FEDERALLY REQUIRED ANNUAL
REPORT FOR AFTER AND YOUR
EXPENDITURES. AND THAT COVERS
THE TIMELINE OF MARCH
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
SEPTEMBER THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY.
BASED UPON THE FEDERAL FISCAL
YEAR. WE WILL HAVE MORE DATA
THIS YEAR ON THOSE FUNDS ONCE
WE COMPLETE. THE REPORTING
CYCLE IN THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
THAT INCLUDES OUR COMMENTS ON
THE FEDERAL FUNDS THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU- I HAVE. A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS HERE. ONE
IS FOR THE L. A. ON ONE'S FOR
CD FIRST LET'S WE HAVE CD RIGHT
HERE- WHAT TO RAISE THE ISSUE
ABOUT THE MONEY WE PUT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR THAT.
POSITIVE TRIGGER FOR FUNDS FOR
CHILD CARE WHICH WOULD GO TO
ADDRESS. FAMILY FOR FAMILY
FEES- INCREASE LOTS AND THE
RATE STIPEND- THE PHARMACY
ENDING IS THAT. FEDERAL MONEY
IS COMING STE- SHORTLY. AND SO
DO WE HAVE A DO WE HAVE A TIME
WHEN GET THESE MONIES OUT THE
DOOR. TO UTILIZE FOR OUR WITH.
FOR OUR FRAGILE AND DESPERATELY
NEEDED CHILD CARE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE IN. EXACTLY
THAT QUESTION IS FOR IS
PRECEDED IT IF IT'S NOT IF WE
DON'T HAVE ANY ANSWER I GUESS
THE REQUEST FOR ME AND THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT WAS THE IT
THE INDICATION THAT WE ADOPTED
THIS IN JULY. IT'S OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THE MONEY GETS
OUT- RIGHT AWAY. WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
GETTING THOSE DOLLARS OUT THE
PROCESS HAS BEEN MORE DIFFICULT
THAN ANTICIPATED AND WE WILL
KEEP YOU UPDATED ON THAT
TIMELINE. OKAY THANK YOU AND
THEN THAT MIGHT NEXT QUESTION
IS FOR THE L. A. O. FIRST OF
ALL GOING BACK TO LAST SECTION
I THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA TO
USE SOME OF THE ONE TIME MONEY
TO DEAL WITH THAT PERSON STARES
AS MR O'DONNELL WHAT WAS
MENTIONING. CERTAINLY WILL BE
ABLE TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND SO IF WE DO GET THIS
POTENTIAL THIRTEEN BILLION IN
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL MONEY- WHAT
COULD THOSE MONIES BE USED FOR
I KNOW THAT. CONGRESS HASN'T
PASSED IT IS STILL QUESTIONABLE
THAT'S GONNA BE THAT THAT THE
AMOUNT BUT IS SWIMMING THAT
THERE IS. THIS NEXT ROUND OF-
OF SUPPORT GOING OUT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHAT COULD WHAT COULD
WE EXPECT AS FAR AS THE
UTILIZATION. OF THAT. THAT PART
OF MONEY. THIS IS FOR LA UP. I
HAVE A GROUP OF ALL OF THE OHIO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. GREAT I'M
JUST RESPONDING I THINK IT
GENERAL. YOUR AVAILABLE TO LOOK
ALONG THE EXTRA. BUT IF THE
FUNDING LOOKS LIKE PREVIOUS
ROUNDS OF FUNDING THE FIRST
YEAR. EARLY SOURCES OF THAT
COULD BE USED FOR. A VARIETY OF
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE REALLY TO
COMPANY. AND NOT ALLOW-
DISTRICTS PROVIDES A FOR.
ADDRESSING HUNTING LAWSUIT
MECHANISM PARTY I THINK WE HAVE
A SEEN ANY REALLY ANY TALK THAT.
THE DEATH NOT ARE OVER
EXPECTATIONS FOR ONE OF THE KEY.
BUT BECAUSE I WAS OF MY
COLLEAGUES PROPONENT EARLIER
SPEAKING ABOUT THE SORT OF- ALL
OF THE THINGS THE- ACTIONS
CONCERT WITH YOUR- YOUR TO
BRING. RIGHT NOW- OUT WHAT WHAT
IT WOULD WAYS TO THE STATE BE
ABLE TO YOU. THAT FUNDING ONE
CONCERN I WAS THAT WE HAVE AND
WE ARE- IN THE NEXT. YOU WILL
MORE DO. COMMITTEE ON THE
PROPOSALS BUT- I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS WE CONCERNED A
LITTLE BIT IS A THE AMENDED OF
ONE FUNDING MIGHT BECOME TO
SCHOOL. IT THIS COMING. BUT-
THE SECOND ROW OF FEDERAL TO
STATES- IS RECEIVING A GIFT SIX
DOLLAR. GOVERNMENT IS FOR
POINTS BILL DOLLARS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR. ACADEMICS OF. BOTH
OF THOSE ARE SOME WE NEED TO BE
SPENT BY OUR BY PUTTING THAT OF
THE- FISCAL YEAR I THINK. IN OF
THE FEDERAL LANGUAGE LAWS SO
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWO AND THAT
IS A LOT OF THIS ONE TIME
FUNDING DISTRICTS MEET SUPPLY
IF THEY ARE SPEND. THOSE
DOLLARS COULD BE UTILIZED THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. IN THIS CASE I
THINK YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE
FACT THAT THESE ARE ALSO MANY
HAVE TENDED TO HAVE A TEMPER
SOME STATES OUTSIDE RECEIVED
SOME DISCUSSION AROUND USE THE
FUNDING AS OPPOSED TO JUST
DISTURBING THE FUNDING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. WILL VARY
FROM- WITH THE STATE HAS SOME
FLEXIBILITY WITH TO DO WE THINK
I HAVE A PART OF IT WILL BE TO
DEPEND ON THE OVERALL ARM
COMPLEMENT OF WHAT ELSE IS
GOING ON IN THE REST OF YOUR
BUDGET. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
SOMEBODY YOU COULD CONSIDER IF
OR OR WHERE THERE IS A GREAT
BEST PLACES TO I'M INCREASE
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE MORE-
SERVICES OR PROVIDE MORE
SUPPORT FOR MANY LOS ONE
EXAMPLE BE TRYING TO DO TO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOL PROGRAM OR
SUMMER ACTIVITIES- OPTION FOR
EXAMPLE WE DO THINK SCHOOLS ARE
COMING BACK WE THINK SOMETHING
IS AMISS HERE SOME OF THE
COMING BE USED TO COVER COSTS
OF TESTING. THERE WILL BE. IF
THE FUNDING COMES FROM THE-
POSSIBILITY TUESDAY MAKES ON
HOW TO DO THAT THE STATE ALSO
WITHOUT TEMPERATURE PATTERSON
YOU CAN BE USING IT. RATHER
THAN FINDING ANYTHING IF
DISTRICT- WE COULD STATE ARE
WOULD HELP AND ALL ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE MORE PROMISING IS
A. FULL OKAY. QUESTION MR
O'DONNELL AND MAYBE THIS WAS
DISCUSSED- BUT I DO GET THAT
QUESTION A CAME INTO MY OFFICE
ABOUT THE GEAR FUNDING OF THIS
WOULD BE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION. DID YOU BROACH
THAT YET. ARE YOU APPLYING FOR
A THREE HUNDRED MILLION
APPARENTLY. WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
CURRENTLY I THINK THE DEADLINE
IS FEBRUARY EIGHTH- WE'RE STILL
EVALUATING THE GUIDANCE THAT
WAS RELEASED RECENTLY ON SECURE
FUNDING AT THIS TIME. THANK IS
THERE IS THERE A REASON YOU
WOULD NOT APPLY FOR THE. I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A REASON
WHY WE WOULD NOT APPLY IT'S
JUST THAT WE'RE STILL
EVALUATING THE GUIDANCE- WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO MAKE
DECISIONS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. IN OUR CLINIC
UPCOMING WEEKS ON THIS MONEY.
AN IMMEDIATE ISSUE THANK YOU.
OKAY FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR THIS
PANEL ISSUE NUMBER.TWO PASSING
AND WHAT WILL THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING I THANK YOU ISSUE
NUMBER- ISSUE NUMBER THREE
WE'RE GONNA THIS IS A MAJOR
ONGOING PROP NINETY EIGHT
PROPOSALS WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE L. A. AND
THEN- CD E. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HELLO AGAIN YES AND
HER IDEA BARBARA FINANCE GOING
TOGETHER- PRETTY OVERVIEW OF
SEVERAL OF THE- SEVERAL OF THE-
GOVERNOR'S. SPENDING THAT HELP
YOU HAVE PROBABLY BEEN THE MOST
NOTABLE WANTED TO BUILD AND
WE'VE ALREADY TOUCHED ON UP TO
THIS POINT SO I'LL KEEP MY
COMMENTS. PRETTY GREAT- THE
PROPOSED INCREASE FOR LTFS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE A COMPOUNDED
COLA OF THREE POINT 84%
REPRESENTING THAT THE SPENDING
COLA IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
WELL AS THE- ADDITIONAL CALL IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OF ONE
POINT 5% OCT TWO BILLION UP AND-
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OVER
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ESTIMATED. LEVEL WITH COUNTY
OFFICER THAT MADE IT TO RECEIVE.
OPTIMALLY TEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT WELL. THIS BRINGS TOTAL
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTH EFFECTS
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. ALL THE OTHER
KEIKO PROGRAMS NORMALLY
RECEIVING A COLA WILL RECEIVE
ONE- AND EQUAL TO ONE POINT 5%
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO-
PRESENTING ONGOING INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY SIX.
MILLION DOLLARS NOT FOR K.
TWELVE PROGRAMS AGAIN-
ADDITIONALLY AS I MENTIONED
BRIEFLY EARLIER IN THE BUDGET
DOES PROPOSE AN AUGMENTATION OF
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING PROPOSITIONNINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY
INTERVENTION PRESCHOOLGRANT
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT. THE
PURPOSE OF THESE GRANTS TO
INCREASE AVAILABILITY OF
EVIDENCE BASED SERVICES THAT
DIRECTLY SUPPORTS WILL GRADING
INFANT TODDLERS. AND
PRESCHOOLERS- WE ALSO HAVE
SEVERAL OTHER SMALL PROPOSALS-
BUT I WILL LET- MY COMMENT AND
THERE AND I HAVE A COLLEAGUE ON
THE LINE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO.
SPEAK IN MORE DETAIL TO
ANYTHING I'VE MENTIONED SO FAR
OR- ANY OTHER PROPOSALS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE QUESTIONS ALL
THANK YOU. GREAT I L. L. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAMBERS MICHAEL
PEREZ WITH THE NEXT YEAR
ANALYSTS ALL THINGS JUST A FEW
COMMENTS REGARDING THAT COLOR
FOR LCS SEVEN KIND OF LOCAL
PROGRAMS. FIRST WE THINK THERE
FINANCES ESTIMATE OF A ONE
POINT 5% COLDER FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR GET REASONABLE. WITH STATE
WILL HAVE THE FINAL NUMBER IN
APRIL BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES THE ESTIMATED
THAT EVERY BUDGET. I'M
PROVIDING THE ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT 3% 21% COLOR JUST UNTIL
SEE IF THAT WAS NOT PROVIDING
THE CURRENT YEAR. WE THINK TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WANT TO PROVIDE MORE I'M GOING
FUNDING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BRING MY MONEY NOW SEE IF THAT
WAS GOING TO DO THAT AS A
BENEFITS ALL DISTRICTS. FIVE
SISTERS FLEXIBILITY AND
PROVIDES MORE FUNDING FOR
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. UNLESS
THING. TO THE EXTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT BE INTERESTED
IN PROVIDING THE ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT 31% COLLECT THE KIND OF.
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS TO RECEIVE
DOUBLE EVERYTHING COLOR. WE
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS
WOULD COST ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
AND FORTY MILLION MORE THAN THE
AMOUNT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET. ON THE NET
OUR COM BUT I HAVE A CHANCE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK. AND DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. WHILE WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THE THREE POINT
EIGHT FOUR CALL IN LC AT THAT
WOULD ASK ADMINISTRATION
ALLEGED LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
PROVIDING THE LEVEL OF QUALITY
PROGRAMS OUTSIDE OF IT CNS AT
THE END YEAH I NOTED THERE WILL
BE A TREMENDOUS INCREASE IN
COSTS FOR SCHOOLS. TO SAFELY
REOPEN IN THE- AND IT'S
PROBABLY. ANY PROGRAMS OUTSIDE
OF THE EVENT WOULD BENEFIT FROM
THIS ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AS
WELL. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
COMMENTS AND WE ARE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. ANY QUESTION.
GREAT AND- HAVING NO QUESTIONS.
GET A MOVE ON TO. GREAT AND I
HAVE. TO THE SEVEN. SO I'M THE
FISCAL CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM THAT- F. C. M.
A. T. IS CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
RESOURCE TO MONITOR AND GUIDE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCY FISCAL
HEALTH THIS HEARING WILL
PROVIDE- THE FC MATC ANNUAL
ADDRESS TO UPDATE THE ASSEMBLY
ON THE STATE OF SCHOOL FISCAL
HEALTH. SO ARE A SPEAKER ON
THIS IS MICHAEL FINE OF FISCAL
CRISIS MANAGEMENT ASSISTANT
TEAM. SHE THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR- AND-
MEMBERS ALONE. SURE TO BE WITH
YOU THIS MORNING. GO AHEAD GO
AHEAD MR FINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIR BOB MY PLEASURE TO
JOIN YOU THIS MORNING- I THINK-
AS YOU ALL APPRECIATE THROUGH
YOUR- THROUGH YOUR QUESTIONS IN
THE PRESENTATIONS THAT ARE
PRECEDED ME THAT THAT- IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THERE'S- LESS OF A
BUDGET CRISIS ARE AMONG OUR K.
TWELVE SCHOOLS IN AND REALLY
BECAUSE OF APPORTIONMENT
DEFERRALS HAS BEEN MORE OF A
FOCUS TO MANAGE OTHER CASH
RESOURCES- AS OPPOSED TO THEIR
BUDGETRESOURCES. ON
ADDITIONALLY AS AS WELL
FINANCING ON. THE L. A. O.
ABILITY TO THERE'S BEEN
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF ONE TIME
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO SCHOOLS
AND SO THE BALLOT HAS BEEN
CERTAINLY OCCUPIED A
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF THEIR
FINANCIAL PLANNING AND
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS YEAR AND THAT
IS TO EFFECTIVELY AND
APPROPRIATELY SPEND THOSE
DOLLARS- I WILL. ARE AS AS WE
LOOK AT THE MOST RECENT FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE REPORTING-
WE NOTE THAT AT FIRST INTERIM
REPORT WHICH WAS A DECEMBER
TIME FRAME ARE WE HAVE ONE
DISTRICT AMONG THE STATE I'M
SORRY I WANT TO BACK UP EARLIER
IN THE YEAR WHEN COUNTY OFFICES
HAVE THE TASK OF APPROVING A
SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGETS ARE FOR
THE YEAR WE HAD ONE DISTRICT IN
THE STATE THAT HAVE DISAPPROVED
BUDGET OUT OF THE ELEVEN
HUNDRED PLUS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTY OFFICES- AND SO
THAT'S A- IT. IS SAKE OF THEIR
THIRD CONSECUTIVE DISAPPROVAL-
AND A DISTRICT THAT- OF BOTH
THE COUNTY OFFICE AND OTHERS
CONTINUE TO BE ENGAGED WITH. AT
FIRST IN REPORTING OF THE MOST
RECENT REPORTING PERIOD THAT
WE'VE HAD WHICH WAS MID
DECEMBER AND THIS IS ALL
PLANETARY DATA BASED ON SELF
CERTIFICATIONS. AND REVIEWS BY
COUNTY OFFICES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN ALL
CASES OF NOT COMPLETED ALL OF
THEIR REVIEWS YET THEY STILL
HAVE SOME TIME. TO DO THAT I WE
HAVE FIFTY ONE. DISTRICTS SELF
CERTIFYING THIS QUALIFIED-
FIFTY OF THOSE FIFTY ONE HAVE
THREE OR MORE CONSECUTIVE
QUALIFIED. OUR CERTIFICATIONS
IN THREE. HAVE SEVEN OR MORE
QUALIFIED SURE. THE QUALIFY
CERTIFICATE THAT THEY ARE THAT
THEY'RE CERTIFYING AMONG THIS
GROUP- THIS FALL ARE THERE ARE
NO DOWNGRADES BY COUNTY OFFICE
OR BY C. D. E. F. MEANING THAT
ALL THE DATA REPORTING AGAIN
THIS SELF CERTIFY DATA WE ARE
NOT AT THIS MOMENT INTO
SEPARATING THAT ANY COUNTY
OFFICE OR CVE WOULD BE
DOWNGRADING THE DISTRICT FROM
WHAT THEY SELF CERTIFIED. BUT
SOME OF THOSE REVIEWS ARE STILL
ONGOING WE HAVE THREE NEGATIVE
DISTRICTSARE TO HAVE BEEN
ONGOING- OF THOSE TOO- IS SET
UP FOR LACTATION- THIS AT THE
END OF THE CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR
IN WILL BE ABSORBED BY A
NEIGHBORING SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
I OVERSAW ALL. OF THEIR THEIR
NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION WE HAVE
ONE NOW ARE A NATIVE
CERTIFICATION IT'S A LARGE
SCHOOL DISTRICT- BELKHIR OF
UNIFIED- HAS- CAUGHT BOTH
COUNTY OFFICE IN. THE REST OF
US THAT MARIN THESE MATTERS A
LITTLE BIT BY SURPRISE IN THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN POSITIVE- HAVE A
LONG HISTORY ACTUALLY OF A VERY
STRONG FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT. OF
THEIR OWN NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION WE BELIEVE IS
VERY SHORT TERM- THEY ARE A
DISTRICT THAT- IS FAIRLY
CONSERVATIVE IN HOW THEY
APPROACH THINGS IN THE- MOVED
TO THE NEGATIVE CERTIFICATION
WILLIAMS FULL DISCLOSURE. THAT.
THEY SAW- JERRY IS J. COMING
THEIR WAY ON THE THIRD YEAR OUT
SO IT'S NOT IN IMMEDIATE ISSUE-
THIS CURRENT YEAR OR NEXT YEAR
BUT THE THIRD ISSUE A THIRTY
YEAR OUT. AND WE ALREADY KNOW
FROM WORK THAT WE'VE DONE WITH
THE DISTRICT- IN THE DISK INPUT
THE DISTRICT HAS GIVEN US THAT
IF THEY WERE TO APPLY THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL COLA. OF THREE POINT
EIGHT. NINE IN THE ONE NEXT
YEAR. ARE IN IN THE SUBSEQUENT
CALLS AFTER THAT- THAT THEY
WILL BE- IN A POSITIVE
CONDITION. IN SO LITTLE LESS
CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION- THAN OTHERS.
CURRENTLY IN IT IN THIS YEAR WE
HAVE FOR LACK OF GOING CONCERN
DISTRICTS THESE ARE SIMILAR IN
NATURE TO A NEGATIVE-
CERTIFICATION BY DISTRICT BUT
THEY DON'T GO HAND IN HAND WITH
EITHER THE FIRST OR THE SECOND
IN A REPORT. OTHERS FOR LACK OF
GOING CONCERN DISTRICTS WERE
ALL DESIGNATED BY THEIR COUNTY
OFFICES EARLIER IN THE FALL ONE
IS UR UNIFIED IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BELLFLOWER UNIFIED IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY MONTEBELLO
UNIFIED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
NORMAL CITY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN BUTTE COUNTY WE ARE
ENGAGED HAVE BEEN ENGAGED- WITH
THREE OF THOSE FOUR ON
DISTRICTS. AT THIS CURRENT TIME
WE HAVE ONE COUNTY OFFICE THE
SOFT CERTIFIED QUALIFIED ALL
OTHERS OF CERTIFIED POSITIVE
THAT ONE DISTRICT OR THAT ONE
COUNTY OFFICE IS A SAN
FRANCISCO. WELL I COUNTY OFFICE
OF THAT AND BY THE WAY THEY ARE
A SINGLE. SINGLE SINGLE COUNTY.
USED SINGLE DISC ARE WITHIN THE
K. SAN FRANCISCO. STAFFERS
COUNTY OF IN BOTH ENTITIES
CERTIFIED SELF CERTIFIED AS
QUALIFIED. AS NOTED THAT USING
A CHROME IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
JANUARY'S THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN JANUARY WHILE WILL
LIKELY CHANGE A NUMBER OF THE
CERTIFICATIONS ALTHOUGH THE
QUALIFIED CERTIFICATIONS THAT
SECOND ROOM. AND HAVE A
POSITIVE INFLUENCE ON AT LEAST
PROBABLY TEN TO FIFTEEN OF
THOSE DISTRICTS IN S. NOTED
WITH ELK GROVE PROBABLY ONE. I
WOULD POSITIVELY ON ONE
NEGATIVE- CERTIFICATION. BY THE
WAY IT ALL WILL HAVE A POSITIVE
INFLUENCE ON ALL LEDS ARE
SPECIFICALLY CHANGING A
CERTIFICATION FROM FIRST
GENERAL WELL I WOULD EXPECT
THAT TO HAPPEN. S. SECOND
INTERVIEW FOR THOSE NUMBERS I
JUST GAVE YOU OVER THE LAST TWO
AND A HALF YEARS- JEFF MATT.
DIRECTLY ENGAGED WITH THIRTY
TWO DISTRICTS. OVER OF FISCAL.
STABILITY ISSUES SPECIFICALLY
ARM. WHEN WE HAVE COMPLETED
THOSE ENGAGEMENTS THAT 65% OF
THOSE DISTRICTS WE DETERMINED
THAT WERE AT HIGH RISK. OF
INSTABILITY 26% OF MODERATE
RISK AND 9% LOW RISK. ARE AMONG
THOSE THIRTY TWO DISTRICTS WE
HAVE FOUR ON THAT WERE JUST
TRIGGERED- IN THE DECEMBER
REPORTING IN SO WE'RE JUST
STARTING TO ENGAGE. WITH THOSE
FOUR DISTRICTS THOSE WOULD
INCLUDE- DIXON INSISTS A
UNIFIED IN SOLANO OF BILL GROSS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT LOST HILLS
UNION ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN KERN. AND WEST
CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. THIRTY MY
ATTENTION FROM THE ROUTINE AB
TWELVE HUNDRED- CERTIFICATION
AND REPORTING PROCESS THAT
HAPPENS SO BASICALLY THREE
TIMES YOUR BUDGET ADOPTION INTO
EACH OF THE IN REPORTS IN THE
LACK OF GOING CONCERN IN THE
ONGOING DURING THE YEAR I
TURNED MY ATTENTION NOW TO
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FORTY.
REVIEWS OF THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
DISTRICTS INGLEWOOD UNIFIED IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND OAKLAND
UNIFIED IN ALAMEDA. AT FIRST IN
A ROOM ON EAGLE WOULD- REPORTED
A POSITIVE CERTIFICATION AND
THEY'RE PROJECTING NO CURRENT
YEAR OR OUT YEAR DEFICIT FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR. THIS WOULD BE
THEIR THEIR FIRST NON DEFICIT
REPORTING- WE CURRENTLY HAVE
STAFF IN INGLEWOOD A VALUE
WAITING THAT A REPORT IN THE
METRICS THAT GO INTO THAT DATA
ON A TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT WE
CAN PER WITHOUT OR NOT. FOR
OAKLAND THEY REPORTED A FIRST
INTERIM QUALIFIED REPORT THERE
AMONG THE FIFTY ONE THAT WERE
QUALIFIED. THEY ARE REPORTING A
CURRENT YEAR DEFICIT FIRST AN
ARM OF ROUGHLY THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS BUT THEY HAVE YET TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE ROUGHLY SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS CITY BE
EIGHTEEN FORTY IS PROVIDING
THEM IN THE CURRENT YEAR. SO
ONCE THE ACCOUNT FOR THAT- THAT
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT. IS SHOT- WOULD BE
WIPED- CLEAN FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR DO YOU STILL HAVE OUT HERE
ON. THE CONCERN WHICH- ON
DISTRICTS ARE ON THE HER- I
MENTIONED- BOLT IN- I ALSO MET
LOS HILLS. HOWEVER THAT WE THIS
POINT INTENDED MONITOR AS
OPPOSED TO ENGAGE WITH- SHANDON
JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
IN- MONTEREY COUNTY. WHICH
SERVES MONTEREY AND SAN LUIS
OBISPO- COMMITTEES ARE WE ARE
ALSO MONITORING THEIR VERY
SMALL DISTRICT BUT IF BEING.
ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY SOME
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENTS. DATA
CLINTON WAS CONTRA UNIFIED- A
LARGE DISTRICT ARE IN THE BAY
AREA WHILE THE WE BELIEVE IT'S
TIME TO FULLY ENGAGE WITH THEIR-
WITH RESPECT TO SOLVENCY TRENDS
THE TRENDS THAT WE SEE IMPACT
INSOLVENCY. ARM WELL THE FIRST
AND FOREMOST AS THE L. A. O.
HAS DONE A GREAT JOB OF
REPORTING PERIODICALLY OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF MONTHS RESERVES
ARE GENERALLY HIGHER IN OUR K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS RIGHT NOW THAN
THEY WERE A DECADE AGO DURING
pTHEY ENTERED. THE PANDEMIC
PERIOD WITH HIGHER RESERVES AND
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN NEARLY AS
IMPACTED. AS YOUR OWN VERY
FAMILIAR WITH DURING THE
PANDEMIC AS WAS ONCE ARE. ARE
PROJECTED TO BE. MULTI YEAR
PROJECTIONS CAN DO SHOW SOME
DEFICIT TRENDS. BUT AS NOTED
THE GOVERNOR'S- ARE. BUDGET
PROPOSAL WITH THE COMPOUNDED-
TO YOUR COLA- WILL- CHANGED OUT
FOR- PROBABLY 2230% OF THE
QUALIFY DISTRICTS IN THE ONE
NEGATIVE DISTRICT. S. FREQUENT
CONDITION. AMONG THE QUALIFIED
OUR CERTIFICATIONS IS DECLINING
ENROLLMENT I'M MORE THAN 60% OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
DECLINING IN THEIR ENROLLMENT
IN AS YOU APPRECIATE THAT HAS
A- VERY DIRECT FINANCIAL
IMPACT. ADDITIONALLY TRENDS
INDICATE THAT SPECIAL ED COSTS-
CONTINUE TO OUTPACE THE REVENUE
GROWTH LEADING TO HIGHER LEVELS
OF LOCAL CONTRIBUTIONS. AND
THEN AS DISCUSSED MULTIPLE
TIMES BY THE COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING OUR EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION RATES TO CASTERS
IN CALPERS WILL BE INCREASING
AGAIN IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE- SPEAKING OF THAT TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE IS A CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE- IT IS THE THIRD
YEAR OUT IN THE PROJECTIONS.
ARE CURRENTLY- BUT IT IS
DEFINITELY ONE OF THE YEARS
THAT WE ARE WATCHING CAREFULLY
NOT ONLY IMPACTED BY THE CAL
STIRS IN CALPERS EMPLOYER
CONTRIBUTION RATES BUT ALSO BY
ENROLLMENT DECLINES BECAUSE OF
THE SPECIAL. EIGHTY EIGHT
CALLED HARMLESS IT WAS IN PLACE
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC
PLUS THE TRADITIONAL EIGHTY A
HOLD HARMLESS SO YOU IN PLACE
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO MOST
DECLINING SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL
NOT FEEL THE IMPACT. OF THEIR
DECLINE UNTIL TWO OF THEIR
MULTI YEAR DECLINES IN TEL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND SO
THAT WILL NOT THAT FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE LOOKING
OUT. IS GOING TO HAVE WELL.
LARA IS SOMETHING WE WANT TO
PAY CLOSER TO. AS ARE THE ONLY-
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO- SPOKE
TO THE MAGNITUDE A ONE TIME
DOLLARS- WHILE WELCOMED A
CERTAINLY PROVIDE SOME.
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAN WHAT THEY'RE
ACCUSTOMED TO DOING BY USING
THOSE FUNDS THAT HAVE A LONG
TERM IMPACT ON. OTHER STUDENTS
ARE POSITIVE IMPACT ON THEIR
STUDENTS. BEING SMART ABOUT HOW
THOSE ARE USED TO DEAL WITH
BOTH IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND LONG
TERM. NEEDS AROUND STUDENT
SAFETY STUDENT EMOTIONAL SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH- INSTANTLY
STUDENTS LOS. ANY ANY LEARNING
LOSS WILL BE IMPORTANT.
SWITCHING ARE TOPICS- VERY
QUICKLY- SPEAK TO EXTRAORDINARY
AUDIT CIVIC MATT'S CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN OUR ACTIVITIES DOWN
SLIGHTLY- FROM NORMAL WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF OUR STAFF CONTINUING
OF AN EXTRAORDINARY AUDIT
REQUEST BY EIGHT I COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS TO LOOK AT THE
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOLS
NETWORK- WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT
ALL OF THE CHARTERS- IN THAT
NETWORK BUT ONLY EIGHT OF THEM
HAT WERE IDENTIFIED BY. THE
SPECIFIC COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
IN THE IMAC REQUEST A WERE WERE
WELL UNDERWAY WITHOUT AUDIT
PROCESS WE'RE STILL MONTHS AWAY
FROM COMPLETION. ALSO SWITCHING
GEARS WHILE THE FOCUS HERE IS
ON K. TWELVE IT WOULD BE REMISS
NOT TO OUR RACE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE WORKING THERE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING FISCAL
DISTRESS- WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
THOSE IN WERE ENGAGED DIRECTLY
IN THREE OF THOSE RIGHT NOW
LASSEN IN LASSEN COUNTY PALOMAR
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. IN PERALTA
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY- WE HAVE
ISSUED REPORTS PREVIOUSLY ON
PALOMAR PERALTA WERE CURRENTLY
IN LASSEN WORKING THERE WILL
HAVE A REPORT COMING OUT
SHORTLY WE HAVE ONE COMMITTEE
COMPETITION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ON OUR WATCHLIST IN THAT WOULD
BE CITY COLLEGE OF SAN
FRANCISCO. WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
IN AND OUT OF OVER A NUMBER OF
YEARS SO THAT WOULD GIVE YOU A
QUICK GLIMPSE OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PARTNERS WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER FIND THIS. IS ALWAYS AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC THAT. THIS
HELPED OF OURS ALLOW FEW YEARS
WE'VE HAD. OTHER FOR ISSUES AND
NOW WE A WHOLE- YOU KNOW SO. ON
ON TOP. SO I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT A FEW QUESTIONS AND SO.
IT'S INTERESTING- YOU KNOW YOU
UNITED SPOKE AT LENGTH ABOUT
THE FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR
DISTRICTS FOCUSING RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO MY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AT SAC CITY. AND OF
COURSE THERE IS THIS THERE IS
DAHLE THING HAPPENING WE HAVE-
THE DECLINING ENROLLMENT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC BUT THE
SAME TIME. WE'RE SEEING A SURGE
IN ONE TIME REVENUE SO. IT'S
YOU KNOW IT YOU KNOW- THE FALSE
NEGATIVE IF YOU LOOK AT LIKE
SOME TYPE OF A TEST- YOU KNOW-
ANALYSIS AS FAR AS WHAT'S
HAPPENING BUT IT'S REALLY KIND
OF A STAY AS FAR AS WHAT THE
PAIN IS. IS DOWN THE ROAD. A
PLUS THE FACT THAT SOME OF THE
SCHOOLS AREN'T DON'T HAVE TO
UTILIZE MONEY FOR UTILITIES AND
HEATING AND AIR AND- BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES AND- FIELD TRIPS AND
SO FOR TRANSPORTATION SO. IT
JUST. REALLY HAS A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE HOW WE LOOK AT OUR
SCHOOL SOMEONE IF YOU COULD
KIND OF. LOOK AT THAT AND I WAS
INTRIGUED YOU MENTIONED. ELK
GROVE AS THE EXAMPLE AND
THEY'VE BEEN ONE OF THOSE
STABLE DISTRICTS IN OUR REGION
HERE FOR A LONG TIME. SO WE GET
A REPORT OF THEIR- NEGATIVE
CERTIFICATION DUE TO THEIR
ENROLLMENT LOSS AND THE IMPACT
ON THEIR MULTI YEAR BUDGETS.
MAYBE YOU COULD TALK ABOUT
DISTRESSED DISTRICT AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT THOUSAND WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. AND HOW THE
STATE. SHOULD CONSIDER. THESE
ENROLLMENT CLASS- AS WE AS WE
LOOK AT THIS FROM A BUDGET
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS A AS A
POLICY PERSPECTIVE. SURE- THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION MISTER
CHAIRED US SPECIFICALLY TO ELK
GROVE BAND AND- NOW GROUPS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN MOST OF
OUR THEIR DISTRICTS AND THEY'L
GROW FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
HAS CONTINUED TO BE A GROWTH
DISTRICT BY WAY OF ENROLLMENT
THEY FORECASTED GROWTH AGAIN
THIS YEAR IN FACT THEY GAVE- A
LOT OF DATA IN INPUT TO THE
CONVERSATIONS- THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE HOW IN THE SUMMER
IN SB EIGHT TWENTY N. ARE
ALLOWING FOR SOME FUNDING FOR
GROWTH DISTRICTS. IN THOSE IN
THOSE AMENDMENTS TO SENATE BILL
NINETY EIGHT FROM JUNE IN EIGHT
TWENTY ARM AS IS IN IN- IN HELP
GROSS PARTICULAR CASE ARE WHILE
THEY PROJECTED. FOR- OF JUST
OVER HUNDRED. THEY'VE ENDED UP
WITH THE CLIP YEAR OVER YEAR
DECLINE OF JUST OVER FOUR
HUNDRED STUDENTS TO ALMOST A
SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENT. WELCOME
CHANGE FROM WHERE THEY
ANTICIPATED THEY WOULD BE SO
FROM A BUDGET STANDPOINT FROM
AN EXPENDITURE STANDPOINT. THE
BUDGET FOR THE HIGHER NUMBER OF
STUDENTS SO THAT THEY WERE
PREPARED TO SERVE THEM- KERR
AND NOW. IS ONGOING AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THESE ANSWERS YET
YEAH. BUT AS TO THE REASONS WHY
THEY CAN CERTAINLY HAVE THEY
THEY CERTAINLY KNOW THE ANSWERS
TO THE DAY ARE CAN LOOK AT THE
DATA. FOR SOME ANSWERS ABOUT
50% OF THAT DROP IN ENROLLMENT
FOR ALL GROWTH IS IN TKA
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN AND
KINDERGARTEN ARM THAT IS A
TREND THAT WE ARE SEEING WHEN
WE LOOK AT INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS
DATA WE DON'T HAVE STATEWIDE
DATA YET BY GRADE. SPAN BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT INDIVIDUAL DATE
DISTRICTS AND WE ENGAGE WITH
THEM. THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS-
THAT'S A VERY FREQUENT-
CITATION IS THAT A SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF THEIR- IN ROMAN
DECLINE IS IN THOSE VERY EARLY
GRADES. AS YOU APPRECIATE THAT
CAN BE VERY FRIGHTENING BECAUSE
IF THOSE STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY
GONE- THEN WE WASHED UP FOR THE
NEXT THIRTEEN FOURTEEN YEARS-
BERMAN ROMAN STANDPOINT. WHAT
WE SUSPECT IS THAT THOSE
PARTICULAR GRADES ARE MORE
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC THAN OTHER GRADES
BECAUSE MANY PARENTS. CHOSE
CHOSEN TO LEAD THEIR- KID- AT
HOME AND NOT IN THEM IN
DISTANCE LEARNING OR VIRTUAL
EDUCATION AND SO WHAT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR DISTRICT LIKE ALL
GROVE AND FRANKLY ALL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING A DECLINE
IS TO ENGAGE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY ON A DEEPER BASIS TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THOSE KIDS ARE
THEY NEED TO REACH OUT TO THOSE
SO IF THEY HAVE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND THOSE KIDS DIDN'T
SHOW UP IN TKA- THIS PAST YEAR
THEY'VE GOT THEY KNOW THOSE
PARENTS ARE IN THOSE FAMILIES
ARE THEY CAN REACH OUT TO.
THEIR KINDERGARTEN KIDS IT
DIDN'T SHOW UP BUT THEY WERE
THERE IN TJ THIS PAST YEAR THEY
KNOW WHO THEY ARE- THIS WILL BE
IMPORTANT IN THEIR ANALYSIS
GOING FORWARD BUT IT WILL ALSO
BE IMPORTANT AND HOW THE-
STRUCTURED THEIR INTERVENTIONS
AN INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EXPANDED TIME AND LEARNING-
GRANT WITH RESPECTIVE YOU KNOW
IT. ATTENTIONAL SUMMER SCHOOL
OR SUMMER LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES I WANT TO BE VERY
SPECIFIC IN SUPPORTING GOES
BEYOND THOSE YOUNGER. KIDS-
THIS ARTICLE LEVEL ARE IN
DEVELOP A PRO LEADING INTO NEXT
YEAR- SO. THAT WOULD BE USING
ACRONIS OCCURS IN EXAMPLE BUT
AGAIN I WOULD I WOULD APPLY
THAT NO MATTER WHERE YOU'RE-
WHERE YOU'RE DECLINING IS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN WHETHER
YOU'RE A THAT HAVE BEEN A
DECLINING DISTRICT OR LIKE L.
GROVER GROWING DISTRICT AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN IS EXPERIENCING
DECLINING- THAT CAREFUL
ANALYSIS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
NEEDS TO BE DONE AS YOU
PREPARE. YOUR PLANNING FOR IT-
FOR THIS COMING SEASON. OKAY
THANK YOU AT ONE MORE QUESTION.
LAST YEAR IN THE IN THE PRIOR
YEARS- WE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
FISCAL OVERSIGHT FOR DISTRICTS
AS FAR AS THE THICK MAT PROCESS
WE PUT SOME PIECES IN LAST
YEAR'S- BUDGET IN THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS. IN YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ARE THERE OTHER
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION- SO THIS THIS
PAST YEAR OBVIOUSLY-
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS OF THE
BUDGET GOT INTERRUPTED BY THE
PANDEMIC ARM AND SO WE DID
PROPOSE- FOR THE TWENTY. TWENTY
ONE BUDGET AND NUMBER OF A
TRAILER BILL PROVISIONS- THAT-
WE BELIEVED WOULD STRENGTHEN-
FISCAL OVERSIGHT REALLY IN MOST
CASES BY JUST DOING SOME FINE
pCHANGING THE COR- A BODY OF LAW
AND REGULATION YES- BUT SOME
FINE TUNING THOSE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS GOT STARTED IN
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY- IT WITH
THE RELEASE OF LAST YEAR'S
JANUARY. OF GOVERNOR'S BUDGET-
HOWEVER THEY THEY REALLY GOT-
APPROPRIATELY FRANKLY PUT ON
THE BACKBURNER. WHEN THE
PANDEMIC YET AND SO WHAT YOU
SAW IN. THE FINAL BUDGET ACT IS
WHAT. HI AGREE ON WE- ANY IN
DEPTH CONVERSATION- WE DID NOT
BRING THOSE BACK UP BECAUSE
WE'RE STILL IN THE PANDEMIC I
WOULD HOPE THEY'LL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. BRING SOME OF
THOSE BACK UP AND HAVE MORE IN
DEPTH DISCUSSION- IN THE FUTURE
BUT I PROBABLY WOULD GROUP THE
PENDING ITEMS- IN THREE
CATEGORIES. ONE IS-
STRENGTHENING THE REPORTING OUT
OF COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND- LABOR
AGREEMENTS OR OR OR SHOWER
AGREEMENTS IN BENEFIT
AGREEMENTS AROUND. UNLESS
UNREPRESENTED EMPLOYEES SHOULD
NOT EVEN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
BUT ON REPRESENT IT WELL WE DID
GET A GOOD CONVERSATION ON THAT
STARTED LAST YEAR BUT BUT
SIMPLY WITH THE PANDEMIC.
INTERRUPTED FRUITFUL
CONVERSATION THE SECOND
CATEGORY- IS I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT- WHAT. WHAT
THE BENEFIT IS SERVED BY OUR
CURRENT PROVISIONS FOR FISCAL
INDEPENDENCE IN FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. ARE YOU DO NOT
SEE THAT IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL LAST JANUARY BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF WORKING
ON DATA AND BACKGROUND FOR
THAT. BUT THAT DISCUSSION I
THINK OUR- NEEDS WITH SOME
POINT TO SURFACE- IN AB AND
HAVE A- IN DEPTH CONVERSATION
ABOUT THOSE CATEGORIES OF
DISTRICTS AND WHAT THE REAL
BENEFIT IS TO THOSE- THOSE
CLASSIFICATIONS. AND THEN THE
THIRD WOULD BE- OPTIONS. ARE
SPECIFICALLY IN MY MIND FOR THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT TO
STRENGTHEN THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT'S ROLE WHEN THE
DISTRICT IS NOT PROPERTIES- OUR
CURRENT OVERSIGHT SYSTEM IS
BUILT ON A PROMISE OF
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE
DISTRICT. AND THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT IT'S BUILT ON A
PREMISE BACK IN YOU KNOW THE
NINETEEN NINETIES WITH AB
TWELVE HUNDRED- IT'S BUILT ON
THIS PREMISE THAT. ARE BOTH
PARTIES RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
A PROBLEM- BAND THAT THEY WANT
TO IMPROVE OVER THAT PROBLEM IN
MAKE AND TAKE APPROPRIATE
CORRECTIVE ACTION IN JOINTLY
TOGETHER MOVE DOWN THE PATH.
WHEN WE HAVE A DISTRICT THAT IS
NOT ON BOARD AND WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF THOSE EXAMPLES ARE
THEN THEY'RE FISCAL RECOVERY IS
DELAYED SIGNIFICANTLY- AND THE
CHALLENGE FOR THE ARE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS I'M INCREASES
EVEN MORE. AND SO LOOKING AT
SOME OPTIONS FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
THE DISTRICT DOES NOT- TIMELY-
DOCTOR FISCAL STABILIZATION
PLAN- FOR COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
TO POTENTIALLY A DOCTOR
POTENTIALLY TO PREPARE. AND
IMPOSE IT ON A DISTRICT ISN'T
AS ONE EXAMPLE- SO THOSE WOULD
BE THE THREE CATEGORIES I WOULD
IDENTIFY SAWYER WITH RESPECT
TO- POTENTIAL FOR FUTURE
CONVERSATION. OKAY THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA THAT S.
THANK YOU I'M- STILL IN-
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY EIGHT
ARE DISTRICTS ARE SMALLER AND
WE HAVE BEEN- EXPERIENCING
DECLINE ENROLLMENT THAT IS A
CONCERN- AND I. ACTUALLY THINK
THERE'S ADDITIONAL CONCERN WHEN
IT COMES TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE SEVEN THROUGH THE
TWELVE- PARTICULARLY THIS YEAR
AS IT'S NOW GOING ON A YEAR AS
OF STUDENTS BEING OUT OF
SCHOOL- PARTICULAR ATHLETES WHO
ARE I AM AWARE ARE PLAYING OUT
OF STATE. AND PARENTS ARE
DECIDING THAT IF THEIR CHILDREN
ARE REALLY GOING TO BE ENGAGED
IN ATHLETICS AND ANOTHER STATE
MAY BE- A PLACE FOR THEM TO DO
THAT- THEY'RE DOING THAT NOW.
WOULD IT BE YOUR RECOMMENDATION
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
YOU KNOW EXTENDING AN EXTENSION
OF THE HOLD HARMLESS FOR THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE YEAR.
AND THEN MY SECOND QUESTION-
WHAT WOULD BE THE ADVANTAGES OF
ELEAZAR IF THE STATE REVERSED
OR PAY DOWN THE DEFERRALS MORE
QUICKLY. OKAY ON THE FIRST
TOPIC OF THE I. OF THE SPECIAL
EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS IN PLACE
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC- IF TRULY
WE SEE THE LIGHT AT THE END OF
THE TUNNEL AS THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT. IN HIS COMMENTS
EARLIER THIS MORNING ALLUDED TO
AND I THINK MANY OF US ARE VERY
HOPEFUL FOR- AND WE'RE LEFT
WITH SIMPLY EXCEPTIONS NEXT
YEAR AS OPPOSED TO THE NORM. OF
THE DISTANCE LEARNING IS THE
EXCEPTION- THEN NOW I DON'T SEE
ANY REASON TO CONTINUE AT A
DISTRICTS THAT ARE DECLINING
WILL REVERT BACK TO THEIR
TRADITIONAL EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
STILL BE FOR FUNDING PURPOSES
BE USING AGAIN THERE NINETEEN
TWENTY DATA AS THEY ARE DOING
THIS YEAR BECAUSE IT. YOU'RE
YOU'RE ENTITLED TO. BE FUNDED
ON CURRENT THE HIGHER CURRENT
YEAR OR PRIOR YEAR. IN NEXT IN
THE BUDGET YEAR PRIOR YEAR WILL
BE NINETEEN TWENTY BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT CURRENTLY COLLECTING
I'M AT ANY DATA IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SO THEY'LL HAVE A
WHOLE ANOTHER YEAR IF YOU WILL
AND HOLD HARMLESS- WITH RESPECT
TO THEIR FUNDING BEFORE THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THEIR
DECLINE. ULTIMATELY DISTRICTS
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE DECLINE
THEY HAVETO ADJUST- STAFFING
IN PROGRAMS AND SERVICES A TO
GO HAND IN HAND WITH THE SIZE
OF THE OF THE POPULATION
THEY'RE SERVING- AND SO- I
BELIEVE THAT. THE HOLD HARMLESS
FOR THE PANDEMIC- HAS SERVED
EVERYBODY. HAS SERVED ITS
PURPOSE INSTANCE SERVICE WHILE
ON IN AND THEN MOVING FORWARD
THAT WOULD GO BACK TO THE NORM-
WITH RESPECT TO- OPTIONS FOR
DISTRICTS IT MAY HAVE TO CLOSE
ON A TEMPORARY BASIS- NEXT YEAR
I THINK- JUST GOT HOME. OF
DEPART FINANCE ADDRESS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S- THEY ARE LOOKING
TO. CREATE AN OPTION FOR THOSE
DISTRICTS. TO AGAIN DEAL WITH
THAT EXCEPTION MAY BE CREATED
BY A LOCAL HEALTH- RESTRICTIONS
OUR DECISION TO CLOSE- IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION EITHER
TEMPORARILY OR EVEN A LONGER
TERM- IN THE NEXT YEAR AS PART
OF THIS IS VERY FLUID.
OBVIOUSLY AS AS WE SEE
IMPROVEMENT- AND GO THROUGH THE
SEARCHES AND I THINK
EVERYBODY'S PROBABLY ON THE
SAME PAGE IN THAT WE WE'VE GOT
TO CONTINUE TO BE SOMEWHAT
FLEXIBLE HERE. WITH RESPECT TO
YOUR SECOND QUESTION ON
DEFERRALS ON CASH DEFERRALS
ARE- NOT A POPULAR THING IN THE
FIELD WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SMALLER SCHOOL DISTRICTS THIS
YEAR WITH THE TWO- ARE. OUR
KINSTON SOMETIMES BE HIT
HARDER- BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
HAVE FEWER RESOURCES TO
BALANCE- I THINK DISTRICTS
OVERALL FOR THIS YEAR I GIVEN
THE SIZE OF THE DEFERRALS IN
THE COMPLEXITIES AROUND IT. ARE
MANAGING OUT VERY WELL NOW THAT
YES THEY HAVE YET TO BE A
REALLY IMPACTED BECAUSE THEY GO
INTO PLACE. IN JUST A COUPLE
WEEKS IN FEBRUARY BUT THEY'VE
ALL DONE THEY'RE PLANNING TO
ACCOUNT FOR THAT- THEY DID THAT
IN THE FALL. MOST OF MARIN
TRAINS POOLS OF TAX AND REVENUE
ANTICIPATION NOTE RULES IF YOU
THEIR COUNTIES ARE THROUGH
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION THE
STATE TREASURER DIFFERENT THAN
THE GREAT RECESSION STEPPED UP
AND CREATED A TRANSPORT. THIS
YEAR AND WE- THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IN SUPPORT-
MADE THAT AVAILABLE- TO ALL
TYPES OF DISTRICTS AND THEN
THERE'S ANOTHER PROGRAM-
THROUGH THE TREASURER'S OFFICE
TO SUPPORT. CHARTER SCHOOLS-
SHE CAN ADDRESSES BUT THERE
WASN'T. PROCESS ALSO FOR
DISTRICTS THAT DIDN'T LEAVE
THEY CAN. MANAGE THEIR
DEFERRALS AND WOULD MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA WELL THERE WAS
AN APPLICATION PROCESS FOR.
EXEMPTIONS FROM THE DEFERRALS
AND CD IS BEEN THE ONE ON
MANAGING OUT ALONG WITH
FINANCING AND IN CAN SPEAK TO
THAT. MY SENSE OVERALLS
DISTRICTS HAVE MANAGED IT VERY
VERY WELL- IS THERE A BENEFIT
NOT TO HAVE DEFERRALS YES
THERE'S A BENEFIT NOT TO HAVE
DEFERRALS- I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION- CERTAINLY THEIR
BUDGET PROPOSAL ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT BY PAYING OFF. A
SIGNIFICANT PIECE MORE THAN 70%
OF THE EXISTING TO FOR ALSO-
NOT THE PAIN I'M ALL OFF BUT
THEN NOT CONTINUING- ONE SMALL
ONE PIECE- THE DEFERRALS ARE
COMPLICATED BY A SERIES. OF- A
PROVISIONS ARE EVEN. THAN THEY
WERE TO THE GREAT. WE NOW HAVE
EDUCATION PROTECTION ACT WHICH
CAME ABOUT AS WE EXITED THE
GREAT RECESSION THAT OVERLAYS
THIS AND COMPLICATES THINGS.
ARM AND SO IT'S NOT BEEN THE
EASIEST OF TOPICS CERTAINLY BUT
AGAIN DISTRICTS OF MANAGE VERY
WELL WE HAVE NO DISTRICTS THAT
ARE IN DISTRESS RIGHT NOW. AS A
RESULT OF- THE DEFERRALS. IN IN
THE CURRENT YEAR. THANK YOU. J.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS PROFESSING NONE THANK
YOU MISTER FINE AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY REVISIT THIS ISSUE-
IN THE FUTURE. SO NOW WE WILL
MOVE ON TO OUR PUBLIC COMMENTS
WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE AND
VIA THE PHONE SO IF YOU'RE-
WATCHING FROM HOME- ONLINE IS A
NUMBER UP THEY CAN SEE IT
DREADED TWENTY TO. GO ONLINE.
IS THERE FOCUSING ON THE TO
READ IT OKAY SO YOU SEE THE
NUMBER RIGHT THERE ON THE
SCREEN- YOU CAN CERTAINLY-
THAILAND DO WE HAVE ANYBODY. ON
THE LINE ON TO TESTIFY. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER
AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW OKAY THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN SO WHILE WE
WAIT FOR PEOPLE TO GET IN THE
QUEUE. DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY TODAY. YEAH. THE JUST A
REMINDER FOR THE PUBLIC THERE'S
ONE MINUTE SIXTY SECONDS. ONE
ONE MINUTE OF PUBLIC COMMENT
CARDI WE KEEP READING BUT I'M
WONDERING WHERE O'DONNELL MET
WELL ENOUGH HE'S TIGHT TIME
EXTRA TIME KEVIN MCCARTY IF I'M
ENTERTAINING ENOUGH IS THAT
WHAT YOU SAID TO ME IN THE
RECYCLE HEARING. YOU HAVE A
SINGLE LONG HERE TODAY WITH HER
SIX YEAR OLD SON WITH NO SCHOOL
AND YOU CAN'T BE FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH TO LET HER SPEAK OUT OF
TURN WELL CALIFORNIA DICE WHILE
CHILDREN ARE SHOOTING
THEMSELVES ON ZOOM CALLS WELL
EVERY WEEK SOMEONE TELLS ME
THEY'RE MOVING THEIR FAMILY TO
I DON'T KNOW TO TAX S. JUST
SOUTH CAROLINA. WELL WE HAVE
BILLION UNRESOLVED CLAIMS WITH
EDT AND WE CALIFORNIANS ARE
PAYING FOR THIS KEVIN MCCARTY
IS IT ENTERTAINING ENOUGH FOR
YOU TODAY BECAUSE I DIDN'T
BRING MY ROLLER SKATES. THIS IS
A CALL SHIPPED WHOLE. AND YOU
HEARD IT OFFICIALLY HERE FROM
THE WOMAN YOU SLANDER YOU TRASH
IN THE SACBEE NEWS YOU CALLED
ME A TERRORIST WHEN I'VE BEEN
IN THIS BUILDING A HUNDRED
TIMES MY CHILDREN HAVE BEEN IN
FRONT OF THIS MICROPHONE GIVING
TESTIMONY TO YOU YOU KNOW WHY
DON'T FIRE HEARING I AM A
DISPLACED PERSON FROM THE TUBBS
FIRE. IT'S A ONE MAN THANK YOU
TIME THAT YOU CAN SECONDS. WE
ARE. NEXT BAKER PLEASE JUST TO
REMIND PEOPLE WHO WANT TO CALL
AND I NEED TO READ THE NUMBER
EVEN THOUGH IT'S ON THE SCREEN.
IT IS. 877-692-8957 THE- PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AGAIN
THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IN THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE NOT THAT ANY OF YOU
EDUCATED IDIOTS IN THIS ROOM
THAT I HAVE SPENT. THE LAST
THREE HOURS LISTENING TO
PROBABLY CARES BUT MY NAME IS
STACY FELLOWS I AM A LIFE LONG
THIRTY TWO YEAR CITIZEN OF
SACRAMENTO I AM A STUDENT OF
SAC CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT HAS FAILED ME. I
AM A DROP OUT I PUT MYSELF BACK
THROUGH SCHOOL NOT BY THE HELP
OF SAC CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR ANY OF THE OTHER
**** DISTRICTING CALIFORNIA BUT
I DID IT IN SPITE OF IT AND NOW
I'M- HERE AT THE MOTHER OF TWO.
AND I. HATED TALK ABOUT BEING
BY. HEY COLD. EVERY COME RATE
OF NINETY PER SE. AND ARE
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED YEAH
PERPETUATED THIS. IN THIRTEEN
DAYS WELL I THINK HERE AND
LISTEN TO EDUCATED. TALK ABOUT
SPEND BILL. OKAY I'LL KEEP YOUR
HANDS IN THE CAR BARTEL YOU
WILL BE A PRISON WE WILL
REMEMBER ALL LIVE WHEN YOU TO
THE GROCERY YOU'RE GOING TO
FEEL JUST THE THING COMFORTABLE
IF WE DO WE RIGHT NOW. OKAY
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER. ANYMORE
SPEAKERS FROM THE AUDIENCE OKAY
PLEASE COME UP. HOUSE OF CLOWNS
HOUSE OF CLASSROOMS I GET TO
THOSE RED NOSE. BOB NEXT TIME I
COME. HOW DOES BEING SELF
DESTRUCTIVE MARC HERE FEEL HOW
DOES A LYING EVERY DAY TO THE
PUBLIC FEEL HOW DOES IT FEEL TO
LIVE OFTEN TASTIC LIFE AND YES.
PRETEND TO PLAY THE ROLE OF THE
HOT BUT HONEST PUBLIC SERVANT
WHAT. DOES IT AS. THIS NEW
REALITY THAT IN THE END IT
WOULD ALL ME FOR KNOCKING.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT GIVEN UP
YOU'RE NOT GOING. WE ARE NOT.
CHOOSING TO STAY SILENT WE ARE
NOT GOING TO HIDE NO MATTER HOW
MANY TIMES YOU SLANDER US IN
THE NEWSPAPERS OR ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. I DO NOT CONSENT YOU DO
NOT GET MY BODY TO EXPERIMENT.
ON WITH THIS ALLEGED VACCINE
WHICH IS NOT EVEN A VACCINE IT
IS A SOFTWARE YOU WANT TO HAVE
IT MCCARTY YOU CAN HAVE MY TO I
BET YOU CAN HAVE EVERYBODY ELSE
IS HERE. DELIGHTS YOU ALL SIT
ON LIKE A PRETTY LITTLE MONEY
STUFFED SUITCASE WILL FALL
THANK YOU YOU NEED TO WRAP IT
UP OPEN UP AND EVERYONE WILL
SEE YOUR DIRTY LAUNDRY. BECAUSE
THE TRUTH ALWAYS WINS THANK YOU
I WILL NOT BE INTIMIDATED INTO
SUBMISSION I WILL NOT BE FEAR
MONGER INTO WATCHING WHAT I
SAY. BECAUSE THE TRUTH HURTS
YOU ALL THANK YOUR TIME'S UP.
THANK YOU I GIVE YOU ALMOST TWO
MINUTES TIME'S UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYMORE PUBLIC
COMMON IN THE AUDIENCE BEFORE
YOU GET TO THE PHONE LINE YES
PLEASE COME UP. GALLAGHER FROM
SOMEONE WHO FELL FOR HIS LIES
WHAT. ON THE FACT THAT THE
PUBLIC STILL DOESN'T KNOW HOW
TREMENDOUS OF A SHARE YOU AND
YOUR LITTLE BOOK WRITING KEVIN
KILEY ARE WHAT TIME DO YOU
THINK IT BE APPROPRIATE TO TELL
YOUR FANS THAT DADDY BILL GATES
FROM PLANNED PARENTHOOD SLIDE
TO A COUPLE THOUSAND BENJAMIN
AND- EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE WHEN
ARE YOU GOING TO REVEAL THAT
THE NEWEST MEMBER OF YOUR
FAMILY A LITTLE BLACK LAB NAMED
CHARLIE. IS SUCH A THOUGHTFUL
AND CONVENIENT WAY TO HIDE THE
FACT THAT YOU VOTE LIKE A FACT
RACES ON THE BALLOT. WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO AIR THEIR DIRTY
LAUNDRY OUT THEY GAVE ME THE
TITLE YOU SOLD PROBABLY WHERE
TODAY WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO
COME INTO ONE OF THESE MEETINGS
WEARING. CLOWN MAKE UP TO MATCH
YOUR CHARACTER. WHEN ARE YOU
GOING TO TELL THE TRUTH
GALLAGHER WHAT ALL YOU'RE GOING
TO TELL THE TRUTH. WHAT IT. BE
LIKE TO. WHEN IS ANY PUBLIC
SERVANT THAT. PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO DO THEIR JOB AND STOP LYING
TO US YOU CAN US IS NOT BE BY
THE WAY FOR THE BEST WAY TO GET
BACK TO ME SINCE THEY OBVIOUSLY
KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT ME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE WHO WISHES
TO PARTICIPATE. SEEING NONE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE HE WANTS TO TESTIFY.
THE CHAIRMAN LINE NUMBER TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU PLEASE KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO SIXTY SECONDS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OUT THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION OPERATE- AS MISS
HOLMES- INDICATED WE HAVE BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. OVER THE SCHOOL
REOPENING PLANNED ALTHOUGH WE
ARE STILL CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EXCLUDED FOR NON CULTURE BASED
CHARTER SAID THAT FUNDING
PROPOSAL A LOT OF OUR NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF- ON FLIGHT EDUCATION
AND INSTRUCTION THAT WE THINK
ANYBODY THAT CAN MEET THE
GOVERNOR'S CRITERIA SHULD BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE FUNDS WE
ALSO AGREED TO COMMITTEE
INTEGRATED PALEO ON. THAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION- WE
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND DEPART MANY ASPECTS
OF THE PROPOSED DAHLE- I THINK
WE'VE SHARED WITH YOU ALREADY
OUR CONCERNS REGARDING THE TWO
BILLION FOR RE OPENING I'LL
JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT WHILE THE
SUPPORT ROBACK TESTING FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF- WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH USING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSE-
WE ALSO YOU KNOW SUPPORT EARLY
ACTION TO PROVIDE ACADEMIC AND
OTHER SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS. I
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THAT- AND ONE LAST
THING ON THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
WE APPRECIATE THAT TWO POINT
THREE BILLION- ONE TIME
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT AND URGED
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAINTAIN
THAT LONG TERM COMMITMENT TO
INCREASE PROP NINETY EIGHT-
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET-
AS- MIKE BY NOTED THE OUT YOUR
CRITICAL PROJECTIONS ARE
CONCERNING INFO WITH THE COURT
MAINTAINING THAT. AND I'LL STOP
THERE. THANK YOU AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING AGAIN. LIE
NUMBER FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
JESSICA TACO ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW FOR THE EARLY
ACTION ISSUES YOU'RE
CONSIDERING WE SUPPORT AB TEND
TO REOPEN SCHOOLS ESTIMATES
COMMUNITY HEALTH ALLOWS AN AB
ONE OH FOUR TO ENSURE QUALITY
LEARNING TIME TO ADDRESS
LEARNING LAW. PRIORITIZING
ENGLISH LEARNERS OF ALL AGES IN
THESE PLANTS YOU'RE GOING TO
COMMENT ON THE DECREASE IN THE
LPF EDUCATED COUNT THIS ONLY TO
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS FUNDING FOLLOWING THIS
YEAR THE DECLINE OF NOT A
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT ISSUE BUT
RATHER A DATA ISSUE AND REBEKAH
MAN THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE.
HOME HARM US FOR THE
UNDUPLICATED COUNT. THEY
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED BY.
ALLOW US TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FREE STRUCK. AS A RESULT
PARENTS DID JUST INCOME DATA
FOR L. IN THE PROGRAM. ADDING A
CHALLENGE TO DISTRICTS TO
COLLECT INCOME DATA FROM
FAMILIES IN ANOTHER FORM. WE'RE
DEFERRALS MEAN COURAGE THE
STATE AND TO ALL THE GIRLS NOW
AND NOT WAIT UNTIL NEXT YEAR AS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED. WHICH WOULD
SHORT CHANGE DISTRICT STARTING
NEXT MONTH. I REFER YOU TO OUR
LETTER SUBMITTED YESTERDAY FOR
COMMENT ON THE RANGE OF ISSUES
YOU'VE ADDRESSED TODAY. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS YVONNE
COUNTRY LOOK AT SUBJUGATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS NOT FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT PROPOSAL- FOR
TOP ACTING AGREED WITH HER
COMMENTS RELATED TO THE FACT
THAT POP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING.
SHOULD NOT BE USED FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH COMPONENT OF THE
PLANT. NINETY EIGHT FINE SHOULD
BE RESERVED FOR DIRECT STUDENT
SUPPORT CONSTRUCTION. WHICH I
DESPERATELY NEEDED AT THIS TIME.
SECOND AB HAVE CONCERN. TO THE
EIGHTH MATTER TESTING PEOPLE'S
THE PROPOSED. THE CADENCES
CURRENTLY PROPOSED WILL COME
WITH SIGNIFICANT COST THE
MAJESTICALLY CHALLENGES.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THE ADVOCACY OF THAT PART
WHICH- WE RECOMMEND PROVIDING
ELEAZAR THE ABILITY TO WORK
WITH LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS TO DETERMINE THE BEST
TESTING APPROACH FOR THE
COMMUNITIES. IN LASTLY SCHOOL
LEADERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
HAVE RAISED CONCERNS RELATED TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
AGREEMENT START BARGAINING
REQUIREMENTS WOULD JEOPARDIZE
EQUITABLE STUDENT ACCESS TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. WE
RECOMMEND CONSISTENCY WITH CITY
PH GUIDANCE WHICH STATES THAT
IT MUST BE EVIDENT CONSULTATION
BY PREPARING A COMMUNITY.
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AIR
INDIA BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN THE EQUITY
COALITION WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE DEMONSTRATIONS
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO SAFELY BE
OPEN ALL REPURPOSE THE JOINING
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OPTIONAL
LOCALLY NEGOTIATED SCHOOL RE
OPENING PROPOSAL AND HE TENDS
MANDATORY REOPENING APPROACHED.
THE STATE OF THE DUTY TO
PROVIDE SAFE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION OPTION FOR FAMILIES
AND STUDENTS TO MARKET IT
DISTRICTS ARE UNABLE TO REACH
LOCAL BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
BEFORE THE DESIGNATED DATE.
COULD IMPLEMENTED NEGOTIATED
STATEWIDE RE OPENING STANDARDS
AND ENSURE THAT ALL DISTRICTS
RECEIVE THE NECESSARY FUNDING
GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT TO REOPEN.
ADDITIONALLY THE CATEGORY OF
HIGH NEED STUDENTS IN ALL
GRADES THAT ARE PRIORITIZED FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND INCARCERATED YOU.
WE AGREE THAT EDUCATORS ON
TRACK TO RETURN IN PERSON AND
DOES THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED FOR VACCINATION AND
LASTLY PLAN FOR SCHOOL RE
OPENING AN EXTENDED LEARNING
SUPPORT SHOULD BE DEVELOPED IN
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND SUBJECT TO A
PUBLIC HEARING. WILL REOPEN
CANNOT HAPPEN SUCCESSFULLY
WITHOUT COMMUNITY COLLABORATION
EMPIRE CRITICAL EARLY IN AREAS
HARDEST HIT BY KOBE NINETEEN.
COULD BE COALITION PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL SUGGESTIONS ON RE
OPENING AN EXTENDED LEARNING
THE LETTER SUBMITTED LAST WEEK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
BIGGER. MY NUMBER FIFTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HERE TODAY I
BEHALF OF THE UP WITH THE CAT
PERCENT FOR EQUAL LETTERS. AND
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA JUST WANT
TO START OFF BY THANKING YOU
ALL FOR SUPPORTING FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS THIS
PAST SUMMER I PROMISE WE'LL
FOCUS ON THAT ISSUE- THIS HELPS
ENSURE THAT SCHOOL CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS TO FREE
THE PURCHASE MALES WHILE
SCHOOLS CONTINUE TO BE CLOSED
UNFORTUNATELY STATE FEDERAL
FUNDING ALLOCATED FOR SCHOOL
NUTRITION EXPIRED AT THE START
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR BUT THE
ADDITIONAL EXPENSE OF EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS GOING FORWARD I
THINK THAT THAT EXPIRE.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO FUNDING
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
THIS SCHOOL YEAR TO PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR THESE PROGRAMS A
RECENT SURVEY- OF ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY
THE SCHOOL NUTRITION
ASSOCIATION SHOWS THAT 64% OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCE FINANCIAL LOSSES AND
THE- 200-019-2000 TWENTY AND
84% ANTICIPATE A NET LOSS IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR THANK YOU TIME TO
PUT DEMOCRATS ARE PROJECTED. TO
WRAP IT UP THANK YOU. LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JANE DEFECT ON
BEHALF OF THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND I
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE CALLING IN
SUPPORT AT THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION IN EARLY ACTION FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING AND AB ONE OH
FOUR WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE STAFFORD YOU
GET CRITICAL SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS WHO NEED IT MOST AS
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE. WITHOUT WE URGE YOU
TO ALIGN AND LEVERAGE
CALIFORNIA PUBLICLY FUNDED
AFTERSCHOOL AND SUMMER LEARNING
PROGRAMS AN EXISTING SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
ALSO ASK YOU TO ENSURE THAT
ELEAZAR PARTNER WITH OUR LOCATE
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT EXPANDED LEARNING
INVESTMENTS. AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS HAVE THE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH FAMILIES AND EFFECTIVELY
PARTNER WITH TEACHERS TO
PROVIDE LEARNING SUPPORT THAT
COMPLEMENT SCHOOL DAY
INSTRUCTION WE ALSO ASK THAT
THE FUNDS BE ALLOWED TO BE
SPENT THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
SUMMER AT TWENTY TWENTY Q. AND
LASTLY I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
WHILE EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL TO
RESTARTING SCHOOL IN RECOVERY
THE GOVERNOR'S- BUDGET
PROPOSAL. I HITCHCOCK OF LIFE
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR OTHER
EDUCATION CATEGORICAL STATEMENT
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION AND
EIGHTY PROGRAM I THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
HANDSTAND WILL FOLLOW. UP WITH
THE LATTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME FORTY LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY MONEY I CAN ALL BE ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN ADDITION TO
THE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE IMPACT
OF A DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT AND
ADA ON SCHOOL DISTRICT BUDGET
THE BY COCA COLA TENSION COULD
IMPACT THE DECLINES IN
DISTRICTS INTERPRETATIVE PEOPLE
PERCENTAGE AS I CALLED HER
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN THE AMOUNT
OF LPS. AND SHIELDING FACT FROM
A LOSS OF SIX HUNDRED ENROLLED
STUDENTS THIS YEAR BUT THE
ABSENCE OF A SIMILAR HOLD
HARMLESS AND ACCOUNT OF OUR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TRANSLATE TO A
PROJECTED MARKET APPROXIMATELY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR. WE HAVE TRIED TO IDENTIFY
ALL OF OUR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AS REQUIRED BUT DESPITE OUR
BEST EFFORTS CHALLENGES BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC HAVE LED TO A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN THE
COLLECTION OF NEEDED FORM TO
ACCOUNT FOR A LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ALLOWING DISTRICTS TO
CARRY OVER OUR EDUCATED PEOPLE
PERCENTAGE FROM NINETEEN TWENTY
WILL ENSURE WE ARE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
CRITICALLY NEEDED SUPPORT FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES. THAT MAKE
UP MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF OUR
DISTRICT AND THAT WE KNOW STILL
ATTEND OUR SCHOOLS ARE OUT ARE
AT RISK OF LOSING FUNDING
BECAUSE OF BUREAUCRATIC
CHALLENGES AND COLLECTING THE
REQUIRED. PAPERWORK THANK YOU.
NINE NINE FORTY ONE. THE LINE
IS ALL. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
NUMBERS MY NAME IS KYLE HYLAND
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION FIRST YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THANK AT THE
MEMBER VALLADARES FOR A REASON
THE ISSUES TO DISABILITY DURING
STATE HEARING WE AGREED THAT
FUNDING FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES SHOULD RECEIVE THE
SAME COMPOUND IN CALL AT THE L.
P. AT THAT. AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE DEDICATION OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
WE BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE CURRENT
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
FORMULA INSTEAD OF CREATING A
NEW FUNDING STREAM. AND FINALLY
WE BELIEVE THAT A PORTION OF
THE EXPANDED LEARNING TIME AND
ACADEMIC INTERVENTION GRANT
SHOULD BE CALCULATED A
PRIORITIZED LIST INTO
DISABILITIES ADVOCATES LEARNING
WHAT MEDICATION FONG WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH. YOU ON
THESE ISSUES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE MCKAY
UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION. ATION OF THE OF THE
ACT PASSED THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FUNDING COALITION OF
ADVOCATES FOR ADEQUACY AND
EQUITY AND FUNDING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND WHILE
THIS YEAR MAY NOT BE THE MOMENT
TO ESTABLISH ASPIRATIONAL
TARGETS FOR THE LTFS WOULD
SUPPORT THE ADVENTURE SPOKE. OF
COMPOUND COLA FORM DOES NOT
OFFER FROM AT. HE ALSO BELIEVE
I ACQUIRED. AT THE MOSTLY WITH
THIS SHOULD ALSO YOU THAT THEY
INCOME COMING AT THE CRITICALLY
AND FUNDING STREAM. THE FOCUS
TODAY ON THE- REQUESTED.
ELIMINATION DIFFERENT BEFORE
INVESTING ONE. ARE OUT AND
FINALLY WE COMPANY INCLUDE OF
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD. AB OF LIFE. DURING THE
CALL NINETEEN AND THEN I ALL ON
THE LINE BECAUSE PROPOSED
VIETNAM MEMBER. I THINK ABOUT
O'DONNELL YEAR THANK SO MUCH
FOR YOUR FOLKS AND IT'S- TO.
THE YOU. I NEVER FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TO STILL WORKING FOR SAY
AN ICY. HOME ONE ARE STILL YOU
CAN GET THE. NUMBER NGUYEN.
UNDER MORNING. YES BECAUSE
REDUCING WITH YOUR A TENER
RITUAL HOW DARE YOU GO CALL
TERROR IS OKAY YOU GUYS UP SHOT
ALL RIGHT YOU GUYS ARE LOOKING
FOR A WOMAN. YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO US ALL WE WILL NOT BACK HE
ALL WITH YOUR G. THERAPY. YOUR
VIRUS FREE DO YOU THINK THERE.
WE WILL NOT PARTICIPATE IN YOUR-
ATTENDED TO. YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO DO ALL THE CHILL MEN. IS THE
I WEARING. THIS IS SO SHOWS
THAT. DON'T THREATEN ME IN PART
TO HIM WE ARE PART. IN WE ARE.
IN YOU WILL. SEEK. IN LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY TRISTEN BROWN
CFT UNION SUCH CATERS A
QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS BOB
DOLE LINER COMMENTS WITH OUR-
PARTNERS AT CTA BUT ALSO JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT- THE
MEMBERS TO SEE IF HE'D DO MISS
OUR STUDENTS WE WANT TO BE BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM. HOWEVER MUST
BE DONE- IT MUST BE- SURGICAL
AND BE SAFE FOR OUR STUDENTS
THEIR FAMILIES AND EDUCATION
STAFF. ONE HIGHLIGHT THE
DISTANCE LEARNING DOES NOT
MEAN. THAT SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED I
KNOW THIS IS KIND OF COMMONLY.
THROWN OUT THERE AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE SITUATION BUT THERE
ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
EDUCATORS AND SUPPORT STAFF
STILL MAKING LEARNING. HAPPENED
AS WELL AS MEAL DELIVERY
HAPPEN. AND THEY NEED MORE HELP
IN EFFORT TO PROVIDE TARGETED
INTERVENTIONS FOR STRUGGLING
STUDENTS. AND WE DON'T THINK
THAT THE SCIENCE IS ACTUALLY
CONCLUSIVELY SAY THE COSTUMES
ARE SAFE THEY'RE VERY OF
STRANGE ABOUT THE U. K. IN
BRAZIL THAT ARE IN OUR STATE
ARE POTENTIALLY MORE
INSPECTIONS. ARE KEEPS RATES
ARE STILL HIGHER THAN WHEN WE
KNEW IT WAS THE BEST APPROACH
TO LIMIT HUMAN CONTACT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. STUDIES
ARE SHOWING THAT YOUNG CHILDREN
HAD BEEN SILENT SUPER SPREADERS
OF THE VIRUS AND META ANALYSES
HAVE SHOWN. THAT THE SECOND
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO END A
PANDEMIC IS TO KEEP DISTANCE
LEARNING MODELS AND NOT RETURN
TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
PREMATURELY. FOR THE MORE DATA
FROM OTHER STATES ARE SHOWING
TO TEACHERS ARE HAVING A HIGHER
RATE OF INFECTION THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION AND
INSPECTIONS FOR STUDENTS IS
ALSO ON THE RISE WHICH IS CAUSE
FOR ALARM. THERE ARE OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE MOST RECENT
GUIDANCE. DOCUMENT THAT ALSO-
JOHNSON HOLES IN TESTING
REQUIREMENTS AND ALLOW FOR
FOLKS TO BE MUCH CLOSER TO ONE
ANOTHER THAN WHAT IS COMMONLY
REFERRED EIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN. TO HAVE THESE THINGS
WEEK THE REPORT. THANKS MY
NUMBER FIFTY THREE. YOUR LINE
IS. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME'S JESSICA BROWN I'M A
PARENT I HAVE TO STUDENTS THAT
ARE- ELEMENTARY AND MIDDLE
SCHOOL STUDENT PARA CALIFORNIA.
AND I AM CONCERNED WHERE THE-
WHOA THE BREAKDOWN FROM YOU
KNOW THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE PEOPLE
AT- LAST YEAR I WENT TO A KID
MEETING FOR MEDIC CAL. AND
CHILDREN AND- PAYING FOR SPEECH
SERVICES- AND HOW MEDICARE HOW
WAS FUNDING THOSE- SERVICES AT
THE SCHOOL LEVEL. AND I WAS
ASKING FOR DOCUMENTATION TO
PROVE THAT TESE CHILDREN WERE
ACTUALLY GETTING SERVICES THAT
WERE ACTUALLY HELPING THEM AND
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT WAS NOT
AVAILABLE NOTHING. THE DIRECTOR
OF MEDIC HAL SAID WE WILL PAY
ANY BILL THE SCHOOL FINANCE WE
DON'T CARE IF THEY LEARN
ANYTHING OR NOT. WE JUST PAY
WHAT WERE ASKED TO PAY. SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID. HOW THAT NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN THIS TIME I
HAVE A CHILD WHO'S IN MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND IS READING AT FOURTH
GRADE LEVEL IN FACT REPORT
DATED NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST HAD AFTER SCHOOL
TO PROVIDE MY SAID WHEN
MEDIATION FOR READING ITSELF
AGAIN TONIGHT TO HEAR NOW NO
REDUCE ARMS OF MY SON HAD MADE
THEIR OWN GAMES AND READING HER
DYSLEXIA MARC HAS A HIGH I.
WHICH YOU HAVE THE INTELLIGENCE
OF BUT AVERAGE BUT BECAUSE OF
HIS THE FLEX HE IS NOT ABLE TAP
INTO HIS ABILITY HE IS STILL
NOT BE A PROVIDED I WOULD LIKE
A REALLY COOL. OUTLINES WHAT
FROM ADD HOW IS ANY FUNDING FOR
MEDIC LAW FOR TECH WHATEVER YOU
PREFER HOW IS THAT GOING
ACTUALLY REACHED PEOPLE THE
KIDS MY DAUGHTER MY NEIGHBORS
NINE MY NEIGHBOR'S DAUGHTER HOW
ARE THE KIDS ACTUALLY GOING TO
BENEFITS AND REAP THE HARVEST
THAT WE CARE SO MUCH ABOUT
THEIR LIFE THAT WE WANT TO
PROTECT THEM FROM A VIRUS AND
PROTECT THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
FROM A VIRUS. BUT WE ARE
ACTUALLY INVESTING IN THEIR
EDUCATION AND THEIR ACTUALLY
REAPING THE BENEFITS THERE IS
NO JUSTIFIABLE TO USE BY MY
SIDE THE SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
HEY YOU KNOW HEY WE NEED TO
REDUCE INTERVENTION AND EIGHTH
GRADE BASKETBALL TO NINETY
GRADE STILL READING AT WORK
GRADE LEVEL. SO THIRD LEG DOWN
DATA AND WE NEED TO FIX IT AND
WE NEED A QUICKER I. WHY AREN'T.
THE CARE INTO THAT WE HAVE WITH
THEM THANK YOU THANK YOU HAVE
TO ASK YOUR WRAP IT UP TO TIMES
UP THANK YOU. MY MEMBERS. FOR
YOUR MIND OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT WHY NUMBER. SIXTY YEAH. GET
OUT MY IS BILLY YOU ARE THE END
OF THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S BUT
CLEAR INCOME. AS THEY DID NOT
IS THAT IT DOES NOT TAKE INTO
THE ALREADY OF THAT CRIME FOR
DIRECT SCHOOL SUPPORT INTO LAW
DECEMBER. THE THUNDER
AUTHORIZED FOR USE MUCH OF WHAT
IS BEING FOR THE TO BE FOR
POINT SIX BILLION PER TO ENTER
PLAN. WE THE LEGISLATURE.
REQUIRE DIRECTIONS. OF ALL NON
FEDERAL FUNDS WITH YOU ANY.
JOHN FUND FOR. THEN WE- THE
LARGEST TAKE. ACTION TO OUR ALL
FOR ALL. THIS YEAR FLEXTRADE
THAT FUNDING FOR NEW COMPARE
RELATED REOPENING LEARNING LOS
OF WORK. AND FINALLY PROGRAM
I'M COMMITTEE WANT A LONG
PROPER NINE EIGHT BASED ON YOUR
PRIORITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR SEAH. X. MY NUMBER BY NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS NICOLE BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATE SEN. AS YOU
CONTAINER. PLANS TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS I WANT TO RAISE THE
PRICE OF THAT IS HAPPENING NOW
AS A RESULT OF THE SCHOOL
CLOSURE AMONG THE CHILD CARE
FIELD. WE APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION ABOUT IN ONE LOW
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE AND BE ABLE
TO USE FEDERAL DOLLARS. I DON'T
FEEL ALSO WOULD LIKE THAT
ANSWER EVEN NOW DALY I RECEIVE
UPDATES THE DATABASE NOTIFYING
ME THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING ON HAND TO
MAKE PROVIDER PAYMENT AND IT
ANY TIME THANK YOU JUST A
MOMENT OF POTENTIAL WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA'S WALKED OVER 20% OF
HIS CHILD CARE CAPACITY SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN FAMILY CHILD
CARE CENTER AT STATE OPEN TO
SUPPORT CENTER WORKERS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED. OF EITHER
HAD TO MAKE PURCHASES TO HELP
FORGET THE BURNING PROVIDERS
THAT PUT THEIR SAFETY FIRST.
CLOSER TO THE MAIN THE CAT CARE
THAT THE- BY MINDED TO WORK THE
THIRD MORE. FOR OUR WAITING
LIST THIRTY PS IDENTIFY. AND WE
HAVE LOTS CARE TO SUPPORT THEM.
PRIOR TO PANDEMIC OF IT YOU
KNOW EACH HAVE BEEN ACCESS TO
CARE. THAT THE BAD IT'S ABOUT.
MINUS DOT THAT. FUNDS FEEL WITH
SIXTY SEVEN. FIVE THE CURRENT
PROPOSED WILL ASK FOR COMMUNITY
PROGRAM TO DEATH ROLE A SIX.
THANK YOU YOUR ATTENTION THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. OPERATOR HOW
MAY BE HAVE A LOT STILL. WE
HAVE TWO PEOPLE THE YOU NEXT.
WELCOME THE GERMANS BY NOW
SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO LINE OF THE-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW MISTER
CHAIRMAN PAMELA K. BUT THE LAW
ANGELES COUNTY WITH. WITH
PERSPECTIVE THE COMMITTEE THE
RIGHT DISCUSSION BECAUSE THE
TWO DOLLAR IN. FOR THE
IMMEDIATE ACTION. WE KNOW THAT
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE HE BUT WE
APPRECIATE DID MANAGE. AND
LEGISLATURE AT FROM IN. TO
INVEST IN AND CLOSED STUDENTS.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION DOWN THE FOR. AND
THE OF THE FOLKS. DOES OF
BENEFIT FROM THE OPTION AND
JOKING. SUPPORT FOR THIS I.
SUPPORT SIX BILLION DOLLAR FOR
EARLY ACTS CLIP ARE IMPORTANT.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR LOOKING
INTO DOING THAT AT FOUR PLAN
ASPEN. WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE IN DISTRICTS AND LOST
COUNTY AND DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH TO OPEN SCHOOLS. AND WE
WANT TO STAY GOODNESS. EIGHTY
AND MY STAFFERS CONTENT SUPPORT
AND- DURING THE TIME THANK YOU
YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION THANK
YOU TIMES AT A JUST NOW WILL BE
THE LAST. SPEAKER WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE TO
JOURNEY TO OUR CAUCUSES YOU
LAST BIGGER. MY NUMBER SEVEN
ONE YOUR MIND IS OPEN PLEASE
CALL THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GERAGOS AGAIN REPRESENTS THE
HEALTH SO. PROVIDING AT THE AND-
TOGETHER. MY COMMENTS ARE. TO
THE TO. IN FOR TO. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF OFFER AND FOR
INSTRUCTION FOR YOUNGER
STUDENTS STUDENTS WITH PINE.
ENGLISH LEARNERS TO SHOULD ALSO
BE INCLUDED THE COLD OF
IDENTIFY FOR THE FUNDING.
ENGLISH LEARN LIKE SPECIAL AT
ALL PEOPLE'S HOME AND- YOU HAVE
NAY ARE NOT OLD. BY DISTANCE
LEARNING SUCH AS BORA IN THE-
ENGLISH LANGUAGE THE- AND
MENTAL IF ANY AND PER IN OUR-
WITH. FOR FURTHER PLAN ABOUT.
PLEASE EXPLICITLY INCLUDE
ENGLISH LEARNERS HE K. THROUGH
GRADE TWELVE IN. THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE THE PART IS TODAY
WITH THAT OUR HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.